that's correct and that was left mainly
to the city manager Steve kanalakis and
others within the city is that right yes
okay
I understand that you had a briefing
with former Chief slowly and Mr
kanilakis on the 26th to talk about what
to expect in terms of the Convoy's
arrival so this is now before the
arrival of the Convoy is that that's
right yes
and can you tell us what the chief told
you in terms of what to expect
well uh the information was not
particularly clear no one had a real
sense of how many vehicles were coming
whether they were going to stay a long
period of time what their actual plan
was there was a sense on the the chief
indicated that the group was somewhat
disorganized and did not speak with one
voice
and in terms of scope scale number of
vehicles number of protesters can you
give us a sense for what you were told
that they were coming from three
different locations the West the East
and Central Canada
to convene on on or near
Ottawa and that they were upset with the
mass mandates which were primarily as
you know a provincial matter but they
were upset with the federal government
as well
and did he give a sense for how long you
could expect them to be in Ottawa
uh my recollection was that uh they
would be here for one or two days that
was the norm you know a lot of people
protest in our city and our police do a
very good job of controlling and
managing the situation and to the best
of my knowledge we never had a protest
in the 25 years I've been in public
service that lasted more than a couple
of days and then they gathered their
signs and placards and and went back
home so it was one or two days was the
sense that you got from the chief in
terms of how long the Convoy would be in
Ottawa yeah there was a bit of a moving
agenda for the organizers of the Convoy
because at one point they had I believe
Mr burnier wanting to speak and then he
was able to come on the Fridays or the
Saturday and then it was pushed back a
day so there seemed to be some
challenges that they were having as to
who was going to speak and when they
were going to speak and that prolonged
it my view at the time was that it would
probably last a couple of days my
understanding was most of these truckers
were independent and if they weren't on
the road doing
business and Pickups they were losing
money so that they would in fact go home
on Saturday or Sunday and obviously that
did not happen right and the chief
didn't give you any indication that it
would be other anything other than the
weekend
no we didn't have any indication we had
uh
we had a a memo or an email from Steve
Ball the hotel association indicating
that one of the organizers had come in
inquired about
a long-term booking of 30 plus days at a
number of hotels they wanted I think
nine to ten thousand hotel rooms and did
that concern you at all
well
um
it did except uh you know when you're
making a booking you have to have some
evidence you're going to follow through
with it so simply asking about booking
11 000 rooms when the city only has
about 11 000 rooms it's at its disposal
the tourism industry
um I don't think I don't think most took
it seriously for the simple reason that
there is no follow-up it was simply
asking
um about rooms and room availability and
rates I suppose and then uh it didn't
really go anywhere because uh my
understanding is the bulk of the people
with large rigs stayed in their cabs
they didn't need hotels
and so in your discussions with Chief
slowly on the 26th was there any
discussion about what would be done in
the event that the protesters decided to
stay longer than a couple of days
uh I don't recall any other discussion
on that at that point okay
point
the term occupation in your
correspondence uh at what point did you
determine that this was no longer a
protest
City are very used to handling large
protests and large visits of State
leaders and so on but nothing of this
magnitude has ever been seen quite
frankly in any City that I'm aware of in
Canada in the last 25 years so is it
fair to say by Monday the 31st after
that first weekend when the the majority
of the of the trucks were still there
that that's when you determined that
they were not going to leave anytime
soon
uh thereabouts either whether it's the
Monday or the Tuesday and then certainly
that was solidified in my mind that they
weren't going to leave on the weekends
when the weekends start at two
uh create this very tense situation
where people were coming in from all
over
the region in fact different parts of
the country to come and support the
protesters and that's where the havoc
and the chaos was created
in our communities and was there ever
ever a discussion that you had with
either Chief slowly or the deputy Chiefs
about blocking access to the additional
convoys that were coming that second
weekend to join the original protest
I I don't recall being in any meeting
when that was discussed did you raise
the issue
um my my bigger concern at that time
from recollection was what can we do to
ensure that the trucks don't go into the
residential areas
because we knew that the impact that
would have because we'd seen in the
first couple of days the constant horn
honking and they had some train whistles
on some of the trucks and there was just
a unruly behavior on the part of these
people who'd come and basically occupied
our downtown so it wasn't a concern that
there were additional convoys that were
coming to join to kind of expand the
footprint of the original Convoy well I
think there was concern absolutely
because when you saw hundreds and then
it turned out to thousands of people
arriving with different pickups and 18
wheelers and so on that this was going
to be bigger than any of us had imagined
okay but there wasn't a discussion to
try and prevent that from happening uh
not in my presence to the best of my
recollection right
now I
would document which is a readout of a
call that you had with the Prime
Minister on January 31st and it's
ssm.can.nsc Dot
402812
and so you had a call with the Prime
Minister on the 31st is that right
that's correct and how did this this
call come about did he reach out to you
or did you reach out to him
uh to be honest I don't recall whether
it was me to him or him to me
um I'm not sure if we can just make that
bigger so we can see
okay so you say hi and as we know these
are summaries of of the call it's not
transcript but it gives you a sense for
what's being said
um and if we go to
uh right so JW is when you're speaking
PM is when the prime minister is
speaking and so the second thing a
second section there before the redacted
portion the second sentence uh third
sentence you said these people had their
time and need to move on we have been
trying to get this across to the chief
of police do you see that yes and when
you say these people are you speaking
about the protesters that's correct
and you say we have been trying to get
this across the chief of police so this
is now Monday the 31st um so right after
the first weekend and so what
discussions did you have with the chief
of police about this issue about letting
them or asking them to move on
well I was interested in what the plan
of action from the police was going to
be in order to clear out the downtown
core because my sense was that this was
not shrinking in size as people started
to go back home it was growing in size
so everyone could see that and um I you
know I stress to the police as you know
we can't direct the police and what to
do but certainly in conversations I have
with Chief slowly he understood very
well the importance of
getting this situation resolved sooner
than later because it would grow into a
bigger issue so you had discussions
achieved slowly over that weekend or on
the Monday
uh sometime in that period I don't know
if it was a Sunday or Monday but you
know I was in contact almost on a
regular basis with someone from the
police service when I was the chief for
the deputy
Bell and so at some point you told him
it's time to move on we need to get
these people out of here is that right
uh no I can't as I said I can't direct
the police but certainly I asked the
questions
um you know what is the game plan to
move forward and uh he's the chief said
that they're uh they're working on one
and I relay that to the Prime Minister
he the Prime Minister wanted to get a
sense of what was going on on the ground
and how this was affecting our city in
particular our residential community and
the small business Community because as
you know we just got out of the lockout
from covet and restaurants and
businesses could start opening and then
all of a sudden we have another lockdown
imposed really by The occupiers Who came
here to disrupt our quality of life
and at the bottom there if we can just
move it up a little bit
uh nope sorry at the bottom yeah it says
the turning point so right after the
redacted portion you say the turning
point is the Terry Fox statue the tomb
Shepherds of Good Hope people just can't
fathom how this is acceptable
and so you're referring to the
incidences that took place over the
weekend with respect to the war National
war memorial and the Terry Fox statue is
that right yeah I think what what was
happening was disgraceful we had some
people dancing on the Tomb of the
Unknown Soldier we had other people
urinating at the cenotaph we had a group
that went and stole meals from the
Shepherds of Good Hope we had and the
Mandate placards put on the Terry Fox
statue it was completely despicable
behavior on the part of these
individuals we welcome protesters who
are respectful of the law and respectful
of our communities the vast majority of
these people and that kind of behavior
were not being respectful and I think
we're hurting their cause quite frankly
when you saw you know the Shepherds of
Good Hope who does such good work in the
in Lower Town in the byward market
having people bully their way in to get
a free meal
that was just abort
and um
further down you say chief of police
said it's so volatile but kept under
control so far trucks are starting to
leave but some die hards chained
themselves to this unfortunate for
people living in residential
neighborhoods they just doing themselves
a disservice which is what you just said
right now chief of police spoke to Chief
lucky and we need a few more sources can
you explain this last part chief of
police spoke to Chief lucky
and we need a few more sources well I
think it's um I should say commissioner
lucky and a few more resources I think
they just left off re okay and so what
was the discussion then and what was a
discussion around this point then
we need our Police Service on its own uh
was completely outnumbered we could not
deal with it just as an Ottawa Police
Issue we needed the support of the other
orders of government
so you were aware that she slowly had
reached out to commissioner Lucky by
this time
um to ask for more resources is that
right yes and so by the Monday it was
clear that Ops did not have the
resources that it needed to handle this
demonstration is that right that's
correct
and so um
in this call there were no specific
requests for assistance from uh you
requesting from the prime minister or
the Prime Minister offering anything
specific back to you is that right
well I I did relay the fact that we
needed more resources and that once we
had the number because at that point
early on we did not have the exact
number that she slowly required to clear
out
uh the the individuals in Center Town
Lower Town Overbrook Forbes as well as
the Byron Market but it was very clear I
made it very clear and the Prime
Minister fully understood that the RCMP
were going to have to be involved they
obviously have a very significant
presence in Ottawa in any event
um responsible for
VIP security and public buildings and so
on right okay so if we just go to the
last page then just to kind of see how
the call ends off
um and it's the Prime Minister says the
remainders will have no choice but to
incite as a counterbalance so we all
have to be careful
um we really appreciate your support of
cities thank you for your steadfast
leadership and your whole team and so
that was the end of the call there
that's great all right and if I can take
you to Ott 3855
and this is a February third email that
you sent to city council to update them
uh it looks like on the the efforts of
the city
that's correct and this is now uh
Thursday before the second weekend
and you indicate uh that you had a call
with the Prime Minister on the 31st if
we just go down a little bit
yeah
um so and then in that third paragraph
you say this morning the city solicitor
and I had a discussion with the team
from GoFundMe to request that the funds
raised so far remain Frozen until the
end of the occupation
um can you explain how the discussion
with GoFundMe came about and and what
action was taken
well as you know the GoFundMe campaign
by the organizers was very successful it
was Raising millions of dollars and and
that was I think one of the reasons why
more people started to arrive thinking
they would get a cut of that money for
their gas and mileage and food and so on
and if they needed places to stay and so
I was approached at some point in that
in that time frame from the the
consulting firm that represented
GoFundMe in Canada
to see if I'd be amenable to having a
meeting with senior GoFundMe people to
discuss and to let them know that the
funds they were collecting were very
much harming our city and um in my
opinion
um engaged in illegal activities
so the meeting was arranged and we had
um
a number of people on the call they'd
also spoken I believe earlier in the day
or after my call with uh I think it was
Chief Bell so he gave them a more
detailed situational report as to what
was happening in our city and why we
felt that these funds should be Frozen
and ultimately sent back to the
individuals because those dollars were
keeping the
the Convoy
going and what happened after that
meeting
well uh Joe I can tell you during the
meeting they I think they underestimated
how big an issue this was and I told
them this was certainly hurting their
reputational
or their reputation because they were
funding a group that was very much
involved in activities that were harmful
to our city and our country
and I can't recall the exact time but a
few days later I believe there was a
decision by GoFundMe to freeze the funds
and I lauded them for doing that and
were there any subsequent calls after
the initial call with GoFundMe did you
have any more discussions uh I don't
believe I did whether someone my staff
did that may have been the case or with
their consultant but um they also I
believe started to send the money back
to individuals
and so um if we look at the following
paragraph it says in the last hour I had
a very good discussion with Federal
Public Safety Minister Marco Mendicino
where I reiterated our City's call for
additional resources to support our
officers responding to this
demonstration on the ground
he assured me that our request for
assistance was being given the highest
consideration by commissioner lucky and
he offered his ongoing support until we
see an end to the occupation so by this
time February 3rd that's the language
you're using there and when you say you
reiterated the city's call for
additional resources when did you make
the original call for resources because
this is February 3rd and you're
referring to reiterating the call for
resources are you referring to the 31st
call with the prime minister or was
there another call for resources between
the 31st and February 3rd
well the very first time that I had
asked for additional resources was with
the Prime Minister on that phone call
and he was he understood completely the
situation we're in he lives in Hondo
obviously and he was seeing firsthand
the challenges our city was facing so he
was the first person that I contacted
um this call with Marco Mendocino or
Minister Mendocino
um I may have had another phone call
with him I can't recall but certainly he
was very very well aware that we needed
additional resources
he asked how many I said that's being
worked on by our chief of police and I
also um indicated that we were going to
reach out to the opp as well and that
Chief slowly who had very good contacts
with Municipal leaders would reach out
to Municipal police forces as well and I
certainly called a number of my mayor
colleagues across the country bringing
them up to speed on what was happening
and said that you may be getting a call
from your chief of police and we hope
that you can help us during this
difficult time and the municipal police
forces were very very responsive and um
we appreciate their their support and
our time of need so in terms of a
specific request for resources this
February 3rd call with Minister
Mendocino would have been the first time
that you asked for resources from other
than the January 31st call which was not
as specific this would have been the
request that you made for additional
RCMP officers yeah I I don't want to
mislead you I may have had another call
beforehand but I I can't recall and I
don't have notes to that effect but we
may have had another call but certainly
this call and this memo that I sent to
colleagues on city council was to deal
with the immediate and the short term
and the long term and if you just scroll
down one of the other parallel
discussions I was our school up around
there parallel discussions I was having
was with um the provincial Minister of
Finance as well as the treasury board
president Mona Fortier and Peter Beth
and Falvey because we knew that a number
of businesses were going to be severely
impacted and we needed to receive not
only officers to bring the situation
under control but in the midterm we
needed financial support to help those
businesses that were suffering and were
there at this time by February 3rd
provincial discussions with the
provinces beyond the assistance to the
businesses that you've discussed any
other requests for for assistance other
than that
well at some point I know uh Chief
slowly would have been in touch with his
counterpart at the opp sorry I mean with
respect to your your discussions or your
requests
uh I may have had a i at one point I had
a discussion with Minister Lisa MacLeod
and indicated to her we needed support
and she was very
appreciative of of the situation and she
said she would relay that back to her
colleague the solicitor general and what
kind of support were you uh were you
looking for in that discussion boots on
the ground OBT officers OPP and RCMP but
to the province of course OPP yes okay
and do you know in that call with Lisa
McLeod took place I don't recall it was
sometime in that general area of when
the the memo went out okay and so her
response was we'll take it I'll take it
back yeah she she was uh very helpful
because she too lived in Ottawa and she
was seeing firsthand I think one of the
the challenges that we face with this is
that people who live away from where
this uh terrible situation was taking
place didn't really have a full not
everyone but some didn't have a full
appreciation for how
horrific this situation was we have
about 18 000 people that live in these
areas this is not just Parliament Hill
this is Center town this is the byword
market it's Lower Town vanity overworked
forums having an impact on a wider part
of the city and I think you know people
started to realize this was turning into
a very volatile situation
when we started seeing fireworks going
off and hot tubs brought in and the
behavior I told you about those four or
five incidents and you know the public
who were living here understood fully
that this was a horrific situation and
the sooner it got resolved the better it
was for everyone yeah and uh at the at
the bottom as well if we see the end of
the of the letter there a number of
colleagues have suggested to me and I
have agreed that a special counsel
meeting be called to discuss the impact
of the truck Convoy demonstration on our
residents and businesses the clerk will
be issuing a notice a special meeting
before the weekend for the meeting to be
held on Monday February 7.
um
so and and eventually
um a special meeting was convened for
the seventh
um why was that not convened sooner than
the seventh it seems that by the seventh
you're almost 10 days into into this
situation
well a number of factors availability of
um individuals that the council wanted
to speak to with no sense in having a
meeting of counsel if the chief wasn't
there or that Steve canalakis wasn't
available this seemed to be a date that
worked well everyone was working around
the clock literally trying to resolve
the situation and one of my objectives
was to try to minimize
the number of opportunities that we
dragged the police chief and his senior
command in because they had work to do
back at their operations center
and so uh this was a date that appeared
to work for almost everyone and that was
the date the clerk circulated the notice
about
and um
Declaration of the State of Emergency on
February 6th
um and I'm going to take you to ott4231
and this is the Declaration of the state
of emergency that you issued is that
right that's correct okay and uh why why
was this done on February 6th what was
the Tipping Point uh or the reason why
it was necessary at this point in time
well I I there are a lot of people
asking up to that point including
members of council and members of the
public and members of the media why
didn't we declare a state of emergency
on the first weekend uh there's a little
bit of a urban myth or misconception
about what a municipal state of
emergency it has very little impact on
Public Safety it really is an
administrative tool that allows the city
for instance to bypass the procurement
policy of the city of Ottawa a good
example is during the pandemic I
declared a state of emergency and
allowed us to go and get personal
protective equipment without going
through a tender process of the top
three and so on so it made those kinds
of decisions quicker it allowed the city
manager to take people from One branch
of a city in a different Collective
Agreement and move them into another
area we needed people for instance to uh
administer needles and do covid-19 tests
and you know if you had a job that was
not essential to that we needed extra
people so
um I think it was um in some ways to
give some comfort to the public that yes
we consider this an emergency but uh we
were constantly explaining and trying to
allow people to understand that this
really did not have any impact on the
overall removal of of individuals but
beyond the potential measures that were
made available to you as a result of
this declaration it's also as you say an
important signal or it's symbolic in a
way and it allows others to understand
that the city considers that it is
beyond the capacity of the city to deal
with the emergency
yes but on every occasion that I've
declared a state of emergency it's been
on the advice of our city manager and
the city manager brought this to me at
that time and we
we had the clerk draft the resolution
and I signed it did you seek advice
prior to February 6 as to whether you
should declare a state of emergency I
would have mentioned to Steve K let me
know when you think it's necessary and
um
you know he came to me I can't remember
the exact date it was probably the day
before this it was signed and um on
January 15th I guess no it's late in
that uh and it was um it was on his
advice and the clerk prepared the
document and I signed it and released it
to the public and so what discussions
did you have with Steve kanalakis about
using this as a way to engage the
province foreign
well I think there was some discussion
uh with my chief of staff and Steve
catalakis that there was a
this may act as a catalyst to get the
other two orders of government to move I
didn't see it that way but they they
felt it might act to push the province
to do their own declaration and to put
more pressure on the province to come to
the table okay so if I can take you to
ont311
it's a summary call between Canada
Ontario and the City of Ottawa and I
believe this is
um what they would refer to as a
situational awareness meetings and if we
can just zoom into that
and so Steve kanalakis is present at
this meeting along with Deputy Minister
Rob Stewart and others and it says there
it's attributed to him Steve kanalaka
city manager from Ottawa provided an
update from the city's perspective and
and bold their Ottawa mayor Jim Watson
is going to declare a local emergency in
the city of Ottawa at 4 30 PM the
expressed intent of this declaration is
to put pressure on the premier to
exercise powers to resolve this
um based on what you've said you've said
that this was mainly for procurement
um is this bolded sentence overstated or
was that the express intention of
declaring the state of emergency no my
understanding was it it was Mr Cadillac
has felt that this was would be helpful
to uh prod the province into being more
Hands-On in the situation I didn't
happen to see it that way but I'm not
disputing the fact that I believe it did
help because of later on in this crisis
The Province did declare a state of
emergency under their provincial powers
and the federal government run and of
course the emergencies act so did the
city consider that the province wasn't
engaged enough in finding a solution
that's correct and why was that
well uh Minister Blair
suggested that we have a tripartite
table where the federal provincial
municipal government elected leaders
could get together share information
bring forward any new information that
we should have at our disposal
and the province rejected that they
didn't feel it was necessary to have
three orders of government at the
political level to have this table
okay and so when you say that or when
you you deemed that the province wasn't
doing enough it was because they weren't
uh coming to the to this tripartite
table is that right well a couple of
things they weren't coming to the table
and we were having
difficulty uh convincing the provincial
officials the need to have a significant
more OPP officers on the ground for two
reasons first of all at some point it
was going to have to be a police
operation to clean out Wellington Street
and the the adjoining communities
uh and that was uh it was important uh
and um secondly uh the um
uh we needed the province on board
because uh you know as you know
municipalities are the creature of the
The Province we don't have all the
powers that people think we do as mayor
or as Council and we need to show a
united front that all of us are
legitimately concerned about the
challenges facing our residential
communities our business small business
community and we needed to move forward
and um so yes it was frustrating uh that
the province was not as
responsive I can say though In fairness
once they did get engaged they were very
good partners the opp was very helpful
but it was getting to that stage and as
I mentioned I believe in our interview
uh the solicitor generals seem at the
provincial level seem to
believe
um that there were 1500 OPP officers
on the ground which was not true at all
and I checked with our our police
officials I said how many OPP today and
they said 50 to 55
so they're the solicitor general kept
repeating that there were 1500 police
officers you'd know if there are 1500
OPP offices you would see them yeah
there weren't okay and we'll get to the
to that in a second but I just wanted to
point out that the tripartite meetings
took place on February 7th 8th and 10th
so on the 6th of February which is this
uh which is this meeting here that would
not have been a reason to want to engage
The Province because those tripartite
meetings had not taken place yet so yeah
well there were tripartite meetings at
the staff level and there were there was
the tripartite group we tried to get
together with the federal ministers uh
mendocini and Blair and myself and we
hoped uh Minister Jones Okay so we're
gonna
um we'll we'll look at those in a minute
um
further down it says
the mayor is what Jim Watson is feeling
the pressure and wants this issue to be
pivoted back to Ontario and Canada
city of Ottawa is looking for a way out
can you are you able to explain
um this is something that Steve
kanalakis said in a meeting but he is
saying that you're feeling the pressure
and you want the issue pivoted back to
Ontario and Canada can you expand on
that well the price of course I was
under pressure but my bigger concern
were the residents who were under much
more pressure than I was living through
this hell in terms of
Steve kanalakis indicating we wanted
Ontario and Canada to be involved was
that first of all we knew that none of
the mandates that they were protesting
had anything to do with the city of
Ottawa or any municipality they were all
provincially right or federally run
secondly we did not have the resources
we didn't have enough police officers to
continue doing all of the rest of the
work of patrolling Ottawa streets and as
you know were 2 600 square kilometers so
you couldn't take every officer away
from Canada and Orleans and venue and so
on and put them in the downtown course
so pivot to Ottawa or pivot back to
Ontario Canada was to say please come to
the table we need your help
okay and if I can take you to ott18172
what date is that this is a February 6th
email
from
um it looks like Ops
to you into chair Deans
so it's from uh James Armbruster
Armbruster I believe he's with the opp
no okay yes sorry uh no he was my EA oh
okay I'm sorry and that's uh to you and
to uh some other people in your office
where I'm reading it says two James
Armbruster from me
on what I'm seeing I'm looking at the
one above
but in any event if we go down yeah if
we're you're looking at the one
underneath it right yeah sorry and if we
go down to the original one
okay that's okay perfect so if we go up
to see the two so this one is from the
Ottawa Police Service John steinbach's
right and it's to you and to
um Diane Dean's Serge from your office
and other people there from the Ops
Etc right and it says chair Deans and
mayor Watson please find below the list
of Ottawa Police Service asks to the
federal provincial and Municipal levels
of government that was requested
Yesterday by the board these asks are
designed to assist with the management
and safe conclusion of the demonstration
right what date is that this is February
6. so it's the day that you declared the
state of emergency right
and then it says the chief is requesting
a meeting as soon as possible to discuss
we're available this evening and if we
go down to see what the list of asks is
uh there are some things there for the
city to do uh and it looks like then the
chief was asking the city to assist in
in several ways that are reflected there
is that right that's correct and one of
those points uh the third bullet point
on the second page there it says yeah
yes sorry if we go up
yeah
um
convene financial institutions insurance
companies gas companies trucking
companies Trucking associations and
local bias to restrict material and
financial support to demonstrators can
you explain what the uh what was being
asked of the city in that point
on that particular bullet point yes
that's something you'd have to ask Chief
slowly because it was his request but my
understanding was that they wanted to
try to see if they could stop for
instance gas stations from filling up
Jerry cans because we knew that was the
transportation method by members of the
Convoy to keep their rigs running in the
cold weather so you know we also had I
know over the course of this period I I
was invited to I think five or so
meetings with different business groups
including bias
and it never came up at those meetings
that I was at that we were asking their
Merchants to stop selling supplies and
so on so that's something that the chief
asked for
um I'm not entirely sure what benefit it
would be but I relied on his good
judgment and was that done did the city
take any steps towards those things
I don't believe so because our number
one preoccupation was to end the
occupation and bring the Streets back
under control of the city of Ottawa so
you can only do so much there are only
so many balls in the air that you can
juggle in order to get these issues
resolved but I don't believe certainly I
was not involved in contacting any
financial institutions for instance
aside from the GoFundMe discussion we
had right and in terms of insurance
companies was that part of the
discussion that was being had with the
province to be able to restrict the
commercial
licenses and insurance of the of the
participants yes but that may have taken
place before the formal request because
we were basically trying to find any
mechanism or method that could help us
encourage the truckers to leave and one
of the suggestions that I believe a
member of council brought to my
attention was there's a separate
licensing regime and insurance regime
for trucks could those organizations
through MTO Ministry of Transportation
of Ontario actually use those tools to
basically Force the trucks to get out or
there would be consequences to their
actions of illegally blocking our
streets and the ministry of
transportation did not follow through on
that they didn't seem to think that was
a reasonable idea or
maybe they didn't think it was a good
idea so you had a call with the
representatives from the ministry of
transportation is that right uh it
wouldn't have been me it would have been
some member of Staff but I'm not me
personally oh okay so you were not on
those calls but it was reported back to
you that they didn't think it was a good
idea that's correct did you have any
understanding as to why they didn't
think it was a good idea
well there was um they seemed to think
that it would uh they couldn't do what
we were asking them to do so there
seemed to be a bit of a contradiction in
terms of what we thought was available
under provincial law and what they were
telling us was was not available and um
I think at one point someone said it
wouldn't make any difference this was a
group that was digging in and having a
you know a paper exchange of rules and
laws and bylaws was not going to move
this group at all okay
um and then the final Point that's on
the the top of that page there are daily
Emergency Operations Center meetings to
coordinate whole whole of City response
including daily public briefings LED and
coordinated by the city so that the
police can focus on operations uh I
don't believe this was ever done are you
able to confirm that
did the city have daily briefings
um
not public briefings there are a number
of press conferences that were held by
both myself and chair Deans and chief
slowly and city manager so we did make
ourselves available
um if not on a daily basis when new
information arrived we weren't going to
have a press conference for the sake of
having a prep conference if there's no
new information but
there certainly were a series I remember
seeing and I think we talked about an
interview a series of memos that went
out over the course of the event
updating members of council and the
public but this is daily public briefing
so I imagine that's for the public
yeah well I guess the public briefing
would have been the press conferences
that were carried on the city's social
media networks and then under advocacy
it says mayor to play to play advocacy
role with other jurisdictions on below
asks so there it talks about the 1800
officers which you did advocate for in
your letter of February 7th co-authored
by cheer Deans correct um and it also
says on the third bullet point
professional mediation and negotiation
capacity can you explain what this was
about what were they asking for there
well again I'm in a bit of a
disadvantage because these are not my
requests these are the requests that
were sent to um to chair Deans and I in
an effort to write to the Prime Minister
and the minister of Public Safety as
well as the premier and the solicitor
general to seek the 1800 additional
Staffing and enforcement we were pushing
the police because one of the challenges
we had was up until this letter came or
this memo came from the chief we did not
have an exact number
that was being requested of the two
other orders of government so this was
something that chair Deans and I pushed
for because we needed that number to go
back to our federal and provincial
counterparts to say all right you asked
for a number here it is and here's how
it's divided so on the issue of
mediation
again I can only
um suggest it may have been they wanted
to have some capacity to go and try to
mediate the safe removal of all of the
trucks but that would be something the
chief would have to ask right so the
chief was the chief asking you then to
engage a professional mediator for that
purpose to try and de-escalate the
situation with the protesters yeah again
I'm not sure the intent or why it was um
I I think it's under advocacy but my
understanding was that these were
requests
for our staff the one request that was
for myself to play was really bullet
number one to get those 1800 resources
I can take you to Ott 20707
and what date is that this is on
February 7th it's the next day after
that email from the Ops right the
requests there's an email on February
7th and it looks like
if we go down
it looks like counselor Eagle is saying
uh Sarah's here's a quick and dirty
draft Jean is fine with the mayor
seconding the motion and then there is
um this is a draft of a wording for
emotion and there's a lot of whereas
whereas and then it says at the bottom
therefore be it resolved that the mayor
supported by city council formally
requests that the federal government
appoint an independent mediator
forthwith to assist in de-escalating the
protest as well as the orderly removal
of the protesters and their vehicles
from the city of Ottawa so is this is
this the response to the request from
Ops to engage a professional mediator
uh I don't believe so I think it may
have been done almost on a parallel
basis it was councilor egg Lai that I
believe drafted it and the gene is the
Jean Jean Cloutier who was going to move
it I checked earlier this week because I
I saw this email I hadn't seen it before
but it never went to city council it was
a draft and I know that at some point in
that period I'd also suggest it um
publicly would there be a role for the
federal government to appoint a
distinguished Canadian
who could go in and mediate and resolve
this the idea was not supported At All
by the federal government I referenced
it I Believe In A CTV interview
but I don't think the two were connected
even though the subject is the same I
think counselor Cloutier to his credit
counselor we're trying to come up with
um some reasonable suggestion to try to
bring an end to this because I think if
I can put it in context every member of
council whether you lived in the
downtown core and represented it or not
we're feeling
um
overwhelmed and Under Siege by
constituents and by people from across
the country harassing members of council
and I think all members of counsel to
their credit we're trying their very
best to come up with sensible ideas that
they could present to us
including the chief and the city manager
and myself and my office to see if this
would help resolve the situation so all
members of counseling good faith we're
trying to do what they thought was best
to end this in this particular case I
don't believe this motion I know for a
fact it didn't go to council so it was
just a draft and I suspect it probably
didn't go to council because the the
quick response I received from the
federal government was we're not going
to the point of mediator okay and do you
know why they didn't want to appoint a
mediator
um I I can only speculate so I shouldn't
speculate I don't know you'd have to ask
okay did they did they tell you why did
they say why they were they were not um
interested in this
again I you know I have a vague
recollection that they uh that I raised
it with either Minister Blair or
mendocini uh but I can't recall the
context of why they were against it okay
and I'm going to take you to ott5513
this is now February 7th
and as we saw earlier Chief slowly had
made a request for 1800 officers uh he
also we haven't looked at the the email
but there is an email in which he sets
out a chart indicating what kind of
personnel he's looking for and how many
yes and this is a letter then um dated
February 7th to uh Premier Ford and
solicitor general Sylvia Jones
and and this is the letter in which you
request if we go down
there we go and there you are asking for
those officers
I was a little farther down further down
on the second page yeah
and I believe we did send the chart to
these uh individuals as well that the
chief had indicated okay I put together
and
um we know that Chief slowly had asked
that you advocate for the resources
um at different levels of government did
he ask you specifically to write this
letter
well that was the implication he
provided us with his request because
councilor Deans and I both agreed that
we needed to get something in writing
because it was putting us in an awkward
situation where we were having these
regular meetings with Federal and
provincial officials and they said well
how many resources do you need and we
didn't have an answer so to the credit
of the chief he put together a very
thorough it wasn't just police officers
or obviously other components that he'd
asked for including civilian staff and
public order officers cyber
investigative capacity digital and
social media forensics and financial
forensics so we wanted to put that in
writing and this letter was basically
the same as the one we sent to the
federal government as well okay and if
we can go up
there we go on the second paragraph
there you say what was initially
described as a peaceful protest has now
turned into a Siege of our downtown area
and then you say as of today there are
currently between 400 and 500 trucks
occupying ottawa's downtown core then
you go on to say these acts in the
occupation are having damaging and
long-term impacts on the well-being of
our residents people are living in fear
and are terrified and they're now being
subjected to the non-stop honking of
large trucks for nine days which is town
to mount to psychological warfare and
you say given the scope and scale of the
Armada of large trucks that are now
occupying our downtown core and this is
now on the second page we are writing to
you to ask today for your help to secure
1800 officers to quell the Insurrection
that the Ottawa Police Service is not
able to contain
and then further down you say we must do
everything in our power to take back the
streets of Ottawa and our parliamentary
Precinct from the criminal activity and
hooliganism that has transpired over the
last nine days we need your help to end
this Siege at the heart of our nation's
capital and in our residential
neighborhoods and to regain control of
our city
so was that description of the situation
uh accurate as to what was happening on
the ground as of February 7th
absolutely you know I think if you just
go back and look at the media coverage
the media themselves were being harassed
during this whole period of time we now
know that a number of children had to
miss a chemo and radiation appointments
at Chio the residents living on those
streets having these horns honked
literally 24 hours a day seven days a
week plus the diesel fumes plus roasting
a pig on one street bonfires lighting
off fireworks having a dance party it
was showing complete disrespect for the
people who lived in the city of Ottawa
and I I put that wording in very
strongly to let the two other orders of
government know that we needed their
help our cities back was against the
wall we had this outrageous behavior by
people who seem to have no respect for
private property public property or the
well-being of the citizens of
Ottawa and my job as mayor was to speak
out and say we have to end this and the
only way we're going to end it is with a
significant significant increase in
boost in the number of police officers
and when you say and to regain control
of our city you're conveying here that
you you the greater you I suppose you
Ops the city Ops had lost control of the
city
well it was a teetering on loss control
we lost control in the Red Zone because
we couldn't even contain Jerry cans
going in you know in one or two
incidents the chief explained to me the
police tried to stop them and then they
were swarmed by a hundred Truckers and
one of the things I think is is vitally
important to remember in this whole
terrible situation was that while there
was a high level of frustration on the
part of the public rightfully so on the
part of our Council and City staff and
myself at the end of the day there were
no um deaths and there were no serious
injuries and so the chief and his wisdom
and I agree with him was not going to
barge in there without necessary
resources to make sure that the one shot
they had the one opportunity they had to
actually get in there and clean up
Wellington Street in Canton O'Connor in
the byword market and the baseball
stadium was to do it with the necessary
resources to move in quick swiftly and
that's exactly what they did and I
appreciate the police doing that but
you're quite right in the red zone it
was lawlessness people were having
parties they were open
fires they were throwing off fireworks
that were a fire hazard to Heritage
buildings in the downtown core they were
harassing people in restaurants tearing
off their Mass these are not sort of
made-up stories these are all documented
during the uh the the Convoy occupation
and so um yes we there's we're not
swallowing our pride by the saying we
you know we could do it all on our own
we needed help and we needed the help of
the other two orders of government
so if I can take you now to Ott 6057
and this is another letter dated
February 7th and this is uh now directed
to the Prime Minister and to minister
Mendicino is that right yes and it's
essentially the same letter that's
correct okay
and um
now I understand that discussions with
the Prime Minister and with Minister
Mendocino were ongoing the seventh is
the same day as there was a first
tripartite ministerial meeting on the
8th there was as well and on the 10th so
did you receive a a formal response to
this letter from
um the prime minister or Minister
Mendocino
I'd have to go back and look at files
often these letters go out they're
publicly made and do you necessarily get
a response what we were looking for is
not a nice type written response we
wanted action and we believe that or I
certainly believe that this letter acted
to break the Log Jam to put in writing
for the first time our specific requests
that we needed help
now the solicitor general did respond to
your letter on February 8th uh sorry on
February 10th is that right I recall her
sending I think a two-page letter uh to
I believe it was both councilor Deans
and myself okay if I can take you to ont
851
and this is the response uh dated
February 10 and we can see there's from
the solicitor general of Ontario
uh and it's to you and to chair Deans as
well thank you for your letter also
addressed to The Honorable Doug Ford
premier of Ontario requesting additional
officers uh and then she says Public
Safety is a top priority for this
government the ministry of the solicitor
general is committed to working with our
policing and Community Partners to
provide them with the resources and
tools they need to keep Ontario's
communities safe and resilient
then she talks about the right to
protest is core to our Canadian identity
peaceful protests are a Cornerstone of a
healthy democracy however criminal
behavior is never tolerated and hatred
or intolerance must be condemned by all
um and um she says the last paragraph at
the bottom we have been encouraged we
have been encouraging all those
participating in the Ottawa protest to
govern their actions in a way to ensure
they are peaceful and respectful to the
community and to those charged with
keeping the peace
and um and then she says regarding the
request for significant additional
resources please note that I have shared
your correspondence with OPP
commissioner Thomas karik commissioner
Thomas Creek and RCMP commissioner
Brenda lucky will continue to liaise
with Chief Peter slowly Ottawa Police
Service to determine how policing
Partners can provide support based on
available policing resources and the
operational plan proposed by the Ottawa
Police Service so what was what's your
reaction to this letter did did this
satisfy what you were looking for in in
the letter that you sent on February 7th
no but I think you know as a former
Minister myself the provincial
government this is the kind of letter
that you know uh is pretty much a
template you thank them you explain the
situation and you are told that um
rightfully so the minister can't direct
the opp on what to do but she forwarded
to the commission of the opp so
um you know we knew at some point we
would uh get through to the province and
they would come and help us and when
they did it was very much appreciated
and the opp did a remarkable job but
um you know there's the level of um uh
frustration that we had was that um it's
fine to forward this to the commissioner
of the opp but uh by that time the
commissioner would have known what our
request is because Chief slowly was in
pretty regular contact with both
commissioners
so did the solicitor general commit to
do anything either in this letter or in
or in any discussions that you had with
her any kind of specific action that the
solicitor general was committing to take
well um again when when I had a call
with her uh I can't recall the date but
with the premier and and solicitor
general were both on the call and they
indicated that they would not be
participating in the tripartite group
which was disappointing but it's it's
their call but I reiterated with the
premier on the I believe the two calls
that I had that it was essential that we
get police officers here as quickly as
possible and the whole issue as I talked
about earlier the the solicitor general
was under the impression that there were
1500 officers assigned to Ottawa which
was not the case I think what may have
happened was that the the minister or
the opp were you know giving you a
cumulative uh number you know 50 here
and then maybe 40 came came back and
then another 60 arrives you account 50
plus 60. and the other thing is I think
you have to keep in mind in this period
was the Windsor situation which was
viewed as a higher priority given the
billion dollar a day trade blockade that
was taking place of Windsor and so we
certainly saw through the news a
significant OPP presence in the Windsor
area and I you know I thought at the
time well you know I wish they were here
because we think we're just as important
as Windsor but I thought well at the
very least they did a very good job in
Windsor and once that's wrapped up
they'll be sending those officers to
Ottawa okay so you expected that the
Windsor issue and by that we mean the
blockade at The Ambassador Bridge would
be resolved before Ottawa became a
priority to become resolved is that
right yes and that's in fact what
happened okay and if I can take you to
ont 858
um now this is a letter that was not
sent to you it's the next day after the
response from the solicitor general
um
uh the kind of template letter as you
described it and this is now February
11th and this is
um directed to commissioner uh karik
and uh the solicitor general says this
letter is being sent regarding the
protest activity occurring in Windsor so
this is the Windsor situation as you
were talking about the government of
Ontario is proposing that a meeting
occur with an agree within an agreeable
time period between a select group of
protest leadership and representatives
of the province to allow their issues to
be heard to move forward with our offer
to schedule a meeting all protesters
must leave the protest site immediately
denounce all unlawful activity and
encourage a period of quiet this means
no unlawful and peaceful unsafe protest
activity can occur between the time of
acceptance of this offer until the
meeting takes place please share this
with the protest leadership and note
that immediate agreement is required any
time delay in acceptance will negate
this offer so in this letter the
solicitor general is offering that the
province will meet with a group of
protesters in Windsor if they leave the
protest site immediately and denounce
all activity
are you aware of the uh if the province
ever offered to meet with protesters in
Ottawa I'm not aware of any such
um
request and is it fair to say that that
option was never discussed either with
the premier or with uh solicitor Jones
at any of your discussions that's
correct
and I actually In fairness I have not
seen this letter I don't believe it was
cc'd to me so it's not that's right it's
not a letter that was sent to you
um but the question was whether this
type of offer that was being made with
respect to the protesters in Windsor if
that ever came to your attention if that
ever happened with respect to the
protesters in Ottawa and what I hear you
saying is that no no that was that was
never an option that was presented to me
or anyone in my office okay
um if I can take you now to
um
I'm going to take you to the first
tripartite meeting that occurred on
February 7th and it is PB Dot
NSC Dot c-a-n-2335
and if we go down to the bottom of that
page yeah right there okay so this is
um my understanding is that this is a
readout of the first of the three
tripartite ministerial meetings that
took place with you Minister Blair
Minister Mendocino I think I believe Mr
kenilakis attended as well and at times
Deputy Minister
um Rob Stewart was in attendance as well
yes it was all done virtually yes
uh BB there is Bill Blair and in the
second line he says spoke to PM last
night felt it was important to convene
table all of them have already been
working well with City officials
and so it looks like they're the Prime
Minister felt that it was important to
convene this tripartite table with
everybody at the table so that issues
could be discussed
and if we look at MM is a minister
Amanda Chino
and in the third line he says we have
confirmed 250 mounties have been
deputized
the he says we have been timely and
responsive in putting our response
together Minister Jones will want to
have a discussion with what they can
contribute
so I understand that he's saying here
that they have made 250 RCMP officers
available
is that your reading of that too
uh yes
okay and if we go to the next page
you say
in the first line you say 150 already
pre-assigned and are you talking about
RCMP officers here that's correct you
say not on Wellington Street or Kent
counted as part of the total but this
doesn't help our foot soldiers with Ops
down to 100 spread over three shifts
over eight hours this isn't a lot a
request is significant biggest crisis
facing our city we are filled with angst
so what are you trying to convey in this
section here
well I have to say Minister Mendocino
was very approachable and reasonable to
deal with uh and the many
opportunities I had to to deal with him
he understood the file but we had a
disagreement in terms of what the I'll
call it um
250 I guess
um officers you know on the ground is as
the federal government was saying they
were on the ground in Ottawa but they
were assigned 50 to West block which was
the new center block 50 Dorito Cottage
and 50 to Rideau Hall so out of the 250
or 257 you remove 150 right away because
those individuals stationed at West
block Rideau College in Reno Hall were
not helping in Center town or the
residential area of Center town or the
byword market or Overbrook Forbes so
um you know it was a bit frustrating
because uh you know when I read through
this once you get down to 100 spread
over three shifts of eight hours a day
it's not a lot of officers and so while
we appreciate it every time we saw a
mounty or we saw an opp officer we
needed the large number of 1800 to get
this situation under control and kick
these yahoos out of our city who are
disrupting the quality of life of the
people of Ottawa so you know at the end
of the day fast forward we got what we
wanted and we appreciate the federal
government the provincial government's
support we wanted it sooner because this
thing should not have lasted three weeks
and then further down in the middle of
the page it says watson that's you on
tripartite table has the province agreed
to this and Bill Blair says both of us
have reached out Marco Mendicino and I
we are working on it she wasn't able to
join today unfortunately and she would
be the solicitor general yes
we'll continue to engage to encourage
them to join these talks
and then you say province is very
reluctant to be a part of what is going
on
Premier line was anything you need I
will be there for you I have gone to
Sylvia Jones with that message the
protesters are digging in tried to light
a fire for example there are misleading
people on social media so what is the
sentiment that you're conveying there
well uh disappointment that the province
didn't want to take part of the
tripartite and when I had that
conversation with Minister Jones and the
premier on that phone call I think it
was a phone call or a zoom I can't
recall to be honest the premier was
adamant that he did not feel it would be
useful to have three levels of
politicians sitting around a table
and did he say why he didn't think that
was going to be that wasn't necessary or
helpful well you know I I think he felt
it would be a waste of time you know I
you know when he said that I was quite
frustrated with him he said look at
what's it going to accomplish a bunch of
people sitting around a table talking
and making decisions and I said well
that sounds like a cabinet meeting and
uh he didn't like that but at the end of
the day
um it was his call if he wasn't going to
go to
forces minister to go to the meeting or
not go to the meeting he just said
they're not going to be part of it so as
I said now In fairness to the premier
when he did engage
it worked we had the police officers and
the opp we had the RCMP and we were all
on the same book but this thing should
have been resolved in week one not week
three and when did you see engagement
from The Province when did you start
seeing that
I'd have to look through my notes but it
was
um you know I think probably sometime by
the end of the uh the second week
the uh the protests some sometime in
that period so we know that the province
declared a state of emergency on
February 11th would you say that they
were engaged before that time or that's
the point of time when they became
engaged well you know notwithstanding
the fact they didn't want to participate
in the tripartite they were obviously
available to us and you know as I
mentioned uh you know at the local level
federally I had very good liaison in
connection with Minister uh Yasser and
akhvi the MP for Ottawa center Mona
Fortier the president of Treasury board
as well uh
I think she was in a different portfolio
at that point and Minister McLeod so we
were having ongoing discussions at the
political level and and all three of
those and other elected officials were
acting as a very good conduit for our
requests back to their political
establishments and I can't give you the
exact uh time when the province was more
engaged but they were always engaged
they just weren't at the tripartite
table and I think certainly after
Windsor they recognize the next big
problem is
Ottawa and they better you know get
there as soon as possible because this
thing was close to swirling out of
control and what we were seeing was
every weekend people were treating this
like it was some sort of a rave or a
party or something and arriving and
there were DJs and loud sound systems
and uh racist flags and desecration of
our national War Monument
and and I think you know I can't give
you the exact date but eventually the
opp came on board eventually we got the
RCMP but as I said this thing frustrated
me because
you know the public were saying well why
don't you tell the police to do this and
as we all know or most people know in
our society a politician cannot by law
direct a police service on operational
matters so we have to work at the
political level to do whatever we can to
get some resolution to a situation that
was extremely
hurtful to thousands of people
so if I can take you that now to um
another document
ssmnsc.can 2052
and I believe this is a readout of the
second tripartite meeting and it looks
like the participants on the first page
are Minister manduccino Minister Blair
uh you if we go down
a little bit yeah and it looks like uh
Chief slowly was in attendance do you
recall him attending one of the
tripartite meetings uh yes okay
so then on the first page you say
uh why no soul gen in attendance
I suppose that's Minister Jones okay I
see that yeah yeah and then Minister
manuccino says no word back so at this
point you had expected that Ontario
would have been at this table is that
right
yes I you know I don't know the the
sequence of dates as to whether you know
because I did have that conversation
with the premier
um where he rejected the idea uh but um
you know I know that the federal
ministers were also trying to get the
solicitor general to engage on the the
tripartite table which
she
declined well this may assist because
then you say I am speaking at Premier
tomorrow so you probably spoke to him
then on February 9th well I had I had at
least uh two calls with the premier so
um you're probably correct in the
sequence of events okay and then you say
We'll ask that his Minister be at the
table
and um
if we go to where it says Blair on
Ontario involvement I know Marco's been
having good conversations with Ontario
they are worried about being visible and
then being asked about what the province
is doing
um do you know what dude what was the
discussion around that point they are
worried about being visible can you
expand on what the discussion was there
I really don't recollect what what the
reference to visible or or invisible
was
okay so you do you know what Ontario's
concern is it says they are concerned
about being visible and being asked
about what the province is doing you you
can't shed I can only speculate okay so
I don't really know what um sure what's
going through their mind at that point
they certainly knew that they were more
than welcome to the table and they they
had had our letter
from councilor Deans and I um with the
specific request and the breakdown that
the officers needed and then the chief
gives a breakdown of what's been going
on uh the breakdown of the resources
what they've been doing and then on page
three
um
so it says on page three
at the very top public safety risk is
higher on Rito it's being contained by
where is this on the very top of Page
Three go ahead yeah
um it says public safety risk is higher
on Rito it's being contained by QC
criminal organization and there they are
radicalized elements as well there is
some negotiations ongoing leading to
movement and that's 48 hours away if we
had resources tonight we can move on
that tonight
and
um Minister Mendocino says confirm Rito
is ahead of Wellington
so my understanding that this is in
terms of clearing areas that Rito and
Sussex
would be ahead of Wellington in terms of
an area to clear because of the criminal
activity that's being described here is
that your understanding as well
uh yes and my understanding because I
was briefed on this was that the chief
indicated there were the criminal
elements I believe were involved with
the biker gang
community in Quebec and they were
blockading um corner of where Rito
Wellington Sussex
Colonel buy Connect and it was also had
shut down as you know the Rideau Center
which was a major economic generator as
well as a lot of small restaurants and
shops along Rito Street in the Byron
market right and then
um slowly says
yes it's blocking a hospital route Etc
higher risk to Public Safety when we
have resources reliability we will be
able to move so here he's indicating
that that area is blocking a hospital
route and therefore a priority for
clearing it out is that your
understanding as well well and also it's
a major Transit hub for both sto and OC
Transpo as well right a lot of small
businesses in that area
and then further down slowly says for
every action we do there is a counter
reaction that can exceed our resources
we saw that in Coventry our public
requests for more than 1800 more people
resulted in the activity in Windsor plus
a national call for protesters to drive
to Ottawa so they can outnumber even
increased police presence
so do you recall what slowly was saying
here about the public request for 1800
officers did he see that as a concern
that it though that request was publicly
made
well I think what we were trying to do
was to keep that number confidential
because we didn't want to show our hand
and the police's hand as to how many
resources were coming in but
um
I don't know when the 1800 came out it
may have come out at a Police Services
Board or a question from a member of
council you know you couldn't keep it
suppressed forever but
um you know I I certainly was not
concerned with protesters coming all the
way from Windsor what my preoccupation
was to get the police officers that had
quelled the situation in Windsor to get
to Ottawa as quickly as possible and I
think his point is it was a bit of a
game of whack-a-mole when they sort of
resolved one situation another thing
would flare up a good example of that
was the The Shack that was being built
near the canal and the NAC and
Confederation Park is permanent
structure where it was a food
distribution point and it was very very
unsafe there was propane open fires
gasoline all stored in this area and our
fire chief and fire service said this is
a Tinderbox that could explode so you
know we had the request from the NCC
because it was their property to move in
they eventually did move in total of
that down but then people started to
come back again so it was one of these
great frustrations that people had
where you got one thing resolved then
you moved on he just didn't have the
resources to keep enough Police Services
there to ensure that a flare-up wouldn't
happen again so it all it all boiled
down to we needed more boots on the
ground and so then Bill Blair says have
you looked at traffic laws Etc
so he seems to be suggesting to use
existing existing laws to deal with this
well um you know the police have the
responsibility for the highway traffic
act you're correct and uh you know
police can issue tickets for bylaws
parking and so on but we had you know I
think the figures are in the
documentation there were thousands of
tickets that were issued hundreds of
people that were charged and arrested
but we couldn't for instance send
unarmed bylaw officers into a very
volatile situation to hand out parking
tickets if police were being swarmed uh
you know certainly you could expect even
worse treatment of individuals who are
not given the proper training to deal
with a confrontation of that nature I
would not want to send a friend or Foe
into into that red zone or into the area
where the Quebec and at the bottom oh
sorry yes yeah I just I you know I
wouldn't in good conscience want a force
by law officers who are not geared to
dealing with angry
unruly mobs into a situation where their
their safety could be in danger right
and she slowly alludes to this at the
bottom he says is a challenging
situation to enforce just yesterday a
hundred people surrounded 30 officers
when they apprehended an individual with
a gas can and were almost overcome we
need extra public order bylaws aren't my
control so he's essentially saying
existing bylaws existing resources is
not helpful
to end the situation yes okay and then
you say show me the mounties we need to
come out of the meeting with a down
payment on resources what will you
commit to
and then Minister manduccino says there
is a 5 PM RCMP call with the city I
believe we need to have the province
present on these calls OPP will play a
critical role
and then you say it's hard for me to
blast The Province when I don't have a
commitment from the feds
um so explain that comment there
well
um you know there was a love we were a
bit like the meat and the sandwich we
were trying to get both orders of
government to provide their National and
Provincial Police Services to the city
of Ottawa and the numbers that the chief
and his command team required to get
this issue resolved and we knew you know
if you go back and look at the sequence
of events from week one to week two to
week three we started to see a lot more
action on week two than we did in week
one and what was important I think from
from my perspective was
um
you know we all had a skin in the game
in the sense that we had a police force
the opp is a Provincial Police Force in
the mounties of the federal police force
and uh we need it all to be working
uh and um you know following the same
script because the last thing we needed
was a bunch of distractions where you
know they don't agree and they're
fighting and squabbling you know at the
end of the the whole process when the
police finally did move in and they had
the 1800 I believe it went up to 1900.
uh it was in my opinion and I'm not a
policing expert but a very good case
study on how to resolve a situation
relatively quickly they moved in I
believe on the Friday they had the
notices uh attached to all the vehicles
on the Thursday
and most of the work was done on
Saturday and then the last of it cleaned
up on on Sunday and so um my point was I
can't go and start criticizing The
Province if you still haven't given me a
commitment for the number of officers we
need it from the RCMP now to get back to
my point on sequence I understand you
know I think a lot of public were saying
well why aren't there more police here
more quickly we had police from
Vancouver Calgary you know all over the
country Municipal forces the mounties
had to ship people in from
all parts of the country and that takes
time there's Logistics to that that's
why I I wished that it started two weeks
ago at the end of week one instead of
the end of week two but at the end of
this process uh it there was a
logistical challenge to get that number
of officers most of whom had to fly or
drive to get to Ottawa we had to put
them up
expensive undertaking we had to make
sure they had proper food they had to be
sworn in those mounties that were were
coming in because they didn't have
jurisdiction on Municipal grounds as a
mounty but the opp did so there were a
lot of things that took time so I wish I
could have snapped my finger and said
let's have 1800 get them in there and uh
and this nonsense but that was not the
case because it it took you know four
five six days when they finally ramped
up and they had the 18 to 1900
individuals it was a very good uh show
of uh leadership
and a very good show of the
professionalism of the police officers
and I repeat this because I think this
gets lost we'd be having a much
different commission and discussion if
someone had been shot and killed or
seriously injured that did not happen
and that is good I think uh credit to
the police officers on the ground in
miserable conditions as you recall it
was freezing February ice all over the
place and uh you know they cleaned it
out and I give great credit to our First
Responders and others who work very hard
paramedics fire service bylaw Public
Works OC transport it was all hands on
deck and I know the public wanted us to
move faster and I empathize with what
they were going through
but at the end of the process I think we
have to remember that there was not you
know these things are tinderboxes you
see them in other jurisdictions where it
flares up and you see
the tragedy of
you know unprofessionalism uh taking
hold
but as you mentioned uh the municipality
is a creature of provincial statute and
here you're saying you wanna uh a
commitment from the federal government
but you haven't secured a commitment
from the provinces and isn't that the
proper sequence as a municipality to go
to the provinces and then the provinces
can then subsequently you know push that
request up to the federal government why
was that sequence not being well In
fairness I think it's a six to one half
dozen of the other in many respects you
know whether we get the province to
agree first with the federal government
we're a little different as a city
because we have we're the nation's
capital we have a large RCMP presence as
a result of headquarters being here the
VIP protection detail protecting Federal
buildings and so on so
um even though we're dependent on the
province we're equally dependent on the
federal government is our largest
employer and a group that pays the most
in
payments in lieu of taxes so the reality
is they were I would consider them equal
Partners during this crisis I wasn't
going to go through the niceties of
protocol and say well we will just keep
hammering The Province until they agree
and then we'll go to the feds we were
trying to do it at the same time on two
different tracks to get them both to
agree which eventually they did but it
took some time more time than I liked
right and did anybody within the federal
government either Minister Blair
Minister manduccino the Prime Minister
indicate to you that by not going first
to the provinces to secure that kind of
commitment that there was a delay in in
procuring those resources as a result of
not following what you call the niceties
I don't believe that was the case it's
certainly the Menace the federal
ministers asked me to you know
communicate with the premier and I had a
pretty good rapport with the premier and
you know as many people know he's very
accessible on his phone and takes calls
quite quickly uh and he you know he was
I think he was sincere when he said you
know anything you need but we needed to
translate that into actual action right
and so
um you know I I was asked by minister
mendocini to raise
the issue of Opp officers and that's
when I said well I can't go and you know
keep pointing a finger at the Province
when you haven't delivered your end of
the bargain they eventually did and
we're grateful for that because that
ended the blockade okay but you didn't
understand from anybody in the federal
government that you were following that
they thought you were following the
wrong process by going directly to them
no no it was never never once raised
that you know well don't talk to us
you're a creature of the province okay
fair enough if I can take you to ssmcan
nsc2837
and this is a readout of the call with
the Prime Minister on February 8.
and so you recall you had a discussion
with the Prime Minister on this day yeah
I'm just looking for my notes it's
February can you zoom into that yeah
February 8th yeah thank you and uh we'll
go down to them to the kind of the meat
of it
yes a little bit down more
there we go
sorry I'm not seeing it on the 8th on my
chronology
but if you have it I'll believe you uh
yes it should be on this screen there
February 8th a call read out of the call
with the Prime Minister and if we go to
the second page
yeah you say uh well the Prime Minister
asks how you're doing you say a
challenge for anyone everyone still a
pretty unstable situation nasty people
out there that just don't represent
Canada reminds me of the Republican
Party Down South can't reason with them
so vulgar and hateful attacking people
ripping masks off honking their horns
it's not over yet and I appreciate it
just you might slow down a bit for the
interpreters I'm just uh okay sorry I'm
just aware of the time but yes you're
right let's slow down for the
interpreters
um it's not over yet and I appreciate
that I had a really good conversation
with Marco and Bill we have a table with
the PT this afternoon at 4 30. do you
know what the reference of the PT is
that just the tripartite or what's the
PT do you know uh
uh I'm assuming it's the province
usually you think of PT it's provincial
territorial but um okay
and hopefully more resources from you on
RCMP but then you say Ford is just
staying away from this but I want to
bring him into the tent
So when you say Ford is staying away
from this what is this is it well it's
the tripartite table that he uh didn't
think was helpful okay and then the
Prime Minister says have they Province
indicated that they will be there at 4
30. you say it's been set up by Bill's
office Sylvia Jones is the name on it
she has been disingenuous saying there
are fourteen hundred
true I spoke to Ford yesterday and he
said anything you want so I'm going to
hold his words to it so this was the
issue that you had raised about the 1400
OPP officers correct yeah I think uh it
was 1500 but close to 1400 correct so
for either 14 yeah and on the Sylvia
Jones her name was on it but uh she did
not participate so she was on the invite
is that right yes okay
and then you ask about resources and the
Prime Minister says one of the
challenges is that it goes in steps the
first step is to go to the opp then RCMP
it's difficult for us to say what we
need to do directly until we have a
better idea of what the province is
doing that's why this table is so
important so can you explain what the
Prime Minister told you here
well I think he was alluding to the fact
that it would have been helpful to have
the province you know it's like a three
um leg stool if you only have two legs
on it it's not that sturdy you need all
three you need the provincial Municipal
and federal orders of government number
one
and uh I just think you know the
during a crisis
from a leadership point of view the more
information you have the better to share
with your partners
we're not in opposition to one another
but we need all three to be singing from
the same hymn book as they say so my
interpretation of that on that call with
the Prime Minister was that um
he felt that we needed to continue to
put pressure on the opp and the province
not the opp but the province to get the
opp to come
in good numbers just as they did in
Windsor you know I think Windsor was
wrapped up relatively quickly and then
there was the situation in a small town
in Alberta where
is a fairly large RCMP presence we
needed both of those Police Services on
board in order to move in the police
from Ottawa could not do it on their own
and having 50 OPP and another 50 or 100
RCMP was not going to cut it we needed
the 1800 total and so when he says this
goes in steps the first step is to go to
the opp then RCMP did you understand him
to be saying that the proper order of
operations was not being followed
um no I wouldn't interpret it that I
think normally in the normal course of
events
um you know for instance the Declaration
of a state of emergency or requesting
the military there is that process where
you have the municipality asks the
provincial government who asks the
minister of National Defense we did that
for instance during the flooding I
believe in 2017 and 2019 where the
military were very helpful to come in
and help but um from my perspective this
was completely different we weren't this
is not a regular
um
situation this is a very unique
situation and again I challenge anyone
to come up with any time in our recent
history in the last two generations
where this kind of a
an occupation took place for a prolonged
period of time so I you know I think he
was referencing probably the normal
course of events is that we would
normally go through the opp and up the
chain of command but we had requests in
based on the letters counselor Deans and
I sent to both orders of government and
it was very clear that we needed both of
them to respond
as quickly as possible with action and
not words
so Minister Mendicino and Deputy
Minister Stewart as we saw yesterday was
very they were both very active in
reaching out and offering their
assistance and asking what uh what the
city needed on the provincial side
um what was
um the Tomaso or Lori LeBlanc or Sylvia
Jones where they also reaching out
proactively to see how they could help
uh well
um
we knew what help we wanted and they
knew what help we needed because we sent
the letter so they were fully aware of
of our request and the specific demand
so you weren't hearing them proactively
like you were from uh from the others
no
um again you know I think um
you know I only had I believe two or
three calls with the premier and I think
only one of those was with Minister John
so I don't recall
um
In fairness I don't know why they would
be asking us what we need when in fact
we told them what we needed in that
letter
to the premier and to the minister right
and then the Prime Minister says but on
the Ottawa policing side
you have seen
as I have sorry where is that which so
we're now
um
further the last paragraph at the bottom
uh oh there now it's in the middle it's
the Prime Minister it's in the middle of
the page but on the policing side it's
on the second paragraph of the Prime
Minister I see that but on the Ottawa
policing side you have seen as I have
some concerns on how things were handled
from the beginning how is your
relationship with the police chief and
how are you guys working together there
are moments when you are saying one
thing and he is seeing another is there
anywhere we can help around that
now the Prime Minister here seems
concerned that you and chief slowly were
delivering different messages do you
have a sense for what that concern was
I don't and I I don't believe I am asked
for clarification
um I had confidence full confidence and
choose slowly he was a relatively new
Chief as you know to the city of Ottawa
but he had extensive experience as a
deputy chief in Toronto and particular
with some large events I think it was
either the G7 or G20 meetings that took
place as wrong so I can't recall where
um
Chief slowly and I were were not on the
same page you know most of the press
conferences
dealt with
uh police matters so he was the lead in
it and I would be scrummed for instance
after a council meeting or when we had a
zoom call of any nature but I don't
recall any
any Rift that we had
I think one of the things was you know I
was probably very impatient at how slow
the process was going to get the police
officers and how slow it took to get the
actual
break down as to what the chief needed
so I may have said you know in public
that I wanted to see this
letter go off to the the two orders of
government much more quickly
and he may have had a different opinion
because you know he sent it when he sent
it so the Prime Minister says he had
some concerns with how things were
handled from the beginning and he said
you have seen as I have some concerns
what were those concerns
well the concerns were what happened to
our intelligence system both at the
three orders of government that we did
not have a better sense that these
individuals were going to come and stay
a long period of time
why were so many vehicles allowed to
enter what I consider the most
significant historic Street in the
history in the in the country because
it's the street that houses our
Parliament buildings
and why the roads were not blocked off
when we started to see an increase in
the number of trucks coming down the
street and parking on King Edward and I
think almost every Canadian has that
same questions why were these allowed to
happen and it's easy to be you know
talking about hindsight and looking in
the rear view mirror
I think this thing came about
and it just kept growing and growing and
we collectively all three orders of
government and the police did not
respond quick enough and we allowed that
major Street and bled into the
residential streets to be taken over by
a group of people that had no respect
for the law and no respect for the
people of our city So when you say all
three levels of government
um kind of aired in in this way and
letting them in what could the city have
done to prevent that situation
well again I'm not a an expert on
policing matters but the first thing
should have been was to you know once we
saw a number of vehicles arriving on
Wellington Street get in there with a
jersey barrier and shut off Wellington
Street that would have pushed them on to
other roads but my understanding from
the discussions that I saw taking place
in the media was that the the prize Pig
was Wellington Street they wanted to
have Wellington Street with a flatbed
truck and a Podium and sound system to
denounce the federal government so if
they couldn't have that going on to
queen or Albert or Slater not much of a
backdrop on those streets so this was
very much I think their intention was to
go in and have them with these vulgar
flags and swastikas and Confederate
flags and so on swirling all over the
place with the backdrop of Parliament
Hill like they've taken over the country
and so but if we go back to that time
there were no discussions with Chief
slowly that you had with him about
blocking access to the downtown area
right no again you know that would have
been handled at the staff level you know
as you know the staff at bylaw and
Public Works would be responsible for
blockading physically the street but you
would need police presence there because
you had to maintain a corridor as they
do now if you go down to Wellington
Street there's still a corridor where an
ambulance or a fire truck could get
through but you're quite correct you
know the challenge we all faced was that
this thing came we didn't think it was
going to be as big as it did and I've
had conversations with other Mayors who
said you know what we learned lessons
from you you know Toronto I think
handled the situation and the mayor told
me meritori that you know we were the
guinea pig of these protests and it
allowed them to get their act together
at the start of the issue because they
saw what the pattern of activity the
truckers were were doing here in Ottawa
and as a result they were able to secure
tow trucks quickly and they were able to
close off access points to Queen's Park
and the same thing happened in Quebec
City so you know these Mayors you know
learned lessons from from us and and if
it had happened in another jurisdiction
I think we would have acted differently
and quickly to secure Wellington Street
as quickly as possible and then you say
uh in response to the prime minister's
suggestion that maybe there is some
concerns about how things are being
handled and your relationship with the
chief you say one thing was
when he said and he is the chief right
correct it's not a police solution but
it is a police solution I think he is
just a bit frustrated everything is
coming down on him but that doesn't make
sense this is a police matter I have
been trying my very best to back him up
every day as you know PM now is not the
time to change courses we have to do our
best to support him
and so when you say now is not the time
to change courses are you speaking about
um well what are you speaking about
well it's not the time to change uh the
leadership of the Police Service namely
the chief but if you go back I just
wanted to you know that was one of the
frustrations I did have with with Chief
slowly when he said it was not a
this is not going to be a police
solution and I think a lot of people
were sort of scratching their head and I
said well if it's not a police solution
how are you going to solve it you know
these individuals you know by and large
you could not argue rationally or
sensibly with they were emotionally
charged angry people from all parts of
the country and uh I just thought that
was a strange statement to make but
again you know as I said I very much
backed the chief and I thought
given the situation he found himself in
he was doing the very best he could to
manage a lot of different groups his
officers to other orders of government
the Police Services Board city council
residence it was a very stressful time
for everyone I'm sure himself included
but um
you know I don't know at that point if
there was some discussion about whether
to remove the chief or not I certainly
don't recall it later on yes because
obviously he did in fact leave the
Police Service
I can't recall how many I think it was
on the
he left on the 15th right so on that
point did you ever have any discussions
with anybody either within the
provincial government or the federal
government about Chief slowly's
leadership and whether or not there
should be a change in course
yeah not with the best of my knowledge
not with the federal government although
I do recall some comments that Minister
Blair made because he knew Chief slowly
because Minister Blair used to be the
chief of the Toronto police but I I
can't recall the context or what was
said about
that I know for instance during the
call I had with Minister Jones and the
premier
they expressed some concern about the
chief's plan or lack of plan to get this
issue resolved
and you know again I I suspect uh
Premier Ford new Chief slowly from his
days as a Toronto City councilor but it
didn't go farther than I think there was
Minister Jones made some reference to
the fact that she was hearing that
things were not operating at the
operations center as well as they should
be and there was some conflict and
division of opinion
now at the bottom the Prime Minister
says listen yes you can say the federal
government will be there with more
resources but again the thing that
frustrates me and everyone is conflated
and then there's some inaudible part and
then he says but Doug Ford has been
hiding from his responsibility on it for
political reasons as you highlighted and
important that we don't let them get
away from that and we intend to support
you on that
so what was your understanding of the
political reasons of why Premier Ford
according to the Prime Minister was
hiding from his responsibility
well I can't speculate on on what the
Prime Minister said but I think I shared
his frustration that um they wouldn't
participate in the tripartite uh we
couldn't get a clear answer as to
whether they were going to support the
number of officers that we needed
um and um
you know the pro the premier did not
come to Ottawa during the uh the
occupation I think there was a sense by
some in the community why is the Premier
not here but In fairness you know
sometimes when you bring a leader into a
situation it causes more disruption
because you need extra police and so on
uh but you know we had an open line of
communication with the premier but I
felt that um
I think I think he uh was probably more
comfortable not getting into the mix of
this until they were able to come up
with the number of officers that he he
could announce we're supporting our
officers but the Prime Minister here is
saying that you're saying that it's for
political reasons well I look at we're
all politicians the three of us and my
sense is that he
didn't necessarily want to wear the
situation because he felt that it was
very much the responsibility of the
Ottawa Police Service and I
fundamentally disagreed with him I said
of course they're the lead Police
Service they have that legal
jurisdiction but we need the help of the
other two orders of government with
police officers and then you say if they
keep dragging their feet I'm happy to
call them out on it it'd be nice if we
have something firmed up with the
federal government to shame them Ford
didn't even make an effort to come and
see what's going on so it's clear you're
sharing here the prime minister's
frustration about the province's lack of
attendance at these meetings and general
lack of involvement in in the the
solution finding well I'm sharing my
frustration because I was you know on
the front line uh trying to explain to
the public why it was taking so long to
get so many
resources into Ottawa when Windsor went
quite quickly
and obviously when the guns were
discovered in that small community in
Alberta it was shut down pretty quickly
but ours was lingering on and there was
um you know while we'd see you know we'd
have sort of a bit of up and down where
you know one day we'd get an account
saying five or six of the rakes moved
out which was good and then the next day
we'd have you know seven or eight are
coming back in so it was very very fluid
and very frustrating and I think um
expressing my frustration as was the
Prime Minister that uh on two fronts one
we need the pressure on the opp or the
province to get the opp here but
secondly the federal government had to
step up and do its Duty particularly
being the nation's capital we needed the
RCMP and you know as I said I went
through this period where you're
spending an hour arguing that we don't
have 250 officers you've already
assigned 150 to those three and I'm not
disputing you wanted to protect the
Prime Minister and the governor general
in Parliament but um don't keep
repeating the fact that there's you know
250 officers out on the street in Ottawa
because that was not the case and no one
and I think look at the end of the
process
um you know was there a little bit of
sort of you know if we push him on this
front politically he might Act
it worked because we got the police
officers and we need it you know you
don't necessarily want to go and
constantly prod and attack and so on but
most of this was done behind the scenes
so that we were not going to show that
at least at the political level there
was this fractious debate we could have
a post-mortem and and deal with that
after but the immediate
urgency was to give some peace of mind
and comfort to those people who are
living through hell in Center town and
the market and Overbrook Forest by the
so would it have been helpful to have
the province in attendance at these
meetings for everybody to be on the same
page and for everybody to know what the
numbers were and what was going on
absolutely I think I think that would
have sped up the process because you
know it's almost like that game a
telephone by the time you get the
translation of the last person it's a
lot different than the first person I
think everyone in the same room that was
the whole and I give credit I think it
was Minister Blair that was the one that
suggested the tripartite political group
meet and unfortunately we weren't able
convince the province but you know you
can't force them to do what they don't
want to do but you know the end result
albeit a week or two late we did see
Unity on the front lines with OPP
Municipal Police Services and Ottawa
Police at RCMP and as I said they did
what I consider a textbook case of
cleaning up a really really
terrible situation and so if the
province had participated in these
meetings and been more engaged do you
think there would have been less of a
delay in receiving resources the process
would have gone faster I can only
speculate because that's a theoretical
question but I truly believe it would
have if we're all at the same table
speaking to one another we can have our
arguments back and forth but you know In
fairness you know at the other levels
um
there seem to be some positive
relationship but there were obviously
disputes
um with respect to what was the final
plan that was going to be
signed off on and then of course as you
know we she slowly left the service so
that created
an element of instability but it didn't
last long because just a few days later
the police with their plan
took hold and cleaned up the city okay
thank you and commissioner this may be
an appropriate time for a morning break
if you wish
okay so we'll take uh 15 minutes uh be
back at 25 2 or 24 to
and thank you and we'll take the time
and that's it
washroom break
the commission is in recess for 15
minutes
thank you
thank you
order a lot
the commission has reconvened that
commissioner
so I want to take you now mayor Watson
to
ssm.can.nsc 2676
and this is the readout of the third and
last tripartite ministerial meeting
dated February 10.
and it looks to be with Minister Blair
yourself Minister Mendocino Mr
kennelakis
and Deputy Minister Stewart
and on the first page Minister Mendicino
talks about discussions
with commissioner lucky of the RCMP to
provide an additional 275 RCMP officers
and then he says this will be
operationalized in conjunction with the
opp need to have a sense of the plan
it's in the middle of that big paragraph
do you see that
this will be operationalized there it is
in conjunction with the opp need to have
a sense of the plan
and then on um so so my understanding
and we'll see a little bit later is that
this is in relation to uh Chief slowly's
plan to use the resources that will be
made available is is that your
understanding as well I believe so yes
okay so if we go to the second page
um just under the redacted portion keep
going at their RS so that is uh Deputy
Minister Rob Stewart says we are
engaging The Province on all of these
areas which are the ones above that are
blanked out
as well as the evolution of the plan
from what I understand the plan of the
chief has not yet been completely
fleshed out that may reflect the speed
with which the RCMP can deploy resources
so what did you understand about the
state of the plan from the ops's
perspective the ops plan
um at this stage which is now the 10th
of February
well my understanding was that it was
still being worked on and there was
still debate amongst different agencies
as to what was going to be the final
plan but in terms of the specifics as
I'm not a member of the Police Services
Board I would have no information or
knowledge about what was going on behind
the scenes right and but here in this
meeting the they're not talking about
specifics of a plan but they're talking
about we need to have a plan in order to
deploy the resources so was a discussion
that the fact that the plan had not been
completely fleshed out that that would
affect or that could delay the RCMP
resources again I could only speculate
because I wasn't part of that decision
making but obviously
the chief felt comfortable days earlier
giving us the number 1800 of police
officers
that one would assume would work its way
into the plan that he was working on so
I think you know the pressure we were
putting on Ops was to give us a number
so we can go back to our partners at the
federal and provincial levels of
government to get the officers that
would fit the plan right that was still
being worked on right and so the federal
your federal Partners uh here are
telling you that the plan is not
completely fleshed out right
yes and they would have received that I
suppose from the RCMP that are at that
Command Center
um as you know you know politicians are
not part of a
putting a plan together to to deal with
an operational matter so I'd have to
rely on their
comments to get that information and
were you hearing this from others as
well that there was issues with the
chiefs with the Readiness of the plan
well I at one point I received a car I
had a conversation with Steve kanalakis
that indicated that there was some
dispute an argument about what the final
plan was going to look like but that was
really the extent of it my
understanding was that these were not
insurmountable issues and that they were
close to signing off in the plan that
would incorporate the 1800 officers to
get this whole terrible situation
resolved right and so your Chief of
Staff yesterday testified that he was
informed by Chief of Staff Mike Jones
that by February 10 there was no
agreement on an integrated plan and he
indicated yesterday that you were aware
of this as well and that it would have
been communicated back to Ops the fact
that there were concerns about the
Readiness of the plan did you
communicate that back to Ottawa Police
Service or to Chief slowly
uh I don't know if I did or not whether
that would have come from Steve
kanalactus or Serge arpan but I don't
recall me raising the issue with them um
anytime I had any conversation about the
plan he would indicate to me that
they're closing in on finalizing it and
um while not giving me the specific date
when the action would start it was
alluded to on a number of occasions that
they would start
a process to clean out the uh the whole
area in days not weeks
sure but here minister manuccino and
Deputy Minister Stuart are indicating
that not having a plan can affect the
deployment of the RCMP officers did you
convey that back to Chief slowly to let
him know that this was the Readiness of
the plan was delaying no again that
would have been uh done at the staff
level not at the political level so uh
Steve kanalakis or or Serge arpa but uh
you know the reality is that um we have
to separate our our roles even though
I'm sitting in on this this group it's
not making operational decisions we were
relying on the Ops to work with their
Partners to come up with a plan that was
achievable and attainable and a
relatively short period of time with the
resources that we'd secured okay and on
page four
uh if we go down
okay and then you say
thank you if we can get word from the
commissioner to slowly sometime today we
can get this moving
um we don't have to pick it up and leave
it on Monday okay sorry I meant the um
the second point at the bottom there uh
where you say this is a good step at
some point I will call the premier to
get them to sit at this table
so this was the last
tripartite meeting correct I believe so
yeah and so
um they in the end the premier did not
come to the table right that's correct
and do you know why the tripartite
meeting stopped after February 10.
uh well I I assume it was because we
were closing in on that date when the
police were going to start moving and uh
it was no longer necessary if we had
secured the number of Opp officers in
that period of time or a couple of days
later there was not much point in
meeting again although I suspect if you
looked at all of the different
phone calls and zooms and so on we would
have had meetings bilateral or
multilateral but not the full tripartite
that was the last one
so in the three meetings that we looked
at there are some common themes that we
can see you're expressing frustration
that you're not getting commitment from
the federal government you say you need
boots on the ground
show me the mounties let's get a down
payment on our CMP officers so you felt
that the federal government was not
committing to the resources that you
needed
well at that time but then we sent the
letter we had the two calls with the
Prime Minister had a number of calls
with Minister mendocini uh Mendocino and
um eventually it it all culminated in
the officers arriving uh both I forgot
to mention Municipal Services as well
they were quite substantial you know
when you walk through the site you saw
Belleville police cars in York Region in
Toronto it was actually quite
quite uh
a relief to see those other police
officers helping their fellow police
officers so
um you know at the end of the day
the process unfolded as it should but as
I've said one of the frustrations I had
as a common theme was
uh the lack of commitment to officers
earlier on in the process so did you say
that the process unfolded as it should
well with the cleanup of the the streets
where is police moved in okay but you
agree that it it took three weeks for
that to happen right yes and that was my
biggest criticism was that it took so
long to get this resolved and again you
know it's easy for me as an armchair
critic to go and say well why didn't you
move faster I understand there's some
logistical you know we had officers from
Vancouver well it takes time to get the
plane tickets and get over here and get
hotel accommodations and so on so
um you know I'm not being overly
critical of the fact that there are some
logistical challenges but I was pushing
from really day one or day two we needed
more help because the chief told me we
couldn't handle this on our own right
but you're not just an armchair critic
as you say you're the mayor of Ottawa
and you see that your city is in need
and so you you have a duty really to
raise those issues and to and to push
all levels of government to do whatever
they can to get this resolved quickly
right yeah that was why I took on the
role of ensuring that we had uh the
political lines of communication open
why we established the tripartite
committee and why we sent the letter
from my office and from Council deeds
and why we continued to have dialogue
with local elected officials members of
council and
our political counterparts at the
federal and provincial government But
ultimately there was a significant delay
in getting those resources although they
ultimately did come clearly but there
was a significant delay in both RCMP
officers and OPP officers is that right
and other municipal office and other
Municipal officers and so essentially
what we're seeing in these three
meetings is that you're not getting what
you need from any level of government
no you know we we I think the other
level of frustration was that we we
pushed uh for some time to get a number
you know I mentioned this earlier this
morning that we we just couldn't go in
continue going into meetings with their
bilateral or the tripartite meetings
without a clear idea from Ops as to what
we needed we finally did get that and
that acted as a bit of a a mechanism to
unclog the decision making but it just
took too long okay so one issue then was
not having an understanding of what was
needed
soon enough is that right like if there
if that had been communicated sooner the
chain of events that subsequently
happened could have started earlier
right sorry can you I don't quite
understand the first part of your
question the first part is you're saying
that you you eventually got the number
of resources that were required and you
sent the letters off on February 7th but
had you understood what was required
earlier from January 31st you already
know that there are not enough resources
as we saw in your call with the prime
minister so had the chief communicated
to you the requirements and a number
sooner that could have been passed on
sooner and the sequence of events of the
meetings and trying to get those
resources could have begun sooner right
in theory I hope that would have been
the case yes okay and if the RCMP
officers had been secured and if that
commitment from the federal government
had been secured earlier then also the
situation could have potentially been
resolved sooner there was a delay there
in getting those Federal resources
correct that's correct and if the
province had been at the table at the
tripartite table and had been part of
the discussions and you were able to
communicate directly to the solicitor
general or to the premier what was
needed and when that also could have
helped uh resolve the situation sooner
correct that's correct okay thank you
so really it was a failure at all levels
would you agree with that yeah there's
no question that um
you know when you look at look back in
hindsight on what happened
there were many failure points along the
way and you know whether it was the city
or the provincial or the federal
governments we all have to take
responsibility for the fact that we did
not act fast enough and that the people
of Ottawa suffered the most as a result
of the fact that we did not clean up
that occupation for
three weeks it's been done sooner and so
we've talked a little bit about what the
Ops could have done differently with the
federal government and the provincial
government could have done differently
what about the municipality what could
the city have done differently
well as you know we have limited
um Authority and responsibility and
powers in a situation like this this was
early on literally within the first 24
hours this was clearly a police issue
and I'm not simply shrugging our
responsibility we had certain
responsibilities from bylaw and keeping
the streets open and Municipal um
requirements and policies and permitting
process this was just this overwhelmed
the city of Ottawa it overwhelmed us at
the administrative bureaucratic
operational and political levels we'd
never seen anything like this in our
lives and uh I think we were all quite
frankly Treading Water trying to keep
our head afloat as we saw this situation
unfold in front of us both on television
and in person so it was uh
um you know
a horrific experience for the people who
live there who tried to work there who
tried to visit our city it's had long
lasting impacts on public many people's
Health it's hurt our tourism industry
for instance and um you know we have to
rebuild that trust with the public and
with the police and we have to on a go
forward basis learn lessons and
hopefully the Commissioners report will
bring forward a series of
recommendations that we
if we ever have a situation like this we
do much better for the public
and so you said you know early on it was
clear that you were the city was
overwhelmed and that it couldn't
um it could didn't have the resources to
handle this not just on the police side
but on the municipal level as well
um
from the 31st I think it became clear
that this was not something that was
going to uh just resolve itself on its
own and I'll come back to this point
could declaring a state of emergency
earlier as of for example the 31st of
January have signaled that the city was
overwhelmed that it was treading water
and a signal to the other levels of
government to act accordingly no our
staff were very clear that again you
know I reiterate the fact that a
municipal state of emergency I think
people see on television Mayors in
United States cities declaring states of
emergency and the powers they have it
wouldn't have made a big difference at
all in hindsight I suppose if I was to
recommend to my successor we often get
this question by the public and people
get quite exercised why aren't you
declaring a state of emergency in
hindsight you know maybe we just declare
it so it brings that peace of mind to
the public that we know it's an
emergency we didn't need a document to
know that this was extraordinary
dangerous serious situation that was
going to have negative impacts on on our
residents and quite frankly the country
and the frustration was that the reason
why we wanted the RCMP there was
the protesters were protesting Federal
legislation right across from Parliament
Hill and the prime minister's office we
need a provincial support as they did in
Windsor because there was an economic
imperative that our city not be shut
down for three or four or five weeks
and so aside from maybe signaling that
need for assistance earlier uh with the
state of emergency what else could the
city have done differently and what else
will the city do differently next time
well we're going through the debate as
to what to do with Wellington Street for
instance I think we're going to have a
you know there's a motion pass many
motions pass by my colleagues on Council
and one of the Motions passed uh clearly
indicated that we have to do something
to protect the Parliamentary Precinct
both in terms of who should
excuse me who should be patrolling
Wellington Street the roles and
responsibilities of PPS versus OPP
versus Ops versus RCMP and then the
military police so we're we're very much
a jurisdictional challenge because we
have so many different layers of
responsibility but you know if I was
looking back and had the ability to you
know change what was done early on I
would have insisted that we have
barricades blockading Wellington Street
as a first step because as I said I
think it was symbolic on the part of the
truckers they wanted that as their
backdrop and uh you know forcing them to
come in on Slater Albert or another
parallel Street to Wellington who did
not have the same effect or impact right
so now we're going through a dialogue
with First Nations with Community groups
with uh all of the different policing
organizations uh to determine what are
we going to do with Wellington Street
because you know we were concerned a few
weeks after the Convoy there was the
motorcycle rally that was somewhat
disruptive but much better contained
with Chief Bell acting Chief Bell
and concern about July 1st there was
some protest but it didn't amount to
much and what's going to happen next
February and January and March are they
going to come back and try to repeat
um the um the behavior that we saw this
January and February so we have to be
better prepared to protect those
National symbols such as Parliament Hill
and you agree that it was unacceptable
that residents would have to go through
this for three weeks right absolutely it
was unacceptable for one day let alone
three weeks but we know that you know in
a free Society people have the right to
protest but this went well beyond
protests it was illegal activity hurtful
activity harmful to the Public's health
and um you know I think the um the
organizers
um you know seem to show very little
respect for the law and very little
respect for coming into our neighborhood
we even had members of parliament going
out and taking selfies and so on uh and
I asked those individuals who are
critical of us moving them out
how would you like to have 40 18
wheelers blaring their horn literally 24
hours a day
spewing diesel fume cooking a roast pig
on a on a spit
uh throwing off fireworks at all hours
threatening people uh being called you
know homophobic slurs and racist slurs
how would you like that in your
neighborhood in Saskatoon or Halifax or
Winnipeg or Red Deer you wouldn't
tolerate it for a minute downtown Ottawa
is not just some sterile environment
called Parliament Hill there are people
that live there thousands of people that
live there
and they were affected the most and uh
and and you know we have to do better if
this uh situation ever comes close to
being repeated we must do better for the
people of Ottawa
and I just want to ask you about the
negotiations that happened with the with
the protesters
um we we heard uh much more detail
yesterday about that and we'll hear more
detail um in future I'm hoping with the
superintendent Drummond's evidence
um can you just tell me what was your uh
what was your understanding of the deal
that was struck what was the deal
the deal was to let me just backtrack
for a moment the reason why I went down
this route was simply there was very
little progress being made on any front
to get the situation resolved and my
preoccupation number one was to bring
some relief to the residential Community
I wasn't as concerned about Parliament
Hill or Wellington Street even those
those are important symbols in our
country but the people being affected
the most were the people that were
trying to get a good night's sleep and
that we're living in that that Red Zone
and so I was approached as you know by
Mr French who said he had contacts with
trucking companies and and those that
some of those that were involved and he
said I'm willing at no charge I'm not
doing this for money or anything else
I'm trying to be helpful because he was
watching what everyone else was watching
on television this um
mess that was you know hurting so many
different people in small businesses so
I had I'd met him two or three times he
was the former Chief of Staff to the
premier Ford uh I I had occasion to deal
with them in my capacity as mayor and he
is chief of staff and was in two or
three meetings with he and the premier
over
a number of months
so I was a little skeptical uh you know
it was you know who does this guy know
you know and I said I'm not interested
in meeting them but you know if you can
come broker some kind of a deal to get
trucks out of the residential Community
good for you so I referred him to my
chief of staff and I think Steve
kanalakis
and over a couple of days they uh
negotiated an agreement based on the
letter that I sent to one of the
organizers Miss Leach indicating uh that
I would be willing to meet with them on
a number of conditions and they're I
think four different conditions I think
you have the letter I don't want to give
you the wrong conditions but basically
you know you've got to get a number of
trucks out of the residential area they
can't be replaced by other trucks and uh
if this is done and a couple of other
things then the mayor would be pleased
to meet with you this stem from the fact
that the police liaison teams approached
the city because there was concern that
communication had broken down between
the liaison teams from Ops and the
protest leaders and as you know there
was not one United voice that spoke for
the protesters there were many different
leaders in different camps
so uh uh prior to Mr French's call Steve
kadalakis did meet with a number of the
um protesters in his office uh and um
heard them out and when he told me
they'd asked for a meeting I was
initially reluctant not with me but I
said I'm not sure if this is a good idea
for Steve and he thought it was and I
said okay what were your concerns well
uh you know that we're meeting with this
group that has been causing such damage
and is this just a public relations
stunt to get a couple of pictures to say
look we met with the top City bureaucrat
and we're going to meet with the mayor
and we didn't get anything in return and
you know Remain the status quo
so they met and Steve Cadillac just
reported back that they seem to be
serious in their attempt to try to bring
the temperature down
and then I believe a day or two after
that's when Mr French got involved we
sent a letter Ms Leach sent a reply back
agreeing to the conditions and they
started I believe on the 13th or 12th to
move uh the trucks the letter I think
was the 13th they started to move some
of the trucks out of the residential
areas onto Wellington Street yes I
believe that was on the 14th on the
Monday the 14th they began the 13th I
think the third teaching was the letter
yes there was a meeting to sort out the
logistics and on the 14th they started
that movement and the police assigned a
senior officer to go down by basically
outside of this building roughly to um
to coordinate the movement of those
trucks and my understanding sorry no no
go ahead my understanding was that 40
big rigs moved and there were upwards of
60 other vehicles of different sizes
that started to move on to Wellington
away from the res residential community
and then that process was stopped when
the emergencies Act was implemented I
believe on the 14th okay and so in total
about over about a hundred vehicles in
total 40 of them big rigs and the
balance passenger vehicles and pickup
trucks right campers and things like
that so I think it was a total of about
102. okay and do you do you know why the
Police Stopped those operations did
anybody did anybody from the police tell
you that were this has been stopped for
these reasons
well um my recollection was that Steve
kanalakis said as a result of the
emergencies
emergencies act all of that activity was
stopped and they had to redeploy
um all of our police officers to the
main event which was to take back the
street okay but nobody from Ops said
that to you this was conveyed to you by
Mr kanilakis that's correct okay and so
in terms of the deal that was brokered
was it your understanding that this was
meant to be a way to solve the the
situation and what you had called the
occupation such that
all of the protesters would leave was
that what the steal was for no no we
were under no Illusions uh that it was
going to solve the problem was going to
solve one small part of the problem in a
residential area along the streets such
as you know Kent and O'Connor and so on
where people live to get them out of
Harm's Way so you know and that was made
very clear uh you know with my
conversations with Serge who had
discussions with Mr French that uh this
was not going to stop the rest of the
activity that we were fighting against
once they relocated to Wellington was
there any kind of assurances as to how
long they could stay there then was it
was was the city giving them permission
to to occupy Wellington Street well the
deal was they were to move out of the
residential areas onto Wellington Street
where no one lives as you know on
Ellington uh Wellington Street they're
just government buildings and most of
those were empty because obviously they
were in the red zone no one was working
out of their office from a safety point
of view so it was very much trying to
deal with one preoccupation that I had
which was the concern for those people
in the residential areas who had been
putting up with you know close to two
weeks two weeks plus of ear splitting
noise and you know train horns and so on
but to your knowledge did the city ever
suggest that once they were relocated
they could stay there on Wellington this
was uh they would be then protected from
any kind of police action to remove them
no no there was no such part of the
arrangement the reality is that we were
hoping that some of those individuals
who quite frankly were blocked in by
other trucks would decide to leave and I
was told by someone with the police
service I can't recall who it was that
in fact five or six of those trucks
actually just left because it was you
know they were stuck behind three or
four deep trucks if they wanted to leave
they couldn't leave anyway so I think
this gave a little bit of relief to
those people who felt they'd made their
point and they had to go home right but
at that time there were about four to
five hundred trucks occupying the
downtown right uh in the downtown there
were more at Coventry and more at Rito
and Sussex okay
now on February 14th we know that the
emergencies Act was invoked were you
consulted on on the invocation of the
emergencies act before it was invoked no
it wasn't okay
did the city request that it be invoked
no
did the city weigh in on whether it was
required necessary or needed
well when it was released I think like
most people uh very few people knew
exactly what the emergencies Act was to
be perfectly honest I remember growing
up in Quebec with the war measures Act
was and the implications that had for
The Province to get back and the rest of
the country but no one had raised the
emergencies act with us but when it was
invoked
and I was briefed on what its powers
were I thought this is a very positive
step
to getting this situation resolved once
and for all because of the provisions in
the act so I very much
supported it and I was
as you may recall the the current chair
of the Police Service the board Eli Al
shantier and I sent a letter to the
Prime Minister thanking him for invoking
the ACT because it actually acted as the
Catalyst for us to move forward and get
that whole situation in the downtown
core resolve once and for all and give
people their street and their homes back
and do you have any knowledge as to what
measures under the ACT were used in
order to affect the police operation
that ultimately ended the occupation
well uh the the single biggest
um
uh issue for us was that we did not even
if we moved in we didn't have the
capacity to move the trucks out because
we had basically two OC Transpo large
rake trucks tow trucks and so this
compelled tow truck companies to provide
the service and I can tell you it sounds
a little bit hokey but you know when I
came out of City Hall after the
emergency act I saw a whole row of tow
trucks parked on Laurier Avenue
I thought I'd never thought I'd see the
day where I'm so happy to see a tow
truck because these tow trucks uh ended
up doing an excellent job basically
hauling all of the trucks and trailers
and campers and everything else out of
Wellington Street
and you know what they had to do because
the companies were still fearful there'd
be retribution by some of the the
trucking Convoy they had to put decals
of the Ottawa Police Service over their
their company decal
almost deputizing them with this with
the logo so that they wouldn't be
harassed after the whole incident was
over but you don't have any knowledge as
to where the tow trucks came from or who
procured them or under what Authority
right
well I'm assuming that it would have
been a combination of the police and the
city uh that procured them I know for
instance I wrote to all right text at
John Tory because I saw the number of
tow trucks they had in Toronto and uh I
said where you know do you have tow
trucks that you can lend us and he said
uh well here's the names of three or
four different companies in Toronto that
we use because he had some but he
couldn't give up his TTC tow trucks just
as we couldn't give up our OC transport
tow truck so uh he provided names I
don't know and I passed that along to
Steve kanilakis and the city staff and
uh the tow trucks showed up because they
had no choice and they did great work
and they helped to speed up the cleanup
of the street
um substantially so just so I'm clear
um do you have do you know that these
tow trucks were procured under the
authority of the emergencies act or is
that your assumption
well um we were told by every tow truck
company that they were not going to
participate and then when the
emergencies Act was introduced uh tow
trucks suddenly appeared so I think the
cause and effect was yes the emergency
act compelled them I read the section
just the other day in preparation of
this hearing and that was made very
clear that they were not going to be
coming and helping us unless they were
forced by law and that's what the
emergencies act did okay so that's your
assumption based on the fact that they
were refusing to do it and then they
they showed up essentially well yeah I
don't know the procurement policies of
Ops versus the city's procurement policy
we often procure vehicles for instance
for the Ops so whether it was Ops doing
it directly or the city of Ottawa it was
one or the other okay but you don't know
I don't know definitively no and we know
on February 15th that slowly an opsb
reached a mutually agreeable separation
where you consulted on Chief slowly's
departure before it happened
um no I received um a press release like
everyone else did that day okay
it shouldn't be because consulted or
notified when the police chief is going
to be replaced or removed I thought it
would be helpful that I that information
was shared by me there's no requirement
I suppose of the the board to do that
but it would have been helpful because
if I was
found myself in a scrum and was being
told this for the first time it would
have been nice to have a heads up about
that okay and on the 16th of February
there was a city council special meeting
you recall that meeting yes okay so this
was the meeting after the emergencies
Act was invoked and this is the meeting
in which chair Deans was removed as
chair and of well as a member of the
board
um and so
my understanding is you had
Communications with chair Deans between
Chief slowly's resignation and before
the council meeting yes can you describe
those discussions
yeah it was on Zoom or teams uh with
myself Steve kanalakis uh Robin guest
from my office Serge arpan and
um councilor Deans and I believe one of
her assistants were on the zoom call
um and um
she um indicated based on a press
release that I can't recall the exact
wording but it was something to the
effects in the documents something to
the effect that we're working on a new
command structure
and I was uh curious about what this was
and also indicated a new command
structure and hiring a new chief
I thought well this seems a little
strange we're in the midst of a crisis I
didn't get into a long detailed
discussion with counselor Deans about
Chief slowly's departure and whether he
was fired or resigned or what the
compensation package was that was the
business of the Police Services Board
uh but it was clear that um
uh councilor Deans wanted to move
quickly to um
um bring in a a new acting Chief and
that was the bulk of the discussion that
we had that uh with that call and you
had a concern about that
I had a deep concern about it because
um you know we had uh Chief slowly on
one day
the next day we had interim Chief Bell
and then the next day uh the board was
going to appoint another Chief so we had
three Chiefs in three days that's not
stabilizing for the situation that we
were about to deal with in two or three
days when the police moved in to resolve
the situation
right but hiring a chief of police is
within the exclusive purview of the
Police Services Board right that's
correct okay
so they didn't need to consult with you
about that decision did they
technically no they didn't but I thought
um
you know I know for instance when Chiefs
have been hired in the past
um the board as a courtesy would bring
the individual or the proposed candidate
to my office for a get to know you uh
session
um and uh I was concerned about the
instability of having three Chiefs in
three days I didn't think that Ascent
um
um much confidence to the community
particularly when the the chief my
understanding was was in Florida at the
time and um probably couldn't make it
back uh you know in time to oversee the
implementation of the plan to clean up
Wellington Street which took place that
weekend right but that decision was the
boards to make right that's right and um
councilor Deans or chair Deans at the
time uh said to the effect you you don't
want me to sign this contract because
the contract had not been signed
and I said yes uh I can't tell you what
to do because you're the independent and
autonomous but I think it would be wise
not to sign a contract until we get this
situation stabilized in Ottawa to have
someone from another jurisdiction come
and try to you know learn the the street
names let alone the command structure
that the chief had put in place and uh
chair Dean's uh committed not to signing
the contract and then later that day it
was discovered that in fact she had
signed the contract
which she was entitled to do as chair of
the board yes but she'd indicated that
she was not going to do it because she
uh understood my deep concerns about
moving at that pace and uh did did you
consider that that discussion with her
about asking her not to sign the the
contract or telling her that you wished
her not to sign the contract uh
compromise the independence of the board
in any way
no I didn't think it did it was
ultimately her choice and she said she
wouldn't sign the contract so I I took
her at her word okay and
um
very briefly I will take you to Ott
29762
and that date is
uh this is the in-camera council meeting
minutes of February 16. okay
and at page six of that
counselor Lieber at the top observed
that the motion spoke of a loss of
confidence in the board which was linked
to the hiring decisions
so it says there that the um the motion
to remove the chair
um as a member of the board was linked
to the hiring decisions now what we
heard yesterday was that the motion was
linked to a loss of confidence that you
had lost in in chair Dean's can you
clarify what the um why this motion was
brought forward to remove charadines
well uh you're correct uh from my
perspective it was the um decision to uh
sign the contract despite giving me
assurance that she wouldn't sign the
contract number one and secondly the
instability that that
um had and thirdly that no one really
outside of the Police Services Board was
was consulted there was no public
consultation with different groups in
society in civil society and in fact it
was two-thirds about two-thirds of
council that voted to remove councilor
Deans as a member of the Police Services
Board and the rest of the Motions uh
including appointing Council Al shantiri
who was then supported at their next
board meeting to be made the new the new
chair of the board
right and in this uh in camera minutes
um we don't see any mention of uh the
assurances that the chair gave to you
according to you
um about not hiring a new Chief
um but that it was linked rather to the
board's hiring decisions and ultimately
as you know uh the the chief that had
been selected uh ultimately rescinded uh
his uh his his offer to to take on that
role uh as a result of the turnover at
the board you're aware of that yes and
uh after he uh sent the board a note
asking that his name be withdrawn from
consideration I phoned him to thank him
for a gracious way that he dealt with a
very awkward and potentially
embarrassing situation to himself and
his
reputation and the fact that he was not
going to pursue any action against the
city and wished us well in our search
and it was a very civil and kind call
from
the the former Chief of uh Waterloo I
believe
and before the motion was introduced at
Council you had asked chair Deans to
resign correct no she asked if I'd lost
confidence in her and at that point at
that meeting I said I'm talking to
members of council I can't give you an
answer on that but then obviously when
um we learned that the contract had been
signed despite assurance that it
wouldn't be signed I did lose confidence
in her and that's why I supported the
motion by councilor moffatt okay
two-thirds of counsel and do you
consider that the turnover at the board
contributed to that instability that you
were looking to avoid
well uh you'd have to ask the province
because they rescinded the three
appointees to their their board as well
but the reality was that
um the uh the board as you know does not
involve itself in operational matters
it's policy and budget driven so
um you know the challenge we had was
that I think there had been greater
instability if we had uh Chief Bell
interim Chief Bell who was working on
implementing the plan signing off on it
and ready to deploy the officers into
the Red Zone to clean it up it would
have been I think it would have delayed
the process if you had someone from an
entirely different jurisdiction who did
not know and there's no criticism Mr
turrigan but he wouldn't know the
intricacies of the city of Ottawa and
their their Road grids and so on that
would have you know if he was coming in
on Monday he would have said don't start
till I get there I assume he'd want to
be involved and so I was pleased that
when Chief Bell uh you know oversaw the
operation we got signed off by the other
police services and the action that took
place at uh on Wellington Coventry and
Rideau was quite remarkable at how
quickly they moved it out and cleaned
excuse me it cleaned out uh the streets
as fast as they did and as efficiently
as they did and without losing a life
okay thank you and I see the
commissioner glaring at me so I'm out of
time and those are all my questions for
you thank you thank you very much
okay thank you uh so we're now into the
uh the second phase of the testimony so
if uh could call on the Convoy
organizers to go first
foreign
mayor Watson good morning my name is
Brendan Miller I'm Council afternoon
which is a organization that represents
the protesters that were in your city in
January and February 2022.
set up here
so mayor Watson following up on some of
my friends questions that have been put
to you today and how things have come
out can you agree with me that you did
not handle the situation
that was before you in January and
February of 2022 properly
no I think uh I would characterize it as
given all of the information and the
circumstances we did the best we could
which obviously was not good enough
and can you agree with me that you
politicalized the protests and
politicalized the situation
no I disagree with that all right
can you agree that the politicalization
of the matter
for which you claim was not yourself but
that the matter was politicalized by the
federal governments
no
you agree that making any of the
protests a political issue in the
governance level
created problems no
can you agree with me that the following
governments and agencies handled this
matter properly first the government of
Ontario
ultimately yes they did handle it
properly but it took some time to get to
that stage okay and the Ontario
Provincial Police
the same
and the Ottawa Police Service
yeah they were on the ground from day
one but obviously as I've expressed I
would have liked to have seen
the intervention to bring back our
streets to our people done much sooner
right and so you've said that they were
on the ground from day one right that's
right they were the
jurisdictional police service right and
as the mayor of a town you don't have
the or the city you don't have the
security clearance or the clearance to
know what the actual operational
activities are of a police agency
correct well it's not a security
clearance matter it's a matter that
there's a separate autonomous
organization called the Ottawa Police
Services Board that has full
jurisdiction over policy and
governance of the police board and the
hiring and firing of four key officers
and that is their responsibility the
only direct link that the city has is
you may know from the police services
Act is that we approve or reject the
budget of the police or right so I'm
going to take you back so I'll just be
more narrow so during the protests you
did not know what the operational
activities were of the Ontario
Provincial Police correct I wouldn't
know what their operational activities
were but they were coming under the
jurisdiction and responsibility of the
Ottawa Police Service but again I was
never made aware of the operational plan
nor was I given the specific time that
it was going to be launched because it
would be outside my jurisdiction you
could put two and two together and you
started to see more police arrive you
knew it was happening imminently but I
didn't have the specific date nor should
I right and so you see you you saw
certain uniformed officers arrive right
from the Ontario Provincial Police
well I I don't know if all of them were
in their uniform there were lots that
were clean clothes I suppose but I saw a
lot of Opp officers in Ottawa when we
finally got to that 1800 number that's
for sure you didn't know how many
officers really the Ontario Provincial
Police had here
from January 26th until the invocation
of the emergencies acted you
well our chief said that on average we
had about 50 to 55 police officers from
Opp at different stages on a daily basis
all right but nowhere near the 1500 that
the solicitor general referred to on one
day and so just in summary you had with
respect to their operational plans and
what they were doing and everything that
the police were up to
you did not know what they were doing
either the Ontario Provincial Police or
the Ottawa Police Service right they
didn't tell you because they couldn't
well there's the church and state you
know there's a separation the Police
Services Board is autonomous under
provincial legislation and even the
board itself and I sat on the board for
a number of years but even the board
itself uh does not have the ability to
direct the chief on an operational
matter you know so if they wanted to get
together and say you know pass a motion
we want you to go and uh you know take
care of speeders on Carling Avenue for
the next two months that would be ruled
out of order it's not appropriate right
so I just want to make it very clear and
I'd just like you to answer this
question if you don't mind
the Ontario Provincial Police and the
Ottawa Police Service
did not and could not update you on
their actual operational plans correct
not on the operational plans but
obviously we received information in
terms of their discussions with other
police services in terms of securing
those resources in the nation's capital
now you used to be the communication
director for the speaker of the house
and federal Parliament is that correct
that's correct and you then became a
member of provincial Parliament
no I became a member of city council and
then a member of provincial Parliament
after that no then mayor then mayor and
then a member of provincial Parliament
after that no then president Canadian
tourism commission well congratulations
but at some juncture uh you became a
member of provincial Parliament correct
you got it now all right thank you very
much and when you became that member of
provincial Parliament it was with the
Liberal Party of Ontario at the time is
that correct correct and you then became
the minister of Municipal Affairs and
Housing from October 30th 2007.
uh yes and you held that office until
January 12 2010 correct and the minister
of Municipal Affairs uh that's the
ministry that oversees the city of
Ottawa and all of our municipalities
under the municipalities Act Right will
the minister is responsible for the acts
uh you know I'm not the over Seer of
municipalities but they are my
um I suppose a client if you you could
put it that way that any Municipal issue
I was responsible for in cabinet right
but you're very familiar of course then
because you held that office with the
municipal act correct
I am yes right and you'd also be
familiar with that as the mayor of a
city yes all right and the current
minister of Municipal Affairs and at the
time of the protest was Mr Steve Clark
right correct and the City of Ottawa
like all municipalities uh across the
country it's a creature statute that
exists at the behest of the provincial
legislature is that correct uh yes
constitutionally yes and you agree that
if provincial parliament of Ontario
wanted to they could set out how they
want Ottawa to be governed and can
basically do what they wish in that
regard right pretty much yeah
and you can agree with me that the city
of Ottawa is treated the same by the
government of Ontario as any other
municipality in Ontario aren't they
it depends on the issue there are some
times where we feel that we're under
served in terms of provincial grants and
contributions and other times where we
feel we're treated fairly okay I've not
seen in any of the many records in this
proceedings that have been produced that
at any time whatsoever that you
contacted Minister Clark
uh I don't know if I had a call with
Steve or not I certainly had discussions
with his colleague Minister McLeod on a
number of occasions and she was very
helpful in relaying information but
um really the matter we were dealing
with uh fell completely outside the
jurisdiction of the minister of
Municipal Affairs and Housing it was
very much the solicitor general who was
the lead Minister and that was Amplified
by the fact that the premier brought her
on the calls okay so the the issue that
you were facing was a resource issue was
it not resource of people yes police
officers right and as the former
minister of Municipal Affairs you know
then that under Section 302 of the
municipal act that the minister May upon
such terms and conditions as it
considers available or advisable make
grants and loans and provide other
financial assistance to a municipality
right you're aware of that yes and at no
time did you ever ask for any form of
Finance financial assistance from
Minister Clark did you no I did with the
premier
you did with the premier right but you
and I both know from your former
workings as the actual Minister that you
go through The Minister's office right
you ask them for financial assistance
and they can give you a grant and give
you money to deal with things like
protests on an emergency basis even if
they want right no there has to be a
program in place you just don't go up to
the minister of Municipal Affairs and
ask for a grant we indicated to the
premier very clearly as I did with the
Prime Minister and his ministers that we
are counting on those two orders of
government when this is all said and
done and finished that we would be uh
keeping very close tabs of all of the
extraordinary costs that we incurred in
order to bring peace to our city and
both the Prime Minister and the premier
said that we'll be there for you to help
financially and we have since submitted
all of our costs it's in the tens of
millions of dollars because as you know
particularly when the Municipal Police
Services arrive they have to be put up
in hotels they have to be given three
meals a day they you know there's
there's expenses and we reimburse all of
those municipalities I for instance ran
into the maribelville a few uh weeks ago
here in Ottawa a few months ago rather
at the Amo conference and he thanked us
for the quick repayment of the invoice
that they received so
um the premier was very
um specific and very generous as was the
Prime Minister that they would be here
to help us financially because the
protesters were coming not to protest
the corporation of the city of Ottawa
they're protesting mandates that were
imposed by the provincial and federal
government we happened to be the um as I
said the meat and the sandwich were
caught in this middle fight between
protesters and two other orders of
government that are responsible for
various mandates with respect to covet
19. so
um you know I wouldn't have gone to the
minister Affairs and Housing because
most of his funding on an emergency
basis is through the
drap program the disaster relief program
this was not a disaster so it wasn't a
disaster no it was a crisis okay
and the disaster is a natural disaster
the bad storm we had a little while ago
the the flooding in 2017 2019 the
tornado in 2018 that's where we seek
support of the minister of Municipal
Affairs and Housing and also through
again the solicitor general when we
called the Army end to help with the
sandbagging and the flooding in Ottawa
right so the thing is is this is can you
agree with me as the minister former
minister of Municipal Affairs that
having a program set out is not a
requirement
for the minister to give a city a grant
they can actually just do it under the
municipal act can they not well there
has to be a program in place there's not
a slush fund that's kept by the Ministry
of Municipal Affairs and Housing that is
there in case of a bunch of truckers
come and uh take over a city there's no
such program I understand that but what
I'm saying to you is this is that the
minister and when you were minister
you had the power to Grant these grants
even if there was no program is that
much no that's not true okay and and
secondly I'm not sure why we would be
going to the minister of Municipal
Affairs and Housing for a grant all we
were asking for was the compensation to
make us whole to ensure that we received
after the whole situation had been been
resolved to make sure that we had uh the
necessary receipts and our Treasurer is
very good at this along with the CFO of
the Ottawa Police all of the costs were
incurred I think the figure was and I
stand to be corrected well over 36
million dollars in costs so that is
being uh okay so now the city of Ottawa
then had adequate Financial funds to
deal with the protest
uh yes we did our healthy Reserve funds
so the only issue is was actually
getting bodies right
well getting bodies uh yes but also uh
having the emergencies act so that we
could get tow trucks and we could have
um a plan in place that once the
um the police moved in we could actually
move those trucks that refused to move
and Tow them to a um
a central location just I just got
something you said you said you wanted
the emergencies act you needed it to get
the tow trucks well we needed something
to get the tow trucks because we're not
successful so when the emergencies Act
was uh introduced and it was made clear
specifically one line that Towing was
one of the requirements that people
could not say no to that was a big win
for us in the city of Ottawa and I take
it uh Mr Mayor that you have of course a
relationship with probably numerous
members of parliament from your position
as mayor in Ottawa right correct yes did
anybody tell you before the emergencies
Act was invoked that it was coming no
all right so you didn't know if you were
going to get these powers or what have
you were going to be ordered with
respect to Towing vehicles
no when they when the Act was
um introduced and my staff
basically printed off a copy of the act
and highlighted those sections that we
could use the one that caught my
attention the first was the towing
capacity to clean up the situation in
Centertown and by the market so you do
know and you've already mentioned that
of course the
Ottawa Police Service Board is
independent of the Police Service the
Ottawa Police Service and they have no
ability to order operational sort of
orders or bylaws right
yes they don't pass bylaws but and as
the former minister of Municipal Affairs
you also know that of course uh the
province of Ontario and the premier and
the ministers at the provincial level
they have no ability to order the opp to
do anything with respect to resources
either that's correct right so you know
these two things right and you knew them
at the time yes right and it would have
been the commissioner of the opp that
would be making those decisions right
yes he was in contact with Chief slowly
right and at no time and that's Mr
Thomas correct is that correct that's
correct right and you agree with me that
at no time uh well you were looking for
these resources did you contact the
commissioner of the opp to outline what
you wanted right no that would be
inappropriate that would be
inappropriate to contact an opp officer
he's the commissioner of the opp what's
the difference you're okay with having
contact with the prime minister of the
country
but you're not okay having contact with
the commissioner of the opp to ask him
for what you need because we have a
system in place where we do not have
politicians interacting directly with uh
police officers or superintendents or
Commissioners that would be highly
inappropriate that's why as a politician
my counterpart is not the opp
commissioner it's the premier and the
minister responsible for the solicitor
general so it would be highly
inappropriate during this whole period I
did not once speak to the commissioner
of the opp or the commissioner of the
RCMP completely inappropriate so you
know I I dealt at the political level
with members of parliament members of
provincial Parliament ministers and the
premier and the Prime Minister that was
my role in this this period in our
City's history
okay and did you have phone calls uh
with the Minister of Justice and and the
uh the premier with respect to what you
needed
well we had discussions with the
solicitor general and the premier and at
the federal level it was the minister of
emergency preparedness and Public Safety
in the prime minister right and so again
just in your statement that you provided
I didn't see when the dates were that
you had these conversations with the
premier uh when were they what were the
dates well I'll have to look them up uh
I don't recall what they are but I
believe it was in um
it was two or three during the month of
uh I believe February February
so it's time to be corrected but I I
don't know the specific date site but it
was the prime minister's office did
provide
um
a quasi-transcript so we have the
specifics on that but these calls that I
had with the premier were um one of them
was uh basically he called me on my cell
phone uh we had a long discussion about
the situation that was on the ground and
then the other was when the minister of
the solicitor general joined us and we
had a discussion about the need for OPP
officers okay so and I can tell you that
the the Prime Minister and the premier
were talking around that time too and he
the premier had told the Prime Minister
and I'm going to put it to you that he
also told you that he had no ability to
order the opp to provide you officers it
had to come from the commissioner and
the opp themselves right right right and
he told you that I don't know if you
told me that but the solicitor general
sent a letter as we saw earlier today
um indicating that she had sent our
request the letter that councilor Deans
and I sent to the premier and the
solicitor general she had sent that to
the commissioner of the opp which is the
proper route not telling him what to do
indicating that this request has come in
and to please
take the appropriate action right and
the premier told you that he wouldn't
join the tripartite meetings because it
was pointless
he felt it was a waste of time right and
it was
how do you know that because you were
looking for officers and they couldn't
order officers no that's I I don't think
you fully understand the situation that
I can't pick up the phone and start uh
barking orders at a commissioner of any
Police Service whether it's the opp or
the RCMP there's a protocol in place and
that protocol is to have a politician to
politician and the RCMP and the minister
said the same thing he can't direct
commissioner Leckie but he can certainly
pass along our request and she made the
decision and we thank her and the
commissioner because at the end of the
day they did provide the resources that
ended up cleaning up this terrible
situation our residents found themselves
in right and this protocol that you've
been talking about and mentioned is it
in writing
well it's it's the law that politicians
are not allowed to direct Police
Services it's very uh I I understand
that but there's nothing that I know of
at least and if you could point me to it
that says that you were prevented from
either callering commission calling
commissioner lucky you're calling the
commissioner of the opp and saying hey
we need some we need some more resources
can you do this yeah again I think that
would be entirely inappropriate you know
to give the powers of um
operational
responsibilities to politicians I'm not
saying that I'm asking you if there's an
actual policy that says you are not
allowed to call and make a request to
the police is there a policy in that
regard well our city solicitor advised
that the route that we should be taking
is the letter to the premier and the
Prime Minister and the two approach okay
so it wasn't a protocol it was what the
city solicitor told you to do well I'm
assuming that he would have told me what
to do based on the uh the law of the
land okay
I'll ask him about that when he
testifies sure the other questions I
have for you
have to do
with the mediator now you had asked the
story with what the mediator you had
asked the federal government if they
could appoint an independent mediator is
that right
uh yes
and the federal government said no
that's correct right and they said no
because they didn't want to look like
they were engaging with the pro with the
protesters is that right you'd have to
ask them I can't speculate why although
as you know there was a a movement on
the same day by two colleagues on
Council to bring a resolution to council
to ask the federal government to
um allow a mediator to try to find a
middle ground that motion never made its
way onto the council agenda so
you said that you had no issues with
financial resources at the time so why
didn't you just hire a mediator
well again uh the issue that the
protesters were in Ottawa was not to
protest the city of Ottawa but Federal
and provincial Mass mandates among other
issues that the truckers were upset with
so it was not really up to the city to
start that kind of a broad-based
mediation what we did do and what we
were somewhat successful was to secure
an agreement by Miss Leach and those
truckers who
fell under her jurisdiction for lack of
a better term and I believe that was
successful we were able to get 40 big
rigs in about 60 smaller ones out of the
residential area and on to Wellington
Street so that was not mediation that
was an individual Mr French who came
forward and offered at no charge the
ability to see if there was some common
ground between our Police Service and
the um the protesters but in terms of
why the federal government didn't want
to deal with a mediator you'd have to
ask them so Mr French steps forward
he says I can help
and he finds some common ground and was
going back and forth of course between
the city and the protesters yes so he
mediated the issue
well he was a facilitator because he
ended up getting a a letter from me and
then a subsequent response from Ms Leach
and the ACT activities took place I
think the next day and then they were
halted once the Enviro once the
emergencies Act was implemented I
believe on the 14th right and after that
agreement was done
the protesters followed the agreement
and tried to get on to Wellington and
the only thing that ended up stopping
them was the police is that correct no
the police were there actually to help
facilitate uh and
traffic managed the um the congestion to
bring them on to Wellington Street and
away from the residential areas so a
senior officer was assigned and my
understanding was that it worked quite
well and then the emergencies act
basically put a halt to that because all
resources for police were needed to
clear the area the following days I put
it to you that after the emergencies act
and it was invoked and you may have
heard some of this evidence yesterday
that there was just a change and that it
was the city who decided not to follow
through with the agreement with the
protesters
and that was what happened with respect
to that agreement
no I believe that we did our best to
live up to the agreement and um as did
the truckers who did move and we
appreciate that because that was the
first time as you know where there had
been any kind of movement on the ground
there was a level of frustration there
was more and more rowdism that was
taking place in the uh on the streets of
Ottawa and we felt as my number one
preoccupation was to protect those
residents who had been putting up with
horn honking 24 hours a day diesel fumes
that were coming into their apartments
and Condominiums and general unruliness
where people were afraid to leave their
homes right and so you would agree then
these statements that have been out by
various people that the protesters did
not live up to the agreement are
incorrect in fact they did
so I'm not sure who you're referring to
there's been you know it's okay but you
agree that the the protesters
lived up to their end of the bargain
right on that particular issue yes right
and you had early set in your evidence
that you know you couldn't negotiate
with these people rationally but you did
have that done in the end didn't you no
I didn't get involved in it because I I
did not believe that I should be
personally involved but Mr French acted
as a go-between between the city Ops and
the the group um under misleach and um
you know we're we're appreciative of Mr
French he had uh really no skin in the
game it was not being paid for this
there was no business angle I think he
saw what was happening and right his
Capital as well and sorry I don't mean
to interrupt but I just want to get my
question answered so
they said you said earlier you couldn't
negotiate with them rationally and you
had no dealings with any negotiations
with them except for the issue with Mr
French right I had one call one or two
calls with Mr French and then it was
handed over to Mr catalakis and Mr right
and so prior to that time you had no
attempt or nothing of involvement with
respect to attempting to negotiate with
the protesters correct that's correct
all right so your statement earlier that
you could not negotiate with these
people rationally you agree that the one
time that you actually had any
involvement whatsoever you did
right you had a rational negotiation
that resulted in an agreement correct no
I didn't because I wasn't involved until
the final agreement I understand okay
thank you those are my questions thank
you
okay thank you the
next stop is uh Mr slowly his Council
afternoon mayor Watson afternoon
um commissioner may I just before I
begin know
um or ask you what your preference is
about the lunch break should we I have I
believe 25 minutes uh could we rise at
one o'clock would that be we certainly
can we can take uh 10 minutes 10 minutes
now and 15 minutes after lunch very good
thank you break you up into two two
parts thank you very much
um
mayor Watson a couple of things if I if
I can please uh this afternoon
um you told the commissioner that
throughout this
this experience
um Chief slowly
uh had your confidence that's correct
and that was right up until the time he
resigned that's correct
um Chief slowly to your observation you
obviously were speaking with him during
this time on a daily basis almost daily
almost daily
um uh during the time that you worked
with him and observed him do you agree
that he performed his duties in good
faith
he did obviously I was not involved
behind the scenes but certainly in any
dealings he had with me or senior City
staff we came away confident and pressed
number one and secondly I thought he was
a very good communicator he was
reluctant to have daily press
conferences which was a bit of a bone of
contention but when he did I thought he
handled himself with distinction thank
you and I I was going to say you you
obviously were not with him during all
the entirety of these operations but in
your observation of him with your
colleagues whether they be political uh
political
[Music]
members of council or political staff or
city staff he was always professional
he was I think if I could just elaborate
on that
um I think he um he found uh the
non-stop flow of questions and and
complaints and and so on stressful as we
all did and uh I think at times he
probably was frustrated himself with uh
the volume of work that was coming in
and legitimate questions by members of
council because as you know
the members of council were representing
the voices of those people particularly
in Somerset Ward and Rito Vanier that
were under tremendous stress
and that stress percolated its way up to
everyone within the organization
including the chief but I certainly
um you know I never saw him be
disrespectful to any member of council I
think he was firm from time to time with
a few members of council that what
you're proposing Mr or Mrs counselor is
illegal but I never saw him lose his
cool thank you and finally like you and
like probably every other person
involved in this on the on the city Side
just confining ourselves to that for the
moment he worked Around the Clock
yes I think that's the same case for his
command team
um and a lot of our staff and so on I as
I said uh on what I saw of him uh I I
had his confidence or I was confident in
him uh I don't know what was going on
behind the scenes in terms of the
operations I I'd heard through Mr
catalakis there was a level of um
um
division within the various police
forces having never been involved in a
protest or a occupation of this
magnitude I would not have any knowledge
to compare that kind of give and take
that we heard was taking place behind
the scenes but certainly it was my
expectation that he would continue to
see the operation through and clean out
uh Wellington and Rito Center and
Overbrook forums understood now
um just a couple of things then you
observed and that
what occurred here in Ottawa last
January and February was unprecedented
first of all yes and and also something
that had probably not been witnessed for
for two generations
well you know as I mentioned earlier
um to the commissioner and to
commissioner Council that you know I've
been in public Life as a political
representative for 25 years and nothing
comes close to this now I think
obviously kovid because it affected so
many people in Ottawa over 800 people
died that was a a bigger challenge but
in a condensed period of time in a
condensed section of the city Nothing
Compares To What We went through and I
think the vast majority of people who
saw what was going on empathize with our
citizens but there were those who
thought it was no big deal and that was
what was frustrating I think for myself
and the front line officers and and the
chief right including
as you've described to the commissioner
your effort to try to engage the other
levels of government The Province the
federal government
um it was the source of some frustration
for you on the basis that they did not
come to the aid of the of of the city
and its residence in what you would have
thought was a timely fashion I I wanted
it to move faster I suspect the federal
government will say well you don't have
your plan ready yet so why are you
asking for resources but we knew
regardless of what the plan was there
was going to be a need for a significant
number of new police officers coming in
particularly public order police
officers those that basically deal with
crowd control so regardless of the fact
that we didn't have all of the the t's
crossed and the eyes dotted on the plan
we need it and we knew there was going
to be lag time by the time you make the
decision and the time they get on a
plane and arrive in Ottawa and and get
geared up it was going to take some time
so yes you know the frustration I have
and and where I think there was a
failure point was I wish all orders of
government had worked faster
to get the plan ready and to get the
officers on the ground and we could have
resolved this hopefully by the end of
week one instead of week three very
difficult I think this tell me if you
agree very difficult to finalize a plan
an operational plan
until you know what resources you have
for for do you agree well I'm not a
police expert so I can't give you an
informed decision I certainly on the
surface of it uh we knew that we were
going to need hundreds and hundreds of
police officers because we were
outnumbered 100 to 1 or 200 to one you
just have to see the video of uh the the
Raves and the dance parties and the
honking of the horns and the all of the
other activities that were taking place
that really stole neighborhoods away
from the people who live in them right
what perhaps more precisely what I was
getting at is that if the RCMP or the
opp in the aggregate had told told the
city through the proper channels right
that instead of 1800 or 1900 additional
Personnel the only Personnel available
was 1 000 in the aggregate right
um what I I understand you were
in listening to your Ops colleagues and
Mr and Steve K and others was that the
the finalization of a plan would require
some knowledge of what that number is if
you're sending a thousand people the
plan is different than if you're sending
1900s you agree I I on the surface I
think that is makes eminent sense yes
um now commissioner may I suggest then I
think I've got just about one o'clock
would can we rise here and I'll yep
we'll rise until uh two o'clock thank
you mayor great thank you the commission
is in recession
those up
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you
order a lot
the commission is reconvened that
commissioner
good afternoon
you're ready to go all set okay thank
you I'll see
thank you mayor Watson
um
a couple of things please if I can about
the cast your mind back to the to the
period before the convo Convoy
protest came to Ottawa in in January I
think you touched on this
um city of Ottawa has uh a long
experience with public protests we do
yes besides quite quite apart from all
of the events that are held by the city
and there are many of them
as they
home to the nation's capital and
Parliament
the city
has a long tradition of
respecting the Democratic right to to
protest that's correct including
protests against mandates and
restrictions that were imposed by
provincial or federal government
as a consequence of the pandemic correct
and in terms of uh the of the use of
vehicles or in
the the the bringing to Ottawa if I can
put it that way of vehicles by
protesters the city also has a long
experience of allowing facilitating
vehicles to come uh to to to the city
yes on occasion uh there's been
arrangements made where they'll Park uh
on Wellington Street for instance I know
there was a farm protest some time ago
and and that was arranged in
collaboration with the police liaison
and it worked well and they left after
they had their speeches and in this case
as you pointed out to the commissioner
the expectation was that the protesters
would arrive in vehicles make their
their point demonstrate and and pack up
and leave
I think most objective people would see
that as a
most likely scenario there's no
thought that this thing was going to
drag on for three weeks when you know
the first time I saw some trucks on
Wellington was the Thursday before the
Friday and I think there were two or
three pickup trucks with some flags and
that was it and then obviously we
received a lot more vehicles on the
Friday and the Saturday and it jammed
the street there was no indication of
which you were made aware
that the protest was either expected to
last as long as it did or to be uh
conducted in the fashion that it was
correct I I had no information that it
was going to go on for three weeks I
think we saw early on there was a little
bit of disorganization in terms of
timing of speakers which pushed their
agenda back and I thought you know worst
case scenario they'll be gone back home
by Sunday right and am I also right that
from your perspective as the mayor of
the city of Ottawa there was no
indication from your policing Partners
at the opp or the RCMP that you should
consider this protest to be any
different than protests of a similar
kind in the past
to the best of my lives I don't recall
receiving any briefing of that nature
that would have been through the police
to the city manager because obviously
there are implications for City Services
rerouting of buses and parking
regulations and so on and had there been
a plan to or had there been information
that that suggested that the trucks
should be intercepted and not permitted
into the city then obviously your city
manager and the staff below uh him would
have had to engage in a traffic plan and
some operation to to put the trucks
somewhere other than residential
neighborhoods around Parliament Hill yes
and as you know the jurisdiction for the
highways and entry on to an off highways
is the provincial government through the
opp not the Ops got it two other quick
things about this please
um did you understand that that Chief
slowly had engaged his command team and
and that acting deputy chief Ferguson
was responsible for the operations plan
that's correct and the deputy chief Bell
was responsible for intelligence that's
my understanding yes
and did you also know that before the
weekend protesters arrived Chief slowly
or his delegates had had already secured
additional police resources from other
Municipal police forces under
memorandums of understanding that exist
well I knew he was making those calls
with other Chiefs I don't know the
extent of it but my understanding over
the last 25 years is that uh you know
there's a reciprocal agreement when
police services need help we've often
been sent to help in circumstances
outside our jurisdiction and vice versa
so that I I just assumed that would be
taking place because he has those
contacts across the province sonnet can
I just show you a memorandum if I hope
to have the number correctly that was a
memo that I think you sent it's kind of
can I have some assistance just pleasing
dialing up
Ott
I think four zeros might be five seven
four six
and then I have dot zero zero one
afterwards if that
helps just uh bear with me mayor Watson
see if um you recognize this document
um yeah just maybe start there do you
see it says draft response to
demonstration emails McKinney comments
had stated that Thursday the 27th of
January do you see that I do yes and you
introduced the name to us earlier I
think Robin guest that's a member of
your staff director of policy correct
and then uh there are a couple of other
people uh to whom that email is
addressed at the top including
um a witness who appeared yesterday your
Chief of Staff Mr arpan Right could we
just scroll down please for the mayor
just
uh they're just stopped there if if we
could please the
um
do you recognize this as
a memorandum that was prepared
either at your direction or the
direction of your staff for the purposes
of communicating uh with your uh
colleagues on Council
uh I think can you scroll so I can see
the whole memo please yeah sure could we
please and just uh I think the other
question probably
yeah this uh this was
um a letter that was a draft uh for
people uh writing me
um via email about the Convoy because
the the gentleman it was from if you
scroll up to the top again Ben Poirier
uh he's our correspondence officer in
the mayor's office so he would have uh
received a draft from probably Robin
guest in terms of this was the template
that we would use initially when people
started to write in with concerns about
the Convoy understood and I won't go
through all of it but you described a
reference in it to past practice to the
to the right to protest in our democracy
and uh that the uh the plans that were
in place for a safe a safe weekend
correct okay understood thank you that's
that's fine thanks very much
um along the way a little a little later
you had and again I when I say you had
the city has a solicitor I think uh
David White yes and Mr White was
requested to prepare a set of options
that I think were legal options I don't
know if this came as a consequence of a
direction that you gave or perhaps
um someone under your direction but
could I please show the mayor uh
Ott
0029767
just want to while that's coming up
mayor Watson just to orient you that
believe that Mr White prepared a set of
options a list of options rather that
could be
considered by counsel
in respect of the ongoing demonstration
do you see that it's dated February the
7th does this refresh your recollection
that Council or you directed Mr White to
prepare that list
uh this is a memo to counselor Deans so
I assume based on the the wording of the
first paragraph she'd asked for this
information
uh not not my office but um it was I
remember seeing this was interesting
to look at the different uh acts that
were out there but uh this was something
that um I believe councilor Deans had
asked for and it was sent to her from
Julia keast
and among among the options that
um were addressed in this memorandum of
course we we see that at three the
federal emergencies act and there are a
number of others including
um the final one concerning injunctive
relief do you see that I do yes were you
engaged in any of the discussions that
were ongoing about whether an injunction
was
available and advisable
well I know that she slowly had asked um
can't recall the exact date but asked
for uh staff legal staff at the city of
Ottawa to consider an injunction I
believe on the 30th of January
stand to be corrected on that and then
um
then there was the city asked us legal
staff to draft an injunction to enforce
Municipal bylaws on February 11th
and they got the injunction on the 14th
but unfortunately then the American well
not unfortunately but subsequently the
emergencies Act
overrode uh the injunction understood
and so that's fine thanks uh for the for
the memorandum we can take that down as
to the emergencies act you've explained
to the commissioner your your
perspective about that
um from your observation
the emergencies act played an important
role in the peaceful resolution of these
demonstrations it very much did yes and
the the the police services that were on
the ground uh were provided additional
additional Powers not just to deal with
the those who were
occupying those spaces but also to deal
with any anyone who might wish to to
come and and participate in the future
correct okay can I just ask you now
please about resources you explained the
um that Chief slowly was requested to
provide a detailed list of the resources
particularized the resources that the
Ops required do you recall that yes and
am I right that he was asked to do that
on February 5th at the police sir by by
chair Deans and the Police Services
Board I believe that's correct and then
provided it the next day February 6th
yes and um we had to redraft the the
letter and decided that both councilor
Deans and I would sign the letter that
was sent to the Premier Minister Jones
prime minister Trudeau and Minister
Mendocino and prior to February 5th uh
do I have it that Chief slowly had
already engaged in the process of trying
to get more resources for the Ops from
not just through the weekend but right
up and well through the whole piece yeah
my understanding was that she slowly was
making
um many calls to other police agencies
Municipal Police Services across the
country and that was taking a fair
amount of time but at the end of the day
I think it was helpful because they
supplemented the resources that we got
from the opp and the RCMP and the the
the detailed resources plan that that
the chief provided and his team provided
on on the 6th of February as you told
the commissioner set out not just a raw
number 1800 but it was broken down by
uniformed police officers a non-uniform
Personnel public order units and and
various other specialties
yes it was quite detailed and um to my
surprise there were you know references
to additional resources for jails and
lawyers and other people not just front
line officers so it's quite a detailed
request and uh that was the basis of the
letter that we sent to the two other
orders of government thank you and you
and chair Deans and certainly Chief
slowly were under
I'll say pressure but small P pressure
from your council members to answer
questions about about not just these
resources but to identify that specific
number that Chief slowly had given and
that you had conveyed in public is that
correct
yes I don't know when that number became
public but um at some point we knew it
was going to get out but I think the
concern on the police uh Services part
was that it was best that it not be
public because that shows our hand to a
certain degree in terms of the magnitude
of the police operation to clean
up our city understood and and just you
got to the question I was going to ask
you just to confirm it wasn't Chief
slowly's idea to publish that number it
was it was as you pointed out it was
inevitable that it was going to come out
once there was a
this caught in the middle status and
political requirements that's correct
okay now can I just ask you quickly but
then a couple of other things about the
the news conference where Chief slowly
made the reference I think it was
February the second it that among other
things there may not be a policing
solution uh to this problem
um did you understand or do you now
understand that what he was getting at
was the very issue about resources that
that the uh Ottawa Police Service on its
own did not have the resources to deal
with this as a matter of its own Police
Service
yeah initially I didn't
um understand that to be the case I just
thought uh he might be saying
um we need you know whether it's a
mediator or you know some other resource
to solve this and and most people I
think were under the impression
uh they were scratching their head
wondering well if it's not going to be a
police operation what other kind of
operation is there you know so I think
given time
um that makes more sense when he says
it's not going to be a police operation
because he doesn't have the resources
but at the time I uh was um
I was surprised that he'd said it that
way and didn't really elaborate or
clarify what he meant subsequent
subsequently of course he was asked
about it and did provide additional
clarification I think I believe that is
the case correct
um now
um and as to as to that issue they I
think you've explained this to the
commissioner just so that I have it it
there was never going to be a solution
to this problem unless there were a lot
more police service members than Ottawa
Police Service absolutely yeah there's
no way I think any even a lay person
like myself recognize that the Ottawa
Police Service was outnumbered in terms
of the resources they had plus as I
mentioned earlier we have a whole city
to police we can't take all of the
police from rural Ottawa and Suburban
Ottawa there's still calls and
activities that require Police Services
they couldn't all go down to the biower
market or Center Town that's why we
needed to supplement them with the other
two forces plus Municipal forces and it
it do you do you share the view that
there wouldn't have been any different
outcome no matter who was the chief of
police if the matter was the resources
yes I truly believe that we need it
um those 1800 that was the best estimate
of the police service and their
expertise
and um the in in combination we also
needed the emergency act or I believe
truly that we would have been in a
stalemate for several more weeks which
would just be intolerable for the public
and it just uh then final uh two two
quick things in if I may mayor Watson
they the resignation I appreciate that
you've told the commissioner that you
learned of it when it was announced
um did you have a chance to speak to
Chief slowly in the aftermath of the
resignation
I did uh it was several weeks later I
invited him to lunch to um
say thank you for his service I think
when these things are are done in a
public fashion it's um
not the kindest way to bid uh goodbye
and to thank someone who would served
their community and so uh I
brought them to a restaurant and we had
lunch we didn't get into a lot of the
details obviously of what he went
through but I just thought it was my
opportunity to thank him for his service
and I think you've said previously that
you regarded his resignation as a as a
true Act of leadership
yes you know obviously uh there were
concerns on the part of some members the
Police Services Board and um I think he
did The Honorable thing
and I stayed at that in um in a
statement I released
there was uh with with your Indulgence
Mr commissioner I have I have one mayor
Watson I'm on borrowed time so that
means you're on borrowed time
um could I just ask you one quick thing
please about the negotiation to remove
trucks from the residential area
um I I won't show you the letter that
was already described that you you wrote
to Ms Leach in her response and so on
but
um
do I can I have it from you that in
respect of Chief slowly
that she slowly was unaware of the final
destination of the trucks that were
moving out of the residential area
and the letter that you wrote to Ms
Leach doesn't describe the final
destination of those trucks there were
some references that we've seen in other
documents to renting Farmland to
um to leasing Farmland rather or parking
parking on the uh Sir Johnny McDonald
Highway what there was some flexibility
or uncertainty about those matters is
that fair well there was there was no
reference specifically to Wellington but
it just common sense would dictate if
they're coming down from uh where the
garden of the provinces is into that
area around this building in fact that
it would be on to Wellington because
there was space on Wellington whether
the chief knew immediately or not I'm
not sure but a senior officer was
assigned to help with traffic management
of getting those 102 Vehicles out of the
site
thank you very much and and your your
term is Mayor is coming up so thank you
uh for your public service 22 days
I think four hours
and Counting
the
Ottawa Coalition please
thank you
uh thank you commissioner my name is
Paul champ uh mayor Watson I represent
the Ottawa Coalition of residents and
businesses
um
so a few questions for you mayor uh
following on your testimony
um one uh question that you just
answered to previous Council uh you'd
indicated that there was no indication
that this protest was going to last
but it wasn't a true mayor Watson that
um we were aware that by the time they
arrived in Ottawa even that first
weekend that they had raised several
millions of dollars on GoFundMe to
you know keep providing them with food
Fuel and food and and other resources we
knew about that correct
uh I don't recall exactly
um when we were informed about the
GoFundMe the first time I had any
contact with GoFundMe was when their
consultant
approached my office and as a result we
had a discussion with three of their
senior people uh asking them to do what
they could to prevent the dollars from
coming into the community and they
subsequently I think a week later agreed
to um uh to freeze the account and then
ultimately my understanding was that the
money was returned to the individual
donors
um another question or area I want to
ask you about is
um your Communications with the chair of
the Ottawa Police Services Board now uh
it's my understanding mayor Watson that
um you and Miss Dean's the chair uh you
generally speaking wouldn't communicate
directly would be through your exec your
Chief of Staff Mr arpan is that correct
yeah almost all of the the um back and
forth on this issue was dealt with by uh
councilor Deans and uh Mr arpa correct
yes you and uh Miss Dean's uh she
doesn't have your phone number the two
of you don't talk directly is that is
that correct
uh I don't believe she has my phone
number I actually very few people do
have my phone number I never keep the
ringer on so I don't rely on that very
often but she had a good rapport with um
with Mr arpan and uh he briefed me on
any item and we did have uh at least one
team's call or two during the course of
the occupation
well while we're on it Dean French he's
he's got your phone number correct
I believe he does from my time at um
when I met with him through the previous
office okay
um you um throughout this protest you've
told us that you would have regular
Communications with uh Chief slowly is
that right yes or his uh deputies well
yeah and that's what that's my next
question how much or how often would you
speak with uh his deputies uh Deputy
acting deputy chief Ferguson and deputy
chief Bell
um more with deputy chief Bell because I
knew him better it would vary sometimes
there'd be one or two calls a day
sometimes there'd be no calls if there's
no information I often got a lot of
information uh from the police via Steve
kanalakis which was a more appropriate
route and he would provide me updates as
you know as you may know Mr my office is
right next to Mr kalaka so we see each
other literally
every hour during the crisis so uh so
you were getting some information from
Chief slowly and sometimes from his
delegates uh primarily deputy chief Bell
correct okay and deputy chief Bell had
your phone number
um I don't know if he did or not
sure how would the two of you connect
well usually through a teams or a zoom
meeting
um or he'd be in my boardroom
and what about uh Deputy our acting
deputy chief Ferguson how often do you
uh speak to her uh I don't recall I had
any conversations with her I think at
some point she was uh
there was one point I think she was on
leave but I didn't really know her I saw
her at press conferences for instance
when there was a press conference she
was often there with the chief and the
other deputy
now uh we heard your testimony mayor
Watson that you were hearing from both
the the federal level and the provincial
level that there were some concerns
about the Ottawa Police Services uh
operational plans to to bring an end to
the occupation correct yes and
um
you'd heard a little bit that uh because
of some dispute or disagreement about
the Ops operational plans this was
causing some delay in the deployment of
boots on the ground
no I wouldn't equate uh that um the lack
of a plan with the request for boots on
the ground we needed both we needed to
plan but we also knew that it was going
to require a significant amount of time
logistically to get these police
officers from coast to coast to coast to
arrive in Ottawa and get them set up and
get them sworn in if they were RCMP or
Municipal Police Services from other
jurisdictions in Canada so the two had
to go in Tandem and I think it's the
previous
lawyer talked about
the reality is that you um we knew that
we needed 1800 and we had to be flexible
enough to determine if we're only going
to get a thousand then the plan would
have to change so I think it was in flux
but there was no question from my
briefings by Mr kanalakis that there was
some argument in the command structure
as to you know what the right plan was
at the end of the day I believe they
chose the right path because it solved
the problem and it brought our residents
back to some degree of peace and
quiet yeah no no injuries or anything
like that when the plan finally enrolled
I think I agree with you mayor Watson
yeah no deaths no serious injuries and
uh given the fact the number of people
that were involved and the anger level
um I'm I'm very grateful that the police
did a very professional job yeah in a
very you know and I was like most other
I think Canadians certainly ottawans
glued to the television watching this
take place as the officers were moving
in from Rito and Sussex the Coventry as
well as Wellington Street and the
residential areas I think everyone in
downtown Ottawa is quite grateful to
those policemen yes
um now with respect to some of the
concerns or disagreements over the Ops
plans during hearing
um
there's some disagreement in the command
structure or something like that is that
what you said you were hearing
no my understanding was that the people
who were responsible for the the plan
which were the three police forces under
the jurisdiction of the Ops and chief
slowly there were disagreements I don't
know what the magnitude of the
agreements disagreements were and nor
should I be meddling in the uh the
development of a plan so this was
information that was relayed to me from
Steve kanalakis and as you pointed out
there was some concerns raised by both
the premier and the federal minister
and uh you were aware mayor Watson were
you not that there was uh you know well
Chief solely no doubt was doing his best
to serve the people of Ottawa that
during
um during his tenure uh you were where
he was experiencing some difficulties uh
with conflicts and friction uh in the
ranks of the Ottawa Police
I don't have any specific evidence of
that I think there were some Rumblings
and rumors but I I could not no one came
to me directly to say there were
concerns I think any time there's a new
Chief that's brought in from outside
there's always some degree of animosity
that people think that should be an
internal candidate and so on and and she
slowly was brought in really as an agent
of change you know we've been well
served by Chief borlow but I think it
was um
it was remarkable that we had for the
first time in our history in African
Canadian leader who would serve the
people of Toronto very well for over 30
years
and I was um very supportive of his
hiring I as you know I
I sit on the police board at that time
when he was hired but when I was
introduced to him when counselor Deans
brought him around before the
announcement I was impressed with his
qualifications and his um
way of handling himself and in fact
I think before he moved and into Ottawa
I had breakfast with him and just got to
know him a little better
just stepping back a bit about the
information you're receiving from the
provincial and federal levels about
concerns with the Ops plans we've heard
from Mr Penn that that neither he nor
yourself shared that information with
counselor Deans the chair of the board
can you tell us why you didn't share
that information with counselor Deans
well these meetings with the premier and
the Prime Minister were held as
confidential meetings and I didn't think
it was appropriate to breach that um
confidentiality but the Ottawa Police
Services Board you're aware they're
they're responsible for the direction
and uh for directing the chief and
monitoring his performance you're aware
of that yeah but not directing
operational matters and what was being
discussed by the Prime Minister and the
premier myself uh was resources to help
him implement the plan and rid the
streets of uh the occupied uh occupied
truckers so it was uh is your concern
with maintaining the confidentiality
with the the Prime Minister and the
premier that's why you didn't want to
share that information with the chair of
the Ottawa Police Services Board that's
correct you didn't think that that
information might be helpful for the
board to know uh when they're having
their interactions with the chief
no because the um the concerns that had
been raised by the premier and Ms Jones
uh were a general in nature there were
no specific
um allegations or of wrongdoing on the
part of the chief the same with um
the um the federal Minister Blair I
think Minister Blair knew Chief slowly
obviously as a former Chief of Toronto
police himself and um he uh like others
at that political level in those
confidential meetings was expressing
concern that the plan was not coming
together as quickly as possible and I
was putting pressure on everyone
to get moving on this because on the one
hand I was being asked with the support
of councilor Deans to send the letter
that we've shown the public today to the
premier and the Prime Minister and my
session really was to get the commitment
by those two orders of government to get
more police officers because we knew
full well with our contingent of Ops we
could not do the job that the public
expected us to do and that was to clean
up what was a horrific experience for
your clients and our citizens indeed you
testified this morning mayor Watson that
words the effect of that from from a
leadership point of view the more
information you have to share with
Partners the better then it's important
for everyone to be sane from the same
hymn book I think you said are all on
the same team
um
following those comments mayor Watson
don't you think it would have been
helpful for the board to know that you
were hearing from different levels of
government that there were concerns uh
with the Ottawa Police operational plans
no again those those meetings were held
in confidence and I wanted to respect uh
uh the confidentiality so that um
we could have these Frank discussions
with respect to the specifics in those
meetings there was nothing really
that sent off any kind of an alarm from
my perspective that she slowly was not
capable and competent of putting
together a plan and overseeing it uh
with respect to internal divisions
that's something you can ask councilor
Deans as she is the chair but I don't
have any inside or outside knowledge of
what was going on behind the scenes with
that command team that we're putting the
plan together I can speculate that
obviously once uh Chief slowly left the
Ops it was literally a matter of I
believe two days and the police action
started so one has to assume that the
plan that he put in place by and large
was the plan and there may have been
some tweaking by the new interim Chief
Bell but I'd certainly give credit to
Chief slowly for bringing it to that
stage and chief Bell deserves great
credit for bringing it to the actual uh
point where the police officers moved in
swiftly
carefully and succinctly to bring an end
to what was a miserable experience for
the residents and the small businesses
of both Center Town downtown as well as
the byward market Vanier and Overbrook
Forbes for the um the stadium the
baseball stadium is located
um I just want to ask you some questions
about the negotiations with the
convoyager organizers I believe you
testified mayor Watson that the first
you heard about potential contact uh was
on February the 8th that Mr kanalakos
approached you and indicated that a
police liaison team had suggested that
it might be helpful if there's some
discussions between mayor's level and
Convoy organizers is that right that's
correct and then
um after Mr canalakos had some contact
or had a meeting with some of them he
then reported back to you uh that the
the meetings have gone generally oh well
is that right so are the meetings
between uh with the first meeting that
Mr canalakos had with the Convoy
organizers third two Council and Mr
Marathi yeah my understanding from uh Mr
kanalakis was that it was a respectful
positive meeting right and um
uh they would keep the lines of
communications open
and then uh it was approximately two
days later on February 10th that you you
had your first conversation with Mr
French is that right I'm just checking
the date here and that's correct yes
okay and then that led to negotiations
roughly over about two days to come up
with those two letters between yourself
and Ms Leach that's correct and uh you
had a number of conversations with Mr
French is that right uh no no more than
two uh the first call and I believe I
had a second one but I
I can't recall what the specifics was
because I indicated to him at that first
call that the primary contact he would
have would be with Mr arpat and Mr
catalakis and then Mr Prime Mr canalak
as they took over the communications
with Mr French and negotiating that deal
with with Miss Leach and the other
organizers yeah and I I had no other
um uh when the letter was signed no
other contact with Mr French but you
know I can certainly say publicly I
appreciate uh the fact that he stuck his
neck out there was nothing in it for him
from what I could see uh lots of um
comments about Mr French himself and you
know his time with the premier but I
found that
he was acting in good faith
and that resulted in the letters which
resulted in taking some pressure not all
the pressure by any means but some small
pressure off that portion of the
residential area
you know
down by the
Garden of the provinces in your in your
two conversations with Mr friendship he
indicated to you that he he was aligned
with the protesters that he he shared
their point of view on many issues sorry
who was that Mr French he indicated to
you he was aligned no he uh he didn't
indicate that he was aligned he
indicated that he had contacts with some
members of the trucking industry
but he didn't he didn't offer an opinion
that he supported their grievances or
anything like that to me in that that
phone call and simply that he had
some kind of connections I don't know
whether he made those connections
through his private uh sector life or
through his time in provincial
government but it was very much along
the lines that he wanted he saw what was
happening and he saw that it was getting
worse
and um he
called me I I literally had not seen or
heard from him uh I think since he left
the premier's office he didn't suggest
you that he he saw the protesters as
Patriots or anything like that nope
now uh so then you you hand over the
matter the file to Mr pan to work out
some kind of uh deal is that right yes
with Mr kanalakis's help because he had
met with others that were from that same
orbit a couple of days or two days
earlier right and um did you give any uh
direction to Mr arpan to uh interface or
work with the Ottawa Police and his
negotiations
uh I didn't give any specific directions
to him uh but certainly the police were
aware that
um we had this contact because the
police were the ones that asked Mr
kanalakis to engage with uh
representatives of the the protest group
because as as the liaison team mentioned
they were they no longer had any
communication something went wrong where
they stopped talking and so this group
went in to see Mr kanalakis and then two
days later we had the dean French issue
uh so the police were involved and both
Chief slowly and deputy chief Bell were
aware that we had this call from Mr
French and uh ultimately they they
signed off on it I think Chief slowly
wanted to make one change to the letter
uh but unfortunately the letter had
already gone out and uh the police then
whether it was the chief or the deputy
then assigned a senior officer to go and
help with the facilitation the following
day uh to get the the vehicles away from
the residential area as much as possible
right so there's the there's the initial
contact on February the 8th through the
PLT the police liaison team but then the
and then the contact was with Mr French
is on the 10th and then the letters are
worked out on the on the 12th I think
finally exchanged on the 13th that's
correct
um between the 8th and the 12th do you
know when Chief slowly and deputy chief
Bell were informed uh that Mr French was
involved and you were working on
negotiations no I don't recall the exact
date it was obviously sometime between
those two dates but I don't recall the
specific date I remember
discussing it with Chief Bell our deputy
chief Bell at the time in my boardroom
uh and he had no problem with it and
um that was again sometime between the
8th and the 12th I can't recall the
exact time I don't have a record of that
so so deputy chief Bell was in your
boardroom at City Hall and was was
talking about it with you well he was
there for uh one of our regular
briefings and um uh we raised it uh with
him at that time and I I don't know if
he knew about it at that time but
certainly didn't express any opposition
he felt that uh if it helped get some of
the pressure off one of the things he
pointed out was that it Shrunk the
footprint of the protests which helped
the police in the long term
contain the situation when they finally
went in that weekend
did Mr pan have uh experience in hostage
negotiations or anything like that
uh no
you know what background experience he
had to negotiate a deal like this uh
well Goodwill and common sense you know
we're in a crisis and we needed all
hands on deck and uh he's been my chief
of staff for 12. years uh excellent
um
Communicator solid education and both
francophone and I was had no hesitation
in asking him to do this he was over 12
years he was given a lot of different
tasks and um I had full confidence that
he could
negotiate this he was dealing with
another former Chief of Staff namely Mr
French so they had I suppose some some
connectivity but at the end of the day I
think what ended up happening was that
we were able to get an agreement we're
able to get 40 big rigs 60 smaller rigs
out of there total 100 and 201 and it
did shrink the footprint as deputy chief
Bell said and it also brought a little
bit of relief for those people who lived
in those corridors on Kent and so on
farther south down Bay Street
um
mayor Watson just want to ask you just a
little bit about uh your relationship
with other City councilors you've told
us that every counselor felt overwhelmed
and Under Siege and you know was getting
a barrage of emails from from residents
and so forth
um but you'd agree with me uh mayor
Watson the the city councilors for
Somerset and Rito Vanier
would have you know really been
experiencing it far more acutely than
any other City councilor correct yes
and uh although In fairness absolutely
they were the worst hit but it had a
ripple effect on the whole city because
obviously residents in Orleans work
downtown and people downtown work in
Canada and so on but no question it was
summer set and people in Orleans weren't
having Overbrook fireworks going off
their windows and trucks outside the
door no but but also I think we have to
include councilor King's award as well
because the baseball stadium was there
and that was turning into quite a circus
as well with you know fires and so on
sure uh and you you viewed or saw uh
what counselor McKinney was doing during
the demonstrations that they were out in
the streets every day and uh getting out
to seeing what's happening to to their
residency I saw a number of um tweets
and video on uh online yes and you agree
with me that was quite admirable of
councilman Kenny to be out there with
with their residents yes I think there
was
um you know I know councilor Deans have
expressed uh concern about
having counter protests because it took
away from police resources but I think
you know both counts are flurry and
councilor McKinney did good work
representing their constituents in
during a very difficult time is there
any reason uh mayor Watson that you
didn't reach out personally to either
councilman Kenny or Council McFlurry
personally to to offer them any kind of
comfort or support about what they were
going through during the time I went
back and and reviewed that I had at
least two calls and one Zoom call with
counselor McKinney I had two or three
calls During the period with counselor
Fleury and then post the event I invited
both counselors to breakfast at a
downtown restaurant ashore support for
the downtown along with Chief Bell to do
a
our own postmortem on what went wrong
and what went well and then a few weeks
later I hosted um
breakfast or a lunch in my office and
invited Minister Marco mendicini along
with counselor McKinney and councilor
Fleury and our First Responders the
chiefs of the different services to
thank all of them for the work that they
did including the two counselors but
one-on-one calls you didn't have
one-on-one calls with those counselors
during the course of the demonstration
oh yeah I did I had at least two calls
with each of them and then I think at
least one Zoom call with uh both of them
okay I guess they forgot that when they
testified last week uh you'd agree sorry
I don't believe that that's not what my
notes of council flurries evidence
reflect
okay uh mayor Watson um you'd agree with
me that uh there's uh some uh political
disagreements in city council
every day
well Martin it's it's been you've been a
municipal politician for a long time
mayor Watson you agree with me that this
last term has probably been a bit more
uh bitter and and hostile than no I
wouldn't use those words I think it's a
lot more challenging and a lot more
pressure filled you know when you take
into account what this Council has had
to deal with and forget just the Council
of the public uh there were two
tornadoes there was a flood there was
the massive storm dorocio I can't
remember the name of it uh there was
covid-19 that was with us for two and a
half years and there was the um the
truck Convoy occupation so uh all of my
colleagues on Council myself included uh
we're feeling the pressure of a very
um challenging time in the history of
our city you know as I mentioned earlier
I was asked by um some students I spoke
to at I believe Algonquin College the
other day last week they said what was
the most
stressful time as mayor this term and I
think a lot of them were going to say
you know the truck Convoy and I said
well actually not to diminish the truck
Convoy but it was covet eight 800 people
died as a result of covid thousands more
were seriously impacted people lost
their jobs their livelihood and that was
a project that or a challenge that every
single citizen of the world had to face
the truck Convoy was a terrible
experience but it was for a set period
of time three weeks it affected
dramatically the people in the inner
core but it ended we're still dealing
with covet and we're still losing people
every day so from my perspective
um I think that added a tremendous
stress because people were calling and
upset with vaccination policies and mass
mandates and everything else and all of
that came to a boil obviously when we
had to deal with the storm and then with
the Convoy
and so just final question uh mayor um
the the city was in crisis uh it was
unprecedented residents and businesses
were suffering
um
this was a time for the city to come
together a time to put aside political
rivalries
um mayor Watson do you think you did
that uh you served your city by uh
getting over political rivalries by
bringing all City councilors together uh
whether it was Ms Deans or Ms McKinney
or others who had disagreements to to
lead the city through this unprecedented
time well I think as you know I was
Churchill I believe that once said you
know parliament in his case is not a tea
party you know people come to these uh
seats after a hard-fought election they
have strong emotions they have strong
opinions on different issues and there's
often clashes that's the the joy I
suppose of democracy where you don't
have everyone agreeing all the time with
everyone else what our Council went
through was horrific and what I tried to
do was to provide as much information
do as much work as I could do with the
federal and provincial contacts that I
had made over the course of my public
service career to bring realistic
solutions to the problem so that we
could give the city back to the people
of Ottawa and ultimately we did do that
it was not a
error-free problem-free situation and
even Council voted that we apologize to
the public which we did because we let
down an awful lot of people in Ottawa
with a situation that we had never seen
before and there was no road map to
guide us and given the fact that no one
lost their lives no one was seriously
injured people were affected but the
police I believe should be commended and
secondly I think the Prime Minister did
the right thing by bringing in the
emergency Sac because that solved our
problem it's easy to sit back and be a
Monday Morning Quarterback but the
people who were suffering the most were
the people of Ottawa not the people of
the West Coast or the east coast and so
I thank those colleagues all colleagues
particularly the two that were affected
the most Mr Speaker
councilman McKinney and um Matsu Fleury
but all members of council were feeling
the pressure because they were getting
emails from around the world
uh you know with some pretty vulgar foul
language and lots of threats against
individuals myself included
I think it's all my time thank you very
much thank you
thank you the next is the
Ottawa Police Service
good afternoon mayor Watson my name is
David michalkovsky and I'm counsel for
the Ottawa Police Service
um
mayor Watson I understand it's not an
uncommon experience for the budget for
the police to be a hotly debated matter
by Council that's correct it's an
understatement but correct
um and I know that for 2022 budget year
uh which I guess was completed the that
process in November December of 2021 the
budget uh increased the chief slowly had
requested was I believe a 2.86 percent
increase from the previous year and what
the Ottawa Police Service board approved
was a two percent budget increase is
that your memory
uh recollect that is in the ballpark you
probably have more specific figures but
there was also you had to include the
assessment growth of the city as well uh
which uh was I believe about uh stand to
be correct about three percent on top of
that
and so according to the media reports
that budget
um
once it had been approved uh by the
Ottawa Police Service Board came uh
before Council for a fairly contentious
debate and ultimately council did
approve of the two percent increase
yes there was some there were some
members of council that wish to
be engaged with this defund the police
process but the majority of council
myself included did not support that and
we felt it's important to um support the
chief's request and also uh you know the
increase also included are also included
assessment growth which I'll have to
check back but I think it was another
two percent on top of that and uh in
fact Chief slowly had requested more uh
from the Ottawa Police Services Board
but they had not given him what he had
been asking for is that your memory I
believe that's correct yes and I believe
uh Chief slowly was on record telling
Council that there would be significant
risks to policing do you recall that
um In fairness I'm not trying to be um
glib with this but almost every Chief
says that when they don't get 100 of
their budget so
um I think that's probably what he said
and
um
you know our job as city council is to
basically vote up or down the budget we
don't get into the micromanagement
because the ACT says that we can't do
that but
um you know we've I've been proud of the
fact that we've been able to provide
annual increases to the police for a
number of reasons including the fact
that our population is bigger we have 20
uh 600 kilometers of road to cover and
Patrol it's a big task and um we felt
those of us who supported the police
budget felt that it was an appropriate
amount
and uh it was accepted and um several
counselors at the time in fact voted
against the two percent increase saying
it was too much correct I believe that
is correct yes
and ultimately what it took to resolve
the protest in Ottawa was a massive
amount of resources
so you're now talking about the uh the
uh Freedom Convoy yeah it did take a lot
of resources and as I pointed out
uh we have every intention of recouping
those dollars based on the conversations
I've had with other orders of government
because it should not come out of the
base budget of the Ottawa Police Service
which is always hovering around uh
Surplus or deficit every year uh and it
took a massive not only um civilian
members but it took a massive number of
police officers on the grounds correct
yes under very uh difficult circumstance
you were called back I recall very well
the weather was miserable the roads down
in that area could not get plowed so
they were almost impassable uh it was uh
you know some officers were working 12
13 days in a row you know one of the
reasons why the chief was going out
getting supplemental Municipal Services
was to give his officers
a day off to recharge their batteries a
much needed day off yes given what was
going on on the ground correct
absolutely it's very stressful for them
you know I saw a a lot of news footage
over the course of the time where the
officers were spat upon and they were
yelled at and screamed and they kept
their cool
um and you know for that we're grateful
there were some incidents where
I felt you know the images of the police
uh being buddy buddy with someone uh
protester was not appropriate and my
understanding was that the
police reminded their officers first and
foremost they're there to be neutral and
um when they did their job they did an
excellent job and I have no problem
defending the Ottawa Police Service and
the actions that they took to bring this
crisis to an end
um and ultimately you have no problem I
take it into agreeing with me as well
that it was brought to a successful
resolution under um Chief the interim
Chief Bell that's correct yes and I
think you know as I mentioned that was
funny thing was it was that the Olympics
were on and I think more people were
watching this activity than the Olympics
because it was so gut-wrenching to see
what was happening to our city for three
weeks and it was such a relief
for everyone to see that this was coming
to an end
and it was wrapped up roughly in three
weeks there were you know um
scattered groups here and there that
lingered on I remember walking up a
couple of days after just to go to the
Rideau Center and you know a number of
people yelling at me effing [ __ ] and I
knew these were still people that were
from the protest they had upside down
Canada flags and so on so
police had to keep the presence in the
neighborhood and in the downtown core
because there were still people that
wanted to do harm to our citizens as
well as to our property public and
private
um and they really this was
unprecedented in terms of your career in
politics is that fair that's right
nothing comes close to it you know I
think back my first month in office I
was uh thrown into the ice storm that
was dramatic but it was not hurtful to
people it was difficult when people lost
electricity and so on and but this was
something that affected thousands of
people very personally and uh was
unacceptable Behavior by fellow
Canadians to come into someone else's
neighborhood and act in that selfish of
fashion and in fact you yourself I
believe as well as Chief slowly received
threats during the protest
yes and I believe some members have
counseled it as well and and I see one I
think uh one two or three a couple
people were charged and
some guy from New Brunswick was coming
down here with guns in his trunk to
shoot me and and he was arrested and the
police obviously took those seriously
and took appropriate action
they did in our corporate security the
same because um you know people had been
outside my house not necessarily
associated with the Convoy but other
groups protesting so they installed a
security system
thank you very much I have no additional
questions thank you
thank you uh now the government of
Canada
thank you mayor Watson um my name is
Brendan Vinnie and I said I'm one of the
lawyers for the government of Canada
hello
um I wanted to start by asking you about
some of your concerns that were
expressed in your conversation of
February the 3rd with ministers Blair
and Mendocino do you recall that first
conversation with that group
let me just get my chronology here
sure
yeah so that was uh with the deputy
minister
uh or was it uh just sit here
there's no indication in the city of
Ottawa or the documents that have been
produced to date that uh and Council may
have information but we haven't seen any
indication that Minister Blair was on
that call we don't object to my friend's
question he may very well have been but
if the mayor is is looking for it that's
probably why I counsel it's the February
3rd call Mayor and I'm sorry if I was
spoken yeah I said you said February 2nd
I think so uh February 3rd
um
yes the the mayor and the notes all
right
yeah the tripartite uh meeting at 5 15.
is that the one you're referring to I I
believe so it's it's it isn't too
material at any rate my point really is
that as early as the conversations you
are having with Federal Partners on
February the third you are already
understandably growing extremely anxious
to secure more resources for the city of
Ottawa right that's correct yes and you
were getting engagement certainly at the
political level uh from the from the
ministers initially and later from the
prime minister right
sorry can you repeat the question you
were getting engagement on these issues
initially from those ministers and and
ultimately from the Prime Minister as
well right yes no we had no difficulty
um having uh calls returned by federal
officials it was quite a Cooperative
relationship and and at the political
level at any rate you were getting the
commitment to do what they could to
assist you in getting boots on the
ground right well uh in theory yes but
uh before you know we could celebrate we
wanted to see the boots on the ground so
that took a longer period of time but at
the very beginning they understood
clearly Minister both Minister Blair
Minister Mendocino they understood that
we needed help and they offered that
assistance we just wanted it faster yes
sure and you um and you certainly took
them took them to be serious in their in
their desire to get you that assistance
to the best of their ability at the
political level right that's correct yes
um and the purpose of getting those
boots on the ground and when we say
boots on the ground what we mean in
those conversations
is RCMP officers working on Ottawa
streets right absolutely yes the purpose
of getting those officers working on the
city's streets was to enforce the law
right that's correct and bring order to
the downtown and the byword market and
Coventry and in your first call with the
Prime Minister that my friend took you
through earlier you expressed some I
think understandable frustration given
the situation you are in
uh with the difficulties in the pace of
bureaucracy at times right yeah I
outlined to the Prime Minister that well
we had a very positive relationship his
ministers were doing good work I have to
say thank you to the local MPS Mona
Fortier and Yasser naxvi in particular
because their two writings were the two
writings most affected by uh the Convoy
minister of Fortier Ottawa Vanier and
including obviously Vanier the market
Lower Town Sandy Hill and Minnesota
member Parliament Knack fee Center town
and uh the Glebe so he the Prime
Minister was
empathetic and sympathetic to the fact
that we needed help sooner than later
and
um
it was exactly what we asked for and uh
it worked because we saw the result the
following days uh the Friday Saturday
and Sunday where the whole operation was
wrapped up quite successfully
in the Press of events though you were
feeling a great deal of urgency and you
weren't sure you were seeing enough
urgency in terms of the implementation
of these efforts is that fair that yeah
you know what you know the interesting
thing is of course being the nation's
capital the Prime Minister lives here
the the MPS are here for their house
sittings and so on and the Senators are
so they they were living and breathing
what a lot of our residents were
although they had the luxury of leaving
and not having to stay in the Red Zone
but there was uh at the initial stages
there didn't seem to be the sense of
urgency on the part of the provincial or
federal government but I think when the
Prime Minister got engaged and then the
ministers suggested the tripartite table
they set up a structure that we could
actually start making decisions and
start seeing results so I think the more
calls we had quite frankly uh the better
it was because I think they were tired
of listening to me hound them for more
resources more quickly sure and at the
same time there's there's matters going
on behind behind the scenes that um you
know that you may not be able to be
aware of in detail and that they may not
be able to be aware of in in all of the
detail because they are operational in
nature right yes and and um you know
both the premier and the Prime Minister
indicated that um you know I should
continue to
uh to work with uh respective ministers
uh which which we did and also our chief
chief slowly at the time obviously was
working the phones to ensure that uh
commissioner Leckie knew exactly what he
needed uh we followed that up with the
letter by councilor Deans and myself to
uh the premier and the Prime Minister
and their respective ministers and we
started to see some action we saw slowly
uh more uh RCMP officers coming in more
OPP and then uh when the plan was
finalized and
um ready to go we had the necessary
resources of the 1800 in the city
to bring an end to this terrible
situation
you I think very fairly earlier this
morning
acknowledged that some of the delayers
are simply practical delays particularly
when you're dealing with the National
Police first the RCMP for example you
told us that you understood these
officers might in many cases need to
travel some distance to get to Ottawa
right yes and there was um there was a
little bit of confusion in terms of at
one point I was told that there was
quite a backlog in getting RCMP maoris
sworn in as um
peace officers I guess for Ontario
um that may have been a situation early
on but apparently they started to do in
bulk and two sessions a day so it It
sped up because my understanding is that
they would not have authority on city of
Ottawa property if they weren't sworn
ins sure and I'll come to that in a
moment but just first on the practice
some of the Practical there's a there's
an element of that just that's just
practical delay right where you're
looking at Travel the need to check into
the hotel they need to eat these things
take take a bit of time depending upon
where an officer is coming from right
yes I think that's a legitimate
um issue uh my point was though that if
we'd start at the process earlier and we
didn't have this lag time we may have
been able to go in on the second week
instead of the third week but sure it's
just common sense right if you start
something you really you finished
earlier but the question is right you
know what's done as matters unfold so
um and one of the things that would take
a bit of time too then once you're
checked in once you've had a meal maybe
gotten sleep and so forth is to receive
shifts in operational orders and be
equipped to go out and start policing
right that's right because uh the vast
majority of these officers maybe not so
much for the RCMP who some may have been
stationed over the years in Ottawa but
most of those officers would not know
where the police station was for
instance for the Ottawa Police so they
had to go through some kind of an
orientation to ensure that they knew
what their instructions were
and um you know lining up frequency on
radios and all sorts of other things
that that professionals told me had to
be done in order for the person to hit
the ground running
sure and you need then to also ensure
familiarity you need to ensure as you
say familiarity with the with the place
that is being pleased to know so that's
part of the need to do things in a safe
fashion right that's correct
and you need a sufficient number of
officers with clear roles and
responsibilities to proceed with a
significant public order a crisis in an
environment like this right that's
correct
and particularly in a place like Rito in
Sussex for example where you'd been told
about a real concern about a more
dangerous element having taken a hold
correct yes
and that was also a top priority for the
same reason in terms of the order of
enforcement that you understood was
likely to occur right so I don't quite
understand your question Rito in Sussex
was a priority for enforcement
um as uh as as the week of um February
7th for example my understanding is from
the documentation that Chief slowly felt
that was a higher priority because of
the criminal element within that
group of trucks and bikers and so on and
that was taken care of I believe uh
earlier than than Wellington Street but
it was a relatively small group compared
to the large number of trucks and people
that were in the Red Zone sure but
because of that more dangerous element
at least as it was being reported to you
that's an area where you would need
again to really assure officer and
protester safety that's correct and also
the
um the protection of private and public
property as you know the Rito Center had
been closed for something like two weeks
losing a couple 2.1 I believe million
dollars a day so it was a stun to be
corrected on that number but it was a
significant loss in the restaurants
across the way and the shadow Laurier
all were being impacted where no one
could even go near the byword market so
those businesses were suffering greatly
along with the people who live in that
area
okay now just coming back you you
indicated the the issue of uh the
officers needing to be sworn in
um and I want to ask you a a few
questions about that mayor Watson um
um let me go back first of all to just
you know you know reconfir I mean the
purpose of having these resources in
place was to enforce uh the laws here
right that's right and in order to do
that you need the law enforcement uh
professionals the peace officers who are
going to be doing that job they need to
be here lawfully themselves right that's
correct they need to have the proper
legal authority to be able to enforce
before you can get underway with a very
significant law enforcement operation
right yes we we estimated that to be
1800.
and if they did not have that legal
Authority you might be in a situation
where the operation itself might be
called into question in terms of its
lawfulness as well as any charges that
might result that's very true uh there
might be a possibility of liability
accruing to the city or indeed the RCMP
or some or the individual officer if uh
an officer wasn't lawfully in in in in
place at that point in time that's right
and our Police Service uh was well aware
of that and that's why obviously we
followed the strict rules to have them
properly sworn in and as I said
initially I was told that that was
slowing down the process but then
something happened whether they added
extra shifts or extra staff or did it in
larger
Gatherings or groups that that was
covered off and
they were now legal to operate in Ottawa
now that process of swearing in officers
to be able to enforce laws within the
local jurisdiction that was also true of
other Municipal police officers too
right such as those that came from
London and Belleville and otherwise um I
stand to be corrected but I don't
believe they needed to be sworn in
because they were sworn in as officers
in all of Ontario with respect to
Municipal bylaws though
well I'm not an expert on that so you'll
have to ask someone who is but my
understanding was that they did not need
to swear in okay and at any rate it is
not something that needed to be done
whichever of us is right about that and
you may be uh it was not something that
needed to be done in the case of the
Ontario Provincial Police right the
swearing process okay
um now can I ask if we could pull up um
ott40s 6610
uh you are of course at the Ottawa 7
emergency council meeting uh mayor I was
yes I was chairing it and quite a number
of motions were passed unsurprisingly
with respect to actions the municipality
should take in response to the Convoy
that had then been entrenched for just a
little over a week yes there were many
many emotions
I'd like to just focus on a couple of
them
the first is at page 10.
begins at page 10.
this is a motion that your colleague
counselor Dean's uh
excuse me it's the motion at the bottom
of the page
it's a motion that we asked your
colleagues counselor McKenney and
councilor Fleury about last week but it
is a motion if you go over the to the
top of page 11 you'll see that it's
carried
and what it asks is that the council
formally petitioned the government of
Canada
to assume responsibility for Public
Safety and Security within the precinct
uh and to commit to an immediate and
increased level of support to the Ottawa
Police is the police force of
jurisdiction subject to the resolution
of any jurisdictional discussions
between the Ottawa Police Service and
the RCMP right yes and that motion's
carried of course so unanimously I take
it uh one dissent by councilor shirelli
oh excuse me I missed that it's right
there in front of me up with the
exception of counselor shirelli that was
passed that's correct
um I want to know if we can to a comment
that Chief slowly sent to you the next
morning and that's that um if we can
pull up please
Ott
405837
you see this is an email from Chief
slowly to yourself and and uh and share
Dean's counselor Dean's copying a number
of others from the Ottawa place
and the city manager Etc do you see that
yeah I think if you can push it up so I
can see the full email that would be
helpful of course do you mind pulling
that down
and um we'll take a moment to look at
that mayor but my question is going to
be first of all is this in reference to
the motion we just looked at yes it is
and I'm just going to direct you to the
the second paragraph there where Chief
slowly is indicating to you and Ontario
policing is governed by the police
services Act
in accordance with Section Five of that
act the city has discharged its
responsibility to provide Police
Services by establishing its own police
force the Ottawa Police Service right
yes
and um
and he indicates that therefore Ottawa
is the soil Police Service of
jurisdiction that he continues as it's
also important to note that the police
services act defines police forces
either the opp or a municipal police
force you see that yes and that's
consistent with your understanding of
the that that's the reason why OPP for
example need not be sworn in that's
correct okay
and when you compare the situation as
you did this morning in Ottawa to the
situations that were in place both in in
terms of enforcement efforts down the
road that were in place both in winds or
and in Coots
you saw that um those operations were
able to move more quickly than you
perceived they were in Ottawa is that
fair
yes uh granted the magnitude of uh
protesters and occupiers was
significantly larger in Ottawa than it
was in Coots or in when Windsor so I
think we had a much more difficult
situation if you just saw aerial shots
or drone shots of the crowds around
Parliament Hill and the byword market
and the cenotaph and so on it was
significantly larger than you know I
looked like you know in Coots there
might have been you know 50 Vehicles now
for a small town and a small crossing
that's a big deal I'm not diminishing
that but certainly just in sheer volume
and I think if I could just comment on
this I think what councilor McKinney's
motion was trying to get at was that
there was a level of frustration that
Ottawa Police were on Wellington Street
trying to keep the peace and deal with
issues of Jerry Cannes coming and so on
and it then stretched our officers and
didn't give them the ability to go in
and Patrol the residential neighborhoods
which was councilor McKinney's true
um you know
councilor McKinney's desire to represent
our constituents and protect those
constituents and similar to councilor
Fleury we had
um you know the tail end of the
Parliamentary Precinct is in his riding
by just the other side of the cenotaph
so uh you know I think it was an attempt
at the motion to uh
ensure that we had some ability to have
the mounties come in and take
jurisdiction on Wellington
and then Wellington Street and then
would free up those Ottawa police
officers to go deeper into the community
neighborhood so the chief uh came back
and obviously pointed out that this was
not legally possible to do and then
there was the other issue that we really
haven't talked about I think we talked
about one of the lawyers asked me about
was the issue of what do we do with
Wellington Street on a go forward basis
in terms of access and so on so that's
one discussion and this is another
discussion but I
it's clear that Chief slowly was not
consulted on this or otherwise I think
he would have told the Mover of the
motion
what
they are proposing is not legal well I
think and the point he's making to your
point I think really is that there's
both legal obstacles and there's
practical obstacles to getting this to
move forward as quickly as everyone
wanted right yeah I think you know there
was the sense that well why don't we
just take the maoris and maybe PPS and
put them on the street and then move
everyone South and I think you know
Chief slowly was trying to be respectful
and not embarrass the counselor but I
think he felt an obligation to inform
uh them of the the law surely surely
um this is not a situation like it was
in Coots where the RCMP was already the
police force of local jurisdiction and
didn't have to worry about any of those
uh legal obstacles yeah and certainly I
knew uh
um the desire to get greater presence in
the center Town residential communities
and as a result I certainly raised it
with Chief slowly on at least two
occasions that you needed to say see a
large presence we keep if we keep
announcing we're protecting the central
core you needed to see a large presence
not one or two officers walking down
Kent Street or O'Connor it had to be
visible and you know again we couldn't
always do that until we had a more
police officers to share the burden
now you told us this morning I believe
that before the 14th of February when
the emergencies Act was invoked that you
in fact were not familiar with the
particular Authority that existed under
that act is that right yeah just the one
uh memo that we showed earlier that
showed that that was one of the options
I think they listed five or six options
it was very brief it didn't give any
details but when it was introduced by
the federal government and to be very
clear I've been consistent on this since
day one we needed that act
it's fine for someone out you know West
or down east to say well you know it was
Overkill no we needed that act we needed
to give our police resources the tools
they could use such as tow trucks
and so on to actually solve the problem
or this thing would have gone on for
many many more days if not weeks so I
was not familiar with it but when it was
introduced our legal staff provided me
with a copy of it and highlighted the
points that we felt we could use to our
advantage to clear up this uh terrible
situation and one of the points that
you've raised in that regard is the
important point of the towing issue and
I'm sorry Mr commissioner does that
finish this one question okay but the
the second um aspect of it Mary am I
right was that the regulations passed
under that act permitted our CMP
officers regardless of the niceties of
being sworn in to enforce provincial and
Municipal laws in the streets of Ottawa
is that fair
yes uh that was through the whole
swearing-in process to be automatically
in essence deputized to enforce Ottawa
bylaws on Ontario laws and that enabled
the clearing operation to occur later
the week of February 14th that's correct
thank you Mr commissioner for your
Indulgence those are my questions thank
you
foreign
next we have the Democracy fund
good afternoon can you hear me
I'm sorry can you hear me yes we can go
ahead
thank you good afternoon mayor slowly my
name is Alan honner I'm appearing
remotely today I'm a lawyer with the
Democracy fund I'm I'm Jim Watson I'm
not the chief
oh pardon me
I think you said mayor
oh I I I apologize I'm sorry I'm here
Watson you told us today uh that Toronto
mayor John Tory gave you some phone
numbers uh for some tow trucks
uh names and phone numbers correct okay
and you passed those on to Steve
kanalakis and City staff yes
and did you ever follow up with anyone
after sharing those phone numbers
um
no because uh once the emergency Act was
proclaimed or introduced I actually saw
the tow trucks on Laurier Avenue lined
up
for quite some distance so there's no
need to follow up because they'd
obviously done done the work that we had
asked them to do was to find trucks
you recall when you gave those phone
numbers
um Q Steve kanalakis and City stuff
well you'd have to go back and check uh
my text messages which I believe are on
on public record and the phone numbers
and the names and the text from John
Tory were on that and it was basically I
would think an hour or so after
receiving them I would have walked next
door I had someone walk next door and
give them to Steve kadalakis
I'm just asking you if you recall when
you shared those phone numbers what what
is the date do you know I I can't
remember it was probably the day of or
the day after I received the information
from meritori
and how many days was that before the
invocation of the emergency Act
well as I said I don't recall the actual
date I met with or I received from Mr
Tori so if you get me that date then I
can work my way back
okay so you didn't follow up and you
don't know how many days passed between
uh those those messages are being passed
on at the invocation of emergency act
thank you well no I just you asked me a
question I'm going to answer it um if I
had the date which I have back in my
office I can tell you the date that John
Tory sent me the text with the names and
numbers of the towing companies and then
I would have referred those either that
day or the next day to Mr cadillacus
but you don't have the dates you know I
have them back at my office I was told I
couldn't bring anything other than the
chronology
you can't tell us now
well if if I can I don't think I'm going
to be allowed to leave and go and get my
document at my office but uh I can
certainly email it to you if you'd like
to know but that's fine I'll move on
mayor okay mayor you did not speak to
Premier Ford or to Sylvia Jones about
the tow trucks
I'm sorry
you never spoke to Premier Ford or
Sylvia Jones
um about tow trucks is that right
uh no I would have had uh in my first
call with uh Premier Ford
um I indicated to him that we were at a
disadvantage because we just didn't have
we had two OC transport tow trucks and
um we couldn't even guarantee that they
would would cooperate so that was a
problem we had and um I can't recall if
I told him I was contacting John Tory
but certainly the reason I contacted
John Tory was because
um I saw the number of tow trucks that
he was able to mobilize in Toronto after
learning from our example a week or so
after and I wanted to know if he had any
TTC uh or city of Toronto and he said
they had these private companies that
came out and they um
they were the ones that whose numbers he
gave me via text message
you had a few telephone calls with
Premier Ford
uh two or three
mayor Watson do you know um
you would agree with me that one of the
biggest issues for the city was the lack
of ability to move trucks
I'm sorry I didn't hear the last part
one of the biggest issues for the city
was the lack of the ability to move
these trucks that's correct
the trucks either they they had to be
towed or they had to be moved by
somebody with keys is that right well
they had someone would have to drive
them out or they would have to be hooked
up to a tow truck and lift it out and
that's what happened with those that
refused to leave and they were brought
to a compound
you know if
sorry satisfying thing similar to uh go
ahead similar to you know if someone's
parking in a no stopping Zone we have
the ability with City tow trucks to to
tow them but those are for for cars not
18 wheelers
do you know if Financial incentives were
offered to a reluctant tow truck drivers
uh not that I'm aware of no if those
incentives were to be made who would
make them the city or the police
a good question I don't know um legally
or logistically who would make it but
it's the pot of money comes from the
same it's the taxpayers so whether it's
the city budget or the police budget
it's one and the same I was asked the
question with respect to the procurement
and
um again I don't know uh whether it was
the police Ops or city of Ottawa that
procured it Mr Cadillac is could
certainly clarify that
um I'm going to just switch topics uh
mayor I understand that someone made a
death threat against you and I'm sorry
to hear that
can I just interrupt briefly you're
going to have to wrap up quickly
um that that is fine um thank you
commissioner
um
in that case um
mayor Watson let me just ask you
um you told us earlier today
um where evidence came out that
um these these protesters they were they
were nasty
um they were hateful and they were they
were vulgar is that right yes
and you said that you saw um or you said
that they had a ripped masks off of
people
yes
did you actually see that
no I saw it reported in the media
okay
and I think he also said that certain
people were attacked
is that right uh I didn't say that no I
I said that I had death threats but I
wasn't physically attacked
no I didn't say that you were attacked
but you said that these protesters were
attacking people did you not say that no
they were disrupting people's lives
that's for sure and uh they refused on
at least three occasions that I'm aware
of that they refused to adhere to the
provincial Mandate of wearing a mask
when going into a shop or a restaurant
so you're not aware of any incidents of
physical violence from the protesters
well you'd have to ask the police I know
they arrested a couple hundred people
and charged a couple hundred people I
don't know what the charges were so I'm
not privy to that information
according to your knowledge
you don't know of any
so I don't know any
of any physical attacks
uh not to my own personal knowledge no
all right thank you those are my
questions
okay thank you next uh uh call on the
CCF
um mayor Watson can you hear me I can
now yes uh good afternoon my name is
sujit chaudry I'm counsel for the CCF uh
we just have a few minutes and I know
it's been a long day for you so I have a
number of Quick factual questions I hope
you can answer sure
um so did you ever request prime
minister Trudeau to invoke the
emergencies Act
no I didn't
uh did you ever request Minister
Mendocino uh to invoke the emergencies
act no
uh did you request Minister Blair uh to
invoke the emergencies Act oh I can save
you I didn't ask anyone to evoke the
emergencies act because at the time I
did not know what contained what was
contained in the emergencies act uh at
the time were you familiar with what was
contained in Ontario's
Emergency Management and civil
protection act
I was given a copy of it and I read it
but I I can't uh recall the specifics of
it at this point but I was certainly
shown it and was
a copy of the um the documentation was
sent to my office from the provincial
government
did you ever discuss the ACT a part of
me sir yeah
um no I with the premiere yeah or with
the solicitor general no
so you never requested that the premier
declare an emergency under that act no
my preoccupation with the premier was
getting resources namely police
resources and compensation for
businesses and individuals that were
affected negatively as a result of the
occupation those are the two areas that
I spent most of my time with the premier
and to his credit he delivered along
with the Prime Minister funding for
compensation for the small businesses in
those zones that were adversely
effective
so
um mayor Watson are you aware
that under that law
once the premier declares an emergency
the premier can issue an order
to regulate or prohibit travel
or movement to from or within any
specified area
well I'm at a disadvantage because I
don't have a copy of it but if you're
telling me that's in the ACT I have no
reason to not believe you
or that the premier can issue in order
to evacuate individuals or remove
personal property from any specified
area
again uh I'm going to take you at your
word that that is the case but I don't
have a copy of the act or the
proclamation in front of me but I did
read it when it did come in several
months ago
okay good uh mayor Watson those conclude
my questions commissioner thank you very
much
thank you
okay thank you I'd like to call on now
the city of Ottawa
this appears to be the inherent risk in
going last but we have no questions
okay thank you thank you uh mayor Watson
if I could just just ask you uh on one
subject you you mentioned
at one point that the
when you were having discussions
uh with respect to the federal
government and I think you mentioned
something about you couldn't
go to the provincial government and
berate them unless the federal
government came across first
and you also said at one point the feds
needed to do their Duty
and that was with respect to policing
right
um
how do you see the federal role how do
they have an equal obligation in your
view for the policing uh
with the province they're equal equally
responsible or do you see do you see it
differently I'm just trying to
understand
let's just say because you were in The
Province before and uh you're now with
the city so trying to understand that
relationship
I think that's a good point commissioner
in the sense that Ottawa I'm not trying
to be braggard about Ottawa I love the
city I live in but we are a little
different than most other cities because
we're the nation's capital in addition
to being a municipal entity under the
municipal Act of the province of Ontario
and we have a large presence of
government buildings and significant
important buildings whether it's the
Supreme Court or or the parliament
buildings and
um there is the mandate
objectors were primarily focusing on as
I understand it the federal mandate to
cross borders and where mass and planes
and so on
and we were caught a little bit in the
middle so I was equally frustrated by
both orders of government and I ended up
as you saw during the number of meetings
and zoom calls and so on of my constant
prodding to get them to take this
situation
to a more urgent level
and so while if we were another city
that didn't have the large federal
government presence everything from the
national cenotaph to the Tomb of the
Unknown Soldier to the Ambassador Corps
uh I think your point would be well
you're no different than a regular city
under the missile act I think we have
that special responsibility as the
nation's capital to ensure that when
people come here they come here uh
feeling safe and secure and proud of
their nation's capital
and I just wanted to get across to both
orders of government that we could not
do this on our own we were literally our
back was against the wall
uh it was a very um frustrating
experience but you know and I've been
critical of both orders of government
but I do have to say if you'll allow me
um I appreciate
um yesterday I was with the Prime
Minister and the premier at an
announcement and the premier was asked
if he supported the emergencies act and
he said he stood shoulder to shoulder
with the Prime Minister there was that
unanimity myself as mayor the premier
and the Prime Minister uh all were at
wit's end as to how to end this
peacefully without any harm to Citizens
or protesters and the end result
notwithstanding a very miserable
experience for people who lived here
during that three weeks of hell
uh the police did an excellent job
getting the the situation resolved but
we now have to remain Vigilant because
this thing can pop up at any time
yeah I guess my question was you said
the feds need to do their Duty and
my question is really do you see the
federal government and the province
having equal responsibility for policing
in this area do you see do you see that
uh yes uh for the um
uh for a number of reasons but uh I
think there it was a joint
responsibility because we needed all
hands on deck and we went farther than
just the Provincial Police and the
federal police we went and reached out
to Municipal police forces across the
country that brought resources into the
city to help us as well so the answer to
your question is yes thank you and thank
you for the time you took to come here
and good luck on your last uh
stage in a very distinguished career
thank you very much sir
so now
while mayor Watson leaves I believe
we're going to be filing some documents
sorry before we do that sorry oh I
forgot mayor Watson there is a
possibility of re-examination I'm sorry
uh it's not actual re-examination but I
have been asked to just reference the
document that mayor Watson has in front
of me by in front of him rather by a doc
ID so that it can be clear for the
record and the document is the timeline
of events submitted by the city of
Ottawa and its institutional report
correct
that's correct okay and the reference
for that is Ott dot i r dot
five zeros two
maybe six zeros but two is the last
number so that's just for the record
thank you would you like it would you
should I give this to someone uh no you
can keep that thanks
okay thank you thank you mayor Watson
thank you sir
so now we're going to just before we go
to the next uh witness we're going to uh
file some documents which is going to be
a weekly event
yes
thank you Mr commissioner uh good
afternoon everyone my name is John
Mather I'm one of the commission counsel
um as the commissioner indicated we are
now going to enter in to evidence a
number of documents and this is
something that we expect that commission
Council will do every week to provide
some context to the public the
commission has received more than 60 000
documents as part of it as investigative
process commission Council have
identified and continued to identify
documents that are relevant to the
commission's mandate
many of these documents will be entered
into evidence as you've already seen
through the examination of witnesses
they may also be entered into evidence
through reports that are filed by the
commission or by institutions that have
an interest in the commission's
proceedings
given the commission's timelines however
we are not able to introduce all the
relevant and material documents in these
manners
and some of these documents then will
just be entered through this process
these are documents such as affidavits
the commissions has received meeting
minutes situational reports other
standard records and correspondence
on a weekly basis commission Council
advised the parties about the documents
that they intend to admit into evidence
the next week
these are documents that the
commissioner May refer to or rely on in
his final report and for this reason the
parties are given an opportunity to
object to any the admission of any of
the documents before they are admitted
today we are entering the first batch of
these documents there are 447 documents
in total they include
by way of example
uh City bylaws for the city of Ottawa
city council motions minutes of the city
of Ottawa and the Ottawa Police Services
Board and letters of request for
assistance relating to the city
as noted these are documents that the
parties have had the opportunity to
review and advise uh whether or not they
have an objection and we are admitting
those documents over which there was no
objection
these documents will be posted to the
commission's website in the coming days
and again as I noted this will become a
regular part of these proceedings thank
you Mr commissioner thank you
now next uh we're uh we have a
further witness uh Ms Rodriguez
and perhaps what we can do is start that
evidence and maybe take a break and say
about
somewhere around four o'clock if that's
agreeable
of course
for the record Natalia Rodriguez senior
commission Council and the commission
would like to call its next witness Kim
ayat
oh
well you swear on a religious document
or do you wish to affirm I prefer to
swear on the Bible please
foreign
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out Kim ayotte
a-y-o-t-t-e first name Kim k-i-m
ite
I do
foreign
good afternoon
nice to see you again very nice to see
you thank you
you had an interview with commission
Council on August 8 2022 do you recall
that yes I do and um have you had a
chance to review the interview summary
that was generated from that interview
yes I have and at this time do you have
any corrections to make to that summary
I do not
okay so uh we will now proceed to enter
that into evidence it's WTS
20
and I'm just going to pull it up and
this is your witness summary correct
that is correct okay excellent thank you
uh I want to cover a few uh short areas
with you just to maybe clarify a few
issues that have come up in the last few
days you were not originally intended to
testify and some issues have come up
that we think you might be able to
clarify for us the first area is with
respect to the issuance of permits can
you confirm whether any permits were
ever sought or issued for this protest
I'm not already aware of any permits
being sought and I know that none were
issued okay
um now there there was some uh
suggestion I believe that some uh that a
permit was granted for some porta
potties do you know anything about that
there were no permits granted for
porta-potties for the city of Ottawa I
personally authorized the use of some
porta-potties at the early stages of the
protest okay but that was not in
response to a permit request was it
that's correct it was not in response to
a permit request okay and this was just
your own
um your own incentive that's correct
okay thank you
um
I want to talk a little bit about uh
bylaw and fire services and
um your your role as the uh you're the
general manager of the emergency and
protective services correct yes that's
correct and so bylaw Services reports
into you is that right yes they do
through a director Roger right and is
that the same for fire Services yes
through the fire chief Paul Hut okay
and so
um I want to understand a little bit
more the relationship between bylaw and
fire on the one hand on fire services
and Ops in the over the course of of
these events and these events obviously
we're talking about the the Convoy
protest in Ottawa in January and
February of this year
uh I want to take you just to refresh
your memory and provide some context to
Ott
2120 so 2120
and
um it's the document is entitled media
availability January 31st 2022 and
you're the custodian of this document it
was come it was brought to us by the
city of Ottawa was produced by the city
of Ottawa and you were listed as the
custodian did you author this document
I did not this would this was authored
by our public information and media
relations department however we do
provide input into it and this is a
document that's prepared uh for me for
media releases or for media events where
I may get asked questions in certain
areas and these are the uh key messages
and responses to some of those areas
okay and you would have reviewed this
document before any key messages were
delivered to the public based on this
right that's correct okay
and so um
if we look at the fifth bullet point so
there's a few questions there yes
so
it says what was bylaw's Role this
weekend and by this weekend it means the
first weekend of the Convoy since this
is dated uh January
31st
and it says how did they support Ottawa
Police and what kind of infractions were
incurred and then it says bylaw and
Regulatory Services role is to support
the lead enforcement agency Ottawa
Police to keep demonstrators peaceful by
assisting with parking control and other
issues as requested by the city of
Ottawa yes demonstrations demonstrations
yes thank you so can you explain
what bylaws rule was uh in that weekend
meaning did it have the uh the role of
enforcing as requested or could it
enforce on its own initiative
so in Ottawa we work under an incident
management system which is a document
also recognized by the province of
Ontario with regards to any type of
incident or any type of of event that we
participate in through that system we
identify incident commanders or or
agencies that have jurisdiction and
agencies that place support roles and in
this particular case has it was a
protester demonstration it fell under
the authority the sole Authority quite
frankly of the Ottawa Police Service and
we were playing a support role so we
would assist or we would attend and do
by law enforcement however we would
always report to police with regards to
what we were seeing and if there were
any potential threats towards our
officers with regards to you know
violence or anything of that nature then
we would certainly back off and ask for
police support to go in so initially
that was the mode of operation we would
report to police and we would allow by
Law Officers to issue tickets our
primary purpose was to maintain the
emergency routes on the first weekend to
ensure that
of vehicles emergency vehicles such as
fire trucks and paramedic Vehicles Etc
police vehicles can actually make their
way around the city as all of those
things were pre-planned prior to the
demonstration uh to look at every risk
and every building to identify
um how we would respond should there be
an incident at any one particular
building
now
uh 26 with respect to what to expect
when the Convoy arrived I believe the
mayor was involved in Steve kanalakis
were you there as well yes I was okay
and
um in that in that briefing or any time
before after uh was it suggested to you
that bylaw would not be issuing tickets
and Towing on that first weekend
no what happened is on on the 29th was I
which I believe is Saturday uh we
received information through the EOC
through our Emergency Operations Center
that uh bylaw had encountered some
difficulties in the field and that now
the police have established a red zone
and by law was to not issue tickets in
that red zone unless it was approved or
through the ncrcc the national capital
regional Command Center and that bylaw
was escorted into that zone and that was
on Saturday the 29th
so prior to the 29th was bylaw
exercising its authority to issue
tickets and to tow independently yes it
was with the understanding that any
single point of contact could cause a
potential serious incident or Riot and
that was something we heard regularly
from the police so we were very cautious
on that front and we advise our officers
to be very careful not to be that point
of contact that could initiate a riot
and as a result of that we were asking
them to be very careful and if they were
fearful for their safety that they
should you know back off and seek police
support before issuing any infractions
okay so on Friday the 27th when they
started to arrive Saturday the 28th
bylaw was functioning as it would
normally at any regular day issuing
tickets and and enforcing as it normally
would sorry Council just for clarity
Saturday is the 29th I just don't want
the witness okay thank you sorry my
apologies I keep thinking that Saturday
was the 20 okay gotcha uh sorry so
Friday the 28th and Saturday the 29th so
up until that point on the Saturday on
the 28th everything was
um was bylaw was acting as it normally
would and on the 29th something occurred
for that to change yes
what we mean by bylaw acting as it
normally would again is a support
function to the police I I it's
tantamount to uh if we have a major
house fire fire is in charge and they're
incident command and then the police
come up and they don't tell police what
to do but the police support the fire
operation actually a better example
would be if if there was a shooting and
there was a victim inside of the house
and our paramedic service was to respond
uh they wouldn't just run into the house
after the victim without first clearing
with police who are in charge of the
incident because the severity of it uh
clearing with them that it's safe for
them to go in and do so and actually
take care of the patient so there are
agencies that have jurisdiction based on
the severity or the incident they're
dealing with and in this particular case
a protest was a police jurisdiction so
we would take
bylaw would not report to police but
they would certainly take their
direction from from police if required
because the police were the agency
having jurisdiction okay so that's
what's decided at the outset that that's
the way it was going to work prior to
the arrival of the Convoy that's how it
always works for protests in the city of
Ottawa okay
I think that
that something changed on Saturday is
that right I received notification from
the EOC uh through regular briefings and
we receive a lot of them uh that yes
there was bylaw encountered some
difficulties I wasn't given all the
specifics with regards to what uh what
had happened but I was told that as a
result of that The Stance has changed
and that a Red Zone has been established
which is probably uh concurrent with the
red zone that was established for for
traffic management Etc and that bylaw
should not go into the Red Zone unless a
directed or approved I can't remember
the exact words used but there is
documentation on this
and supported by uh protection of the
Ottawa Police okay and when you say the
Red Zone what did you understand that
zone to be
so the Red Zone would fluctuate
throughout the throughout the protest
based on the amount of vehicles coming
in so originally the Red Zone was you
know me primarily the downtown core and
then it expanded to include Rideau and
Sussex because of the of the activity
there it also included Coventry
eventually and then it expanded up uh
south of of uh Wellington uh based on
the vehicle locations so again
um where the protesters were were
generally Where The Red Zone would
expand and contract based on police
activity and so it was fluid quite fluid
and so what was bylaws rule outside of
the red zone
bylaw's role outside of the Red Zone was
to continue to enforce uh City bylaws
recognizing that if they encountered any
vehicles with protest paraphernalia or
any type of
suggestion that Vehicles were involved
in the protest which happen in certain
hot spots throughout the city whether it
was the Vanier church or or Bronson
Avenue that if it was related to the
protest it still required some sort of
police either support or notification
that you're going in and enforcing your
laws
and when you're saying that
um there was an integration then with
ncrcc does that mean that calls to bylaw
to 3-1-1 were being redirected to ncrcc
yeah it depends on the call because some
of them were uh whether it was
anti-masking pandemic type calls or
whether it was uh you know parking calls
or noise was a big one obviously illegal
fires Etc uh so in The Hot Zone
following the 29th yes those calls would
go to Ottawa Police to triage and the
ncrcc if they were to be acted on and so
I just want to be I just want to clarify
um in your witness statement just to
make sure I I make sure that that is you
know in line with what you're saying now
in your witness statement and we can
pull it up if that's helpful to you
um but it says Ops directed the city on
January 29 uh to instruct bylaw officers
not to take it or tow vehicles anywhere
in the Red Zone without police approval
is that essentially what you're saying
about what happened on January 29th yes
that's a paraphrasing of what I had been
advised of uh through the EOC okay so
this was told to you through the EOC
best Gooding would have been the one to
inform you of that that's correct okay
and so that stance from January 29th uh
about the red zone and that bylaw was
not a ticket in tow without police
approval that didn't change throughout
the protest did it
well in the the enforcement stance
changed and I believe it was in
approximately February 4th where police
wanted to take a more aggressive
enforcement uh posture and they
established a special team where bylaw
and police would work together and just
go out and start ticketing in full force
and and
so that was called a
a quick a quick response team I believe
is what it was called at the time right
but this
throughout the entire uh protest in the
Red Zone yes in the red zone and as you
said outside of the Red Zone uh if there
was uh some sort of indication that the
vehicle in question was related to the
protest then the police would make the
decision as to whether or not to take it
or toe is that right that's correct and
if I didn't say so earlier it was
primarily as a result of of Officer
safety you know we our officers are not
trained uh to the level that police
officers are not equipped with the with
the same type of tools that police
officers are equipped they are trained
to deal with contact but move our
conflict but mostly verbal and and uh so
I mean we're very concerned about what
we didn't know right I did I was not
informed of all of the intelligence that
the police had with regards to the
element of of the crowd and what I was
basing a lot of my decisions on was
based on what I was seeing South of the
Border when you know buildings are
burning and riots are happening and
people are dying and when we were
preparing for a worst case scenario for
this for this event
that's the image I was trying to want to
avoid but to prepare for in the event
that we got to that point right and
time in the second week there was an
integration between Ops and bylaw to
ensure bylaw safety do you have a sense
for when that was do you know I in my
head I believe it was around February
4th where they established those quick
response teams and that's where they
would work together and you're saying
that was primarily for bylaw officer
safety correct it was for everybody's
safety right our concern is not just for
the bylaw officers it's my primary
concern because they're my they're not
my officers they work with me
but I'm also concerned for the
protesters safety for police officer
safety uh there were a lot of people in
the protests who weren't angry but there
were a lot of people in the protest who
were angry so you know we have to
protect everyone and When 3-1-1 Calls
were being redirected to ncrcc was that
within the entire Municipality of Ottawa
how did that work exactly I can't speak
to how the 3-1-1 story triage the call
at that point in time I know that bylaw
would have worked with them directly to
say you know here are the you know
standard you know questions you would
ask and
based on the information you received it
would either go to the police or it
would go to by law and are you aware of
any in any instances in which by law
wanted to act and wanted to enforce some
bylaw violation and they were prevented
from doing so
for most part throughout the incident
you know not enforcing what they do for
a living was a morale hit for bylaw
officers they were frustrated that in
the media they were being criticized for
not doing their job when in fact they
were told not to do their job and you
know for the for the senior leadership
we understood why that was there we
tried to relay that to our bylaw
officers but yeah there was a there was
a morale issue and a a want to go out
and do their job and they certainly
proved that in the follow-up
protests that that came to town whether
it was rolling thunder or even on Canada
day they enforced a lot of their uh
their activities then so if if a vehicle
did not appear to be related to the
Convoy that that vehicle could be
ticketed or towed
there had to be some discretion so if it
was in a no stopping Zone it was towed
no matter what even if it was related to
the Convoy because we needed to keep the
emergency routes open and they did an
excellent job keeping the emergency
routes open
um we did ask our officers to use some
discretion because you know uh the
perception of us ticketing our citizens
you know of a vehicle and then not
ticketing one because next door it's a
convoy it was just not proper and it
wasn't appropriate so we we did ask them
to use discretion and to be careful on
when they ticketed citizens that were
mixed up in with the convoys could just
looked like we were taking sides and
that's not appropriate and that's not
what we were trying to do right and
quickly it appears based on the evidence
we've received so far that there were
numerous fire code violations and other
infractions that would involve fire
services such as open fires and barrels
stockpiles of fuel illegal fireworks Etc
not just in the Red Zone but in
residential areas as well so I want to
ask about how how fire service is which
is also under your direction was able to
to exercise its function within this
system that you've now described where
bylaw is essentially integrated with
with the police
exactly as Biola did they would go
through the ncrcc there was a fire
representative in the ncrcc in the event
that there was a major incident that
would occur uh they were able to provide
very quick situational Awareness on what
the ascendant is and and how uh they
were going to deal with it from a fire
perspective but with regards to
enforcement of the fire code and open
air burning it was the exact same thing
we would either see receive a complaint
through 3-1-1 or or and we would advise
the ncrcc and they would say you know we
know we have a fire they go yeah we know
it is we know there's a fire there and
the police would actually make the
decision do we go in or don't we go in
some of it was based on their resources
whether it was based on the criminal
element that was holding the fire and
and but for the most part the the fire
took uh not not their Authority but
certainly uh direction from the police
with regards to and they did it on
several occasions where they did go in
and put out fires
um but that was with Ops support correct
exactly always with OBS support and so
if fire Services saw potentially
dangerous situation and wanted to act to
remove that Hazard they had to have Ops
support in order to do that is that
right that's correct and that was seen
with regards to the removal of the
flammable liquids at two of the sites
where there was a you know an
accumulation of quantity of flammable
liquids okay and so fire service has
never acted on its own authority like
independently from the police fire
Services would go out and do inspections
on their own whether it was undercover
or whether they were you know uh just to
see what they can observe they would
report back through their chain of
command and they would get direction
from the police on uh when can we go in
and and deal with this issue report the
risk and then let the police identify
when the police had the resources to
deal with the risk okay and we're going
to take our afternoon break now and
thank you very much okay thank you okay
so we'll take 15 minutes and come back
at 4 15. thank you
it says for 15 minutes
thank you
order a lot
foreign
if I can take you to Ott 9778
and before we do it I have been asked
um if you can please slow down your
answers a little bit I am also guilty of
this for the purposes of the translation
so I think we will both try to speak a
little bit slower if that's okay agreed
great thank you
foreign
okay and this is not the document I
wanted
9778 yeah okay well it may be that I
have it wrong here in my notes uh but in
any event
um if we can actually go down this is um
I did want to take you to this one for
something else so we can we can go to
this document that's fine so this my
understanding is a letter uh that you
wrote to Mr parody who and who is the
director of Real Property Services uh
public services and procurement Canada
is that right that's correct and what
was the purpose of this letter
we were trying to get security around
the cenotaft in that it had been
desecrated uh you know several instances
had occurred overnight and we wanted it
protected and so I put the request in
through the EOC to contact the federal
government to see if they can provide
security services and or offense around
it or that we can protect uh this very
important site
um at which time I received notice that
yes they wanted it in writing so I
proceeded to put it in writing okay so
you contacted them first and they said
put the request in writing and that's
what this is that's correct and
um did uh did they provide that fencing
and did they put that fencing up yes
they did okay and did this request come
from Ops meaning did Ops ask you to
reach out to procure this fencing or was
that something the city did on its own
accord it came through me through the
EOC which has an Ops Sergeant at in the
EOC so I believe it came through the Ops
and that they did not have the resources
to secure and protect the site and
they're asking if the federal government
could actually provide that security
okay so Ops through the EOC was asking
the city to ask
pspc to provide this fencing that's
correct okay
um so we can take that down now I wanted
to ask you about Towing and towing
capacity my understanding is that and I
had a document ready for that but it's
the wrong one in any event that there
were about 28 vehicles that were towed
that first weekend does that sound about
right to you that sounds correct yes
okay and
um my understanding is that most of this
Towing was directed at ensuring that the
emergency lanes were cleared is that
that's correct okay and uh were any
heavy trucks ever towed by the city no
at any point
um
no okay so any Towing and any Towing
numbers refers to pickup trucks and
passenger trucks essentially passenger
vehicles is that right that is correct
okay
um now
we we see later on and I think you'll
agree with me that minimal Towing
happened subsequent to that first
weekend
there was some times there were there
would be no days where sorry there'd be
days where there'd be no Towing and
there'd be days where there'd be one or
two uh Vehicles towed does that sound
about right correct and so we heard that
towing companies were not willing to
participate in Towing for various
reasons and that was the reason why
Towing wasn't more aggressively pursued
is that right well there are two issues
there one is Towing of small Vehicles we
are still accomplishing that but we had
to work within the Red Zone and the
emergency routes were staying clear so I
think the protesters got the message
early on that we're going to have zero
tolerance in the emergency routes for
the protection of the citizens and
themselves and and the buildings of the
city of Ottawa
and but the secondly is the larger
vehicle Towing was the real challenge
for obtaining those tow services and so
we reached out to well the EOC again
reached out looking for
resources we were getting it from all
different directions the police asked
the EOC to see if they can make some
contacts the police were also making
contact with various tow companies they
were asking if we had any contact with
the province so through the EOC again we
were contacting the province to see if
they had resources the mayor suggested
that you know meritori in Toronto had
contacts we did receive those from the
mayor and again we would inquire with
regards to the availability of Towing
and for the most part it was no they
didn't want to participate and initially
they were they were sympathizers for the
most part the other thing was that it
was their client group and and you know
their reputational risk down the road
with regards to uh losing those clients
uh I didn't hear damage to trucks much
but then they came out and said it was a
driver safety issue and that's what they
kept bringing forward all the time uh
following uh you know other discussions
with them
any leads we had or any possibilities of
toad were passed down to the EOC and or
sorry the work was being done by the EOC
to make these contacts they were
provided to the police and police
ultimately made the contacts and got the
appropriate toes to end the protest but
the towing that was being procured was
being looked at was heavy towing
capacity is that right that's correct
and so in terms of the other towing
capacity uh towing capacity for
passenger vehicles the city had that
right yes we we had those contracts they
were still willing to do the smaller
vehicles
um
there were delays in obtaining toes at
times and that caused some some issues
but for the most part we were able to
tow if we needed to tow smaller Vehicles
right and
panels include uh pickup trucks correct
yes okay
so the reason they were 28 toes in the
first weekend and very minimal Towing
after that there was no other day where
there were double-digit Towing it was
one two sometimes zero Vehicles being
towed and we there is a chart that will
be entered into evidence that shows that
the the number of vehicles that were
being towed every day is that because
the towing companies that had been
Towing that first weekend refused to
continue towing or is it because bylaw
was not requesting additional Towing of
passenger vehicles after that first
weekend
it's not the first thing you mentioned
it wasn't because we couldn't get the
tow trucks it was primarily because the
emergency routes were being maintained
and they were open and that's what we
normally find with a major event is the
first few hours you get a lot of people
who aren't familiar with the closure of
the emergency lanes or keeping those the
no toe zones and then you know they get
towed and then the word gets out quite
quickly that those are no-toe zones and
and or tow zones sorry and then you know
things self-correct to a certain degree
so the purpose of Towing was
exclusively to maintain emergency lanes
is that right that was our priority of
Towing yes okay so if the emergency
lanes were maintained then no Towing
would take place generally that's
correct okay
uh so let me ask about emergency lanes
then
I'm trying to I want to understand a
little bit about how they worked so the
question is whether emergency Lane there
was an emergency Lane maintained on all
streets or whether certain designated
routes were ensured that they had an
emergency lane north south and east west
can you shed some light on that yes only
certain routes had emergency lanes again
these were all pre-planned so part of
our our planning cycle and we do this
for all events and demonstrations is we
have a a city Department a
transportation department that actually
has experts that look at traffic flows
and and you know how to best manage the
traffic and and the incident and it's
called Tim G the traffic incident
Management Group and they work closely
with police to identify you know how are
we going to manage the uh The Incident
That's being proposed or or coming
forward and they would close uh certain
lanes for example Kent Street was closed
completely there was no emergency Lane
on Kent Street and there were a few
other streets like that but for the most
part we had the emergency routes that we
had identified through the 10 G group
were maintained throughout the pen or
throughout the protests so if if an
emergency occurred on Kent Street a
street that you've indicated was
completely blocked off so a building in
the middle of Kent Street there is a
fire or some emergency how would the
emergency vehicles get to that street we
were able to access it through other
streets so you know the the streets that
are running uh perpendicular are
parallel to it the buildings were
accessible by other means okay so it's
not an ideal situation but it was the
best situation that we could come up
with based on the planning okay and and
I assume then that there would be some
areas that would not be completely
accessible if if a lot of streets were
closed off completely or there were
several streets that were closed off
then there there would be at least some
buildings that would have been
inaccessible to emergency vehicles every
building was pre-planned in that they
would you know fire and paramedic
service would look at their Cad and look
at what they were dealing with in in the
preparation for all of this and they do
it for other City events such as Canada
Day Etc and and they go okay so how are
we going to get there if there's an
incident and what's the biggest risk
incident that we have in this building
so let's say for fire it would be a fire
you know a major fire and then how would
we access it and we ensured that we have
multiple access to to every building
even so one street could be closed but
you might still have three other streets
that actually you know uh encapsulate or
surround that building so those
buildings were all uh we were sure that
we could attend all of those buildings
it wouldn't be an ideal response because
sometimes you'd want to put your ladder
truck let's say on Kent Street to
actually bring the ladder or Tower up to
access certain floors and and that
wouldn't be available but there was
always a plan to how do we actually
assess and manage these types of
situations when we're faced with them so
we were comfortable from an emergency
service that we could ask access the
buildings that we needed to access given
any given any emergency okay and when
you said the cad they would look at
their own CAD what did you mean by that
yeah so fire Services as a computer
aided dispatch system so it's a sorry
can you repeat that computer computer
aided dispatch system so it identifies
you know the streets where the hydrants
are uh the the buildings the height of
the buildings you know what the risk is
for the building so
um you know a hotel would have a much
higher risk level than than a government
building that's unoccupied uh you know
or a government building that's uh not
occupied in the evenings or on the
weekends uh So based on the risk level
will dictate how many resources we
actually have going to those calls so
it's not always just one fire truck
going to an incident in fact sometimes
people will say oh my God that must have
been a big fire there was like six
trucks going to it yeah it might have
been a false alarm the reality is is
those six trucks were required in the
event that it was a real uh incident
they needed to set up there are so many
different tasks that need to take place
in the initial minutes to be successful
that those resources need to be there
okay and in this case we're
the from EMS or fire ambulance to be
able to access any points within the
areas that were occupied with trucks
there were no substantial delays we did
get some complaints with regards to
paramedics not being able to access or a
paramedic trying to get through a street
and it was taking a little longer but
we've we investigated every one of those
complaints to look at it with regards to
our response standards to see whether or
not they still fell within our response
standards and if they didn't was it an
acceptable risk you know what is it was
it reasonable and we didn't have any
high level risks that we were concerned
with with regards to any response okay
um now I just want to ask about the um
the relocation of the trucks as part of
the negotiation between the protest
group and the City of Ottawa
um I want to take you to Ott 30057
and
um is this uh is this a text message
from your phone yes it is and um and it
says Chris protester in Brackets is that
the name that you entered for that phone
number that's correct okay and who who's
Chris protester it's Chris Barber okay
and so in green
um this would be you speaking and and
the gray would be Mr Barber correct
correct okay thank you
and if I can just take you to page four
of those exchanges
so you say are you continuing to try to
move trucks today or has that effort
stalled and if we just go up a little
bit more we'll see I just want to look
at the date that that was sent if we go
up
uh yeah so it's on Tuesday February 15.
okay thank you we can go back down
are you continuing to try to move trucks
today or has that effort stalled and you
and he says we moved maybe 40 yesterday
I wore myself out yesterday with that
rested up now and preparing to get at it
again and then you say thanks Chris
um so
we have heard that there were about 40
um heavy trucks that were relocated as a
result
um is that your understanding as well is
that what Mr Barbara was telling you yes
I can can I concur with him that that
was approx or my approximation as well
at the time okay and there were an
additional passenger vehicles that were
that were towed as well yes because
there were trucks and cars and trucks
and to move the trucks they had to move
the smaller Vehicles as well and they
were relocated not necessarily all on
Wellington but they were relocated okay
so this 40 number uh refers to the heavy
trucks only right correct okay and we
know that uh shortly after this message
um the the effort to relocate trucks uh
stopped or was ended
you also had discussions with a
superintendent Drummond who I understand
was the Ops liaison to to this
relocation effort did he explain to you
why there were no more trucks being
relocated to Wellington at a certain
point
no he simply indicated that the police
were no longer allowing trucks on
Wellington okay and he didn't give you
an explanation for why no okay thank you
those are all my questions for you Mr
Elliott thank you very much thank you
okay
thank you Council
um first up is the
Ottawa Police Service
all right
good morning Miss uh good afternoon Miss
Mr Aya it'll soon be good evening
um thank you um I Am David mitchikovski
I'm Council for the Ottawa Police
Service
um I just want to um get some
clarification with respect to the
relationship between bylaw and
Regulatory services and the police and
you mentioned uh Roger Chapman is that
the name yes he's the director of bylaw
Services correct
and so um if you could please turn up
ott0359
and if we scroll down to the bottom of
the uh chain there is a draft
yeah so if we just stop there thank you
very much
um in which
um it indicates or perhaps you could
just go up a little bit more so we could
just see
yeah it's from Peggy uh starrich to uh
shizlan lamat
and you'll see that um what has been
sent is a I guess a draft uh release to
Ottawa business partners
um that has been drafted and is being
sent uh to you ultimately for review
correct
I believe I'm in the review process yeah
up further up into the uh and exchange
and so you'll see um if we look at the
um
seconds uh sorry the sentence that
begins the Ops will always be available
to respond to any issues of safety you
may encounter by dialing 9-1-1 if you
are experiencing issues relating to
covid-19 and masking please call City
bylaw 3 City bylaw at three three one
one first
correct I see that that's what they were
suggesting and so if you then
um could scroll up to the next email
just uh this is the date of Thursday the
27th correct so it's the day before the
protesters uh started arriving and so
just above that you'll see there's a
response from a Michelle
Lalonde I think at 1106 A.M
and so um Mr lalon says bylaw has one
area of concern the Ops will be
available to respond uh and sorry so
it's the same
um email and he has highlighted the
sentence that says if you're
experiencing issues relating to covid-19
and masking please call
um city by law at 3 11 at 3-1-1 correct
and then you'll see underneath he writes
his comment about I guess he has
concerns about that phrase and he says
um since this relates to a protest
demonstration covid-19 complaints are to
be directed to Ops for response
responding to covid-19 complaints during
a protest demonstration is a safety
issue for our officers by being subject
to violence we have made our position
clear over the year that bylaw services
does not respond to protest
demonstrations including the activities
surrounding it can we change what is
highlighted in yellow and then if we
scroll up above that
um you'll see
um
there's a request for a revised uh text
and then if you scroll up to the uh
continue scrolling up please
and then you'll see uh that somebody
named Tanya McCumber has said on January
27th below is the email chain regarding
the calls within the demonstration Roger
advised myself that Kim made the police
aware yesterday at a meeting and Roger
will reiterate again tomorrow at the
meeting with the police
and I take it you did reiterate that
position yes I reiterated the position
that we would not be putting by law
officers in dangerous situations that
that could affect their health or or the
safety of anyone around them and that
had been I guess the consistent position
of bylaw for about a year prior to that
it sounds like as I indicated earlier
yeah it was uh it was the position for
all protests and and demonstrations it's
I want to say it's always been that way
but it's it's been that way for a long
time as far as I can remember it
um you mentioned that there were
occasions where bylaw uh went in with
police in these uh QR teams these are
quick response teams correct yes and so
they would issue tickets for parking
noise uh bylaw uh complaints and and
that would be in the demonstration Zone
correct correct and in fact there were
several hundred uh tickets issued by
those quick response teams for those
type of complaints where they're not yes
that's correct
um and um we can also see if you can be
good enough please uh to turn to uh
10463
Ott
and if we could just look at the first
page those are your your notes Mr Ayo is
that correct embarrassingly yes
um they're pretty legible so if I could
come in a good day for this because so
many by the notes are not that good I
could just um ask uh to look at number
three uh sorry I wonder if we could just
see the date of your notes February 2nd
uh February 2nd okay perfect and number
three the market was in the Red Zone but
that zone has been shrinking as a result
of police demobilizing the demonstration
so you were able to then to provide uh
some uh enforcement uh in by law
enforcement in that area as well that's
correct kind of like what I was
explaining earlier the Red Zone would
contract and expand based on on how the
protesters they would expand on the
weekend and contract during the week
because of the amount of additional
people that would come in on the
weekends
um I understand that on the first
weekend uh so that would be the weekend
of starting Friday the 28th
um 29th 30th there were is it fair to
say thousands of trucks uh in Ottawa
I think our estimation was you know
500 to a thousand like it was it was
difficult to tell because of all the
small Vehicles as well if you if you
included all of the small Vehicles yes
it would be over a thousand uh my
understanding was after the um weekend
after the first weekend we've heard
somewhere in the vicinity of 70 percent
of those uh big trucks left
is that consistent with your
understanding the consistent number
throughout the following weeks was
around 400 to 500 that actually stayed
behind and those were big trucks those
were the the tractor trailers that that
number would fluctuate as well as it
would expand and contract but mostly it
stayed consistent because the trucks
moved into the area and stayed there
they chained themselves together they
made themselves difficult to move
and and as a result of that they were
there for the Long Haul so that'd be
about 400 or so I think correct yeah and
um you'd agree with me I assume you were
following some of this on social media
while it was going on
I have people send me social media links
I'm not the social media Guru that
others are but I was following some of
it on social media and you would agree
with me that there was a lot of
misinformation about what was going on
what the demonstrators uh were doing
what they might do
I'm I'm not sure that I unders that I
can corroborate whether the information
I was seeing on social media was was
misinformation or accurate information I
I wasn't I did report to my office every
day which is City Hall I was exposed to
the honking every day I did go out for a
walk and observe certain things so
unless you can give me some specific
information with regards to what the
misinformation might be I'm I am sorry I
I I'd rather fair enough we'll be
hearing it from others sure um that's
that's okay
um we did not have in Ottawa uh 15 000
hotel rooms occupied by Convoy members
for 30-day periods to your knowledge did
we I don't think we have 15 000 hotel
rooms in the city of Ottawa but I yes no
I don't think that they were all
occupied for the entire duration that's
right
um because basically the core was those
400 trucks correct
yes
um I wonder if you'd be good enough
please to look at document Ott 10103
and um if we can um
start at the top I guess this is some uh
iMessages I assume between yourself and
Beth Gooding correct and Beth Gooding is
the director of Public Safety have I got
that right that's correct and she was
The Incident Commander of the EOC
and this is um on February 15th uh so
that's the Tuesday
correct and the movement of trucks as I
understand pursuant to the mayor's
agreement was on February 14th is that
right
correct that's when it started yes to
move the trucks and on the 15th As I
understood your evidence the police had
stopped uh assisting in the moving of
trucks and were encouraging uh the
truckers to go home is that right yes
and on the 15th then you were discussing
what happened in that agreement what the
effect of it was correct with um uh Ms
Gooding
and so I was trying to obtain uh numbers
of trucks that had moved sure because
that was the key question that I was
being asked from from the city manager
in the mayor's office and so if you'd be
good enough please to look at um Beth
gooding's um
message at 1 24 PM correct
and so you'll see you're asking her
about the number that are still there
and she says I think there's about 337
uh 57 357 but the chief slowly had been
saying 400 so that there's a Delta of
43. correct yes so what I read from that
is that the 400 was the original number
and now the police are saying there's
357 So what had moved is 43 right and um
and then we see it 126
uh you tell her that what you're
interested in the numbers is the big
trucks and whether they move that's what
you want the information that's correct
and so you tell her at 1 56 if you could
please scroll down
um you tell her uh
that according to the protesters I think
they moved about
um 40 the previous day is that right yes
and she said that that basically aligns
with what the ncrcc has said correct
correct
and at um
you continue then to discuss how many
and how it's difficult
um to to count them and if you could
please look at 419 PM you have to scroll
down a bit
um yeah so at 419
um
um Ms Gooding says also confirming again
that there was some weirdness yesterday
when trucks left spaces other vehicles
got into the empty places left as the
hardcore protesters are jocking for
position
that's what yeah that's what she says
and and
um the agreement as I understand it with
the mayor was that the truckers said
that if Vehicles moved they would not be
replaced correct correct and so that
seems not to have occurred yeah my
understanding is as I indicated earlier
that while they were moving some of the
big trucks they had to move some of the
smaller pickup trucks that were you know
wedged in between them or beside them
and that those were probably the ones
jockeying for spots after the fact
and so if we then look at 457
and that same chain you indicate you're
going to report approximately 175 trucks
remain south of Wellington and 120 North
of Wellington correct yeah I believe
that's after I actually walked it and
counted them
and um if you could look at 425 please
you can just go up a bit
you're talking about
um I guess Ms Gooding is giving you the
count as best as they're able to on the
15th of the number of trucks remaining
correct at the various locations yes and
so what we see is Metcalf 70 trucks
correct
yes that's what she says and so
yesterday we saw a picture
um from the mayor's office of Metcalf
and we saw no trucks on it but I assume
that we were only seeing a one block
portion because there were about 70
trucks still on Metcalf it looks like
is that what you're understanding from
Ms Gooding yeah I I um I don't know if
this was if these were the numbers that
she was giving me before the movement or
after like these I'm asking her for the
numbers so I don't know if we can scroll
up a bit so I can just get the context
of the conversation before that sure
they're using the cameras to try and
identify you know what trucks are where
right
and so you would agree with me uh that
on the 15th there were trucks uh still
on Metcalf correct yeah I I actually
walked it and a good portion of Metcalf
was cleared right and there were a
number of trucks still on Metcalf though
correct yep perhaps South yes
and
those are all my questions uh thank you
very much Mr Ed thank you
okay next uh I'd like to call on the uh
the Convoy organizers
foreign
good afternoon sir for the record
Brennan Miller I'm counsel to the
freedom Corp which is an organization
representing the protesters that were in
your city in January and February of
2022. so just first off uh I want to
talk to you sort of In Your Capacity as
being the director of uh safety and and
that sort of things or overseeing that
department uh can you agree with me that
between January 27th and February 14th
there were over 3 000 tickets issued for
provincial and municipal infractions
and that sounds uh a correct I'd have to
actually look at the numbers but we did
provide all of those documents uh
through the disclosure process right and
were some of those tickets issued by the
bylaw office most of them were issued by
the bylaw office right and I take it
that uh during the issuing of those over
3 000 tickets uh none of your bylaw
officers were assaulted
there were some contentious uh times and
and uh so I can't I can't say that none
of them were assaulted that not that I
know of not to be enough right so you
never uh had reported you and no charges
were laid against any protest or issued
a ticket with respect to physically
assaulting a bylaw officer no I just
know that a couple of them got swarmed
but that they didn't get physically
assaulted okay so three thousand tickets
is a lot that's a lot of interactions
with a lot of protesters
and not a single assaulting a peace
officer charge was laid in relation to
your bylaw officers
that's correct
now the numbers I understand is that
between January 27th and February 14th
there were a total of 31 arrests made is
that correct of the protesters you'd
have to ask the police that I don't uh I
don't capture those numbers okay you
don't keep those sort of numbers you
don't capture those certain numbers I
don't I don't manage the police I manage
all other emergency services in the city
of Ottawa okay to your knowledge is it
not true again you don't have to if you
don't have the information please just
advise to your knowledge is it not true
that only 16 people of the protesters
between that same time period January
27th and February 14th were charged
I can't speak to that thank you
now dealing with
um some of the stuff with respect to the
uh cooperation of the leaders of the
protest as well as
dealing with the safety lanes and that
sort of thing is it not true that the
protest leaders
were actually concerned about
maintaining the safety lanes and raise
that with you they did right and they
wanted to ensure that the lanes were
open so that emergency vehicles could
always get through correct right and the
protest leaders cooperated with you and
the city in maintaining those safety
Lanes right yes right and they
maintained them for the most part yes
yeah and when new trucks would even
arrive they even organized to talk with
the what they refer to as block captains
did they relate that to you no all right
but when new vehicles were arrived uh
had arrived to your knowledge you agree
that they always organized to make sure
that those safety lanes were open yes
foreign
and you did have I believe your fire
chief even do an inspection of uh the
Coventry Street or Coventry
yep just for clarity the fire chief
wouldn't have done the inspection but
one of his chief officers would have so
there are many different Chief levels
within the fire service
right and when that fire chief did the
inspection
um he asked them not to have any open he
did not or uh uh he asked them not to
have any open fire pits isn't that right
I I can't speak to that I don't I don't
know the contents of that right
I understand that you attended a
logistics meeting at City Hall on Sunday
evening uh of February 13th to discuss
the truck's moves yeah that's the only
time I ever met with The Arc with the
organizers of the protest is it not true
that at that meeting the protesters
explained
um who would uh who
at that two
okay
that two removed camps outside of the
city had already been established
outside of the city where they would go
to
from my recollection the discussion was
around how are we going to move the
trucks out of the residential areas and
that there was limited spots on
Wellington Street so I wasn't 100 sure
we could move all 400 trucks on to
Wellington actually I knew we couldn't
move all 400 trucks onto Wellington
Street and that the agreement from as
far as I was concerned meant that they
had to make sure that those other
vehicles left town
and left the city of Ottawa and they
said yes that they had secured ground or
so and that's Farmers properties outside
of the city right so that's what I'm
trying to clarify because I'm just going
to be fair to you because it's going to
be evidence about that so they told you
that they had set up two camps in
properties they were allowed to be at
outside of the city and that they were
looking to move there
yeah we they told me that but I was also
aware of that through other intelligence
rights as well and then the plan was
that uh vehicles uh
uh when other vehicles would go there
and then there would be some other
vehicles that would go to Wellington is
that correct correct right and the city
agreed to that yes right
now if the protesters were able to move
the vehicles on Tuesday and Wednesday
which is February 15th and 16th this had
been agreed
can you agree that the result would have
been most if not all of the vehicles
would have been cleared out of downtown
except for Wellington
I can't agree with that only because I
didn't see a lot of protester move
Vehicles moved except for the ones we
allowed onto Wellington so there seemed
to be some movement onto Wellington but
no movement out of the city as was
agreed to so if there would have been a
good faith movement on both parts then I
could maybe agree to that but I can't
today right but isn't it true in the
commission's heard evidence that the
move on to Wellington eventually got
blocked
it got stopped by police yes right so it
got stopped by the police so the deal
didn't go through because of the police
yes right and so if the deal went
through
and it was followed the only vehicles
and trucks of the protesters would have
been on Wellington
I am not confident that would have
happened
right but there was no reneging on the
deal
on behalf of the protesters at the time
and that's the evidence the commission's
heard today or to date would you agree
with that yes but thank you but the
Delta was they didn't they didn't
control all the people in that block
they said they wanted to control all of
them and they hoped that they would have
all of their buy-in but they didn't they
had difficulty moving the 40 to
Wellington Street because people didn't
want to move okay but
the difficulty in moving individuals to
Wellington Street after the agreement
was announced I put to you was only
stopped because the police wouldn't let
them on to Wellington and because the
police then also stopped them from
leaving the streets they were parked on
isn't that correct no I I can't speak to
that you'll have to ask staff sergeant
Drummond on
those are my questions thank you
okay thank you
next it's a former Chief slowly's
Council thank you commissioner we have
no questions for Mr ayotte okay uh next
would be
the Democracy fund jccf
good afternoon Mr ayat my name is Rob
kittridge and I represent the Justice
Center for constitutional freedoms and
we have five exciting minutes here
together today so I'm going to plow
through a number of questions parking
tickets serve as a deterrent to Illegal
parking don't they
they do when people know that parking
illegally will get them a ticket and a
fine that deters at least some people
from parking illegally doesn't it
yes of course uh I'd like to understand
a little more about how often Ottawa
parking enforcement people can ticket
and illegally parked vehicle in the
ordinary course of business so let's say
just to pick a totally random
hypothetical example that I parked my
car this morning in the middle of
Wellington Street obstructing traffic
and I left it there for two and a half
weeks assuming that for some
incomprehensible reason my car didn't
get towed how many parking tickets could
I possibly find on my windshield at the
end of that period of time that's a very
good question and I don't have that
answer for you I don't know the minutia
of of the the regulations my background
is the fire chief and and now I'm
managing all of this but I don't have
that knowledge could uh parking ticket
be issued daily
to an illegally parked vehicle I I would
have to get that information would you
assume that probably a parking ticket
could be issued daily I believe it could
because the parking infractions the
signs would say you can't park between a
certain time period and then once that
time period lapsed the next day the time
period would start up again so it'd be
reasonable to say that at least one
ticket per day could be
that would be reasonable yes
um leaving aside the instruction from
Ops to stop bylaw enforcement without
police instructions and accompaniment is
it it's true that illegally parked
Vehicles weren't ticketed anywhere near
that frequently during the process where
were they
I believe I understood the question but
I I'm going to kindly ask you to repeat
it can I can I just ask you to go a
little slower I'll even give you an
extra minute or two deal all right I'm
trying to plow through no I know but
then it's worth of questions but it's
it's with the interpreters the time is
uh time is tight
um
so tickets weren't issued daily to
illegally parked trucks during the
protest were they that's correct
um if the city had ticketed illegally
parked Vehicles much more aggressively
don't you think that mounting fines
might have persuaded some drivers to
move their vehicles I do not you don't
think any drivers would have moved if
more tickets were issued I do not
believe that the protesters were feared
feared getting tickets or fines and not
a single driver would have moved in the
face of mounting ticketing I
I can't say that 100 but certainly in my
opinion uh very few would have left
all right
um You said on the 29th you're
instructed by Ops not to ticket in the
Red Zone without their okay and
accompaniment on the 28th approximately
how many bylaw or parking enforcement
officers were working in the downtown
area
yeah I believe that stuff's in that
information is in the disclosed material
I don't have that but it was in the you
know 10 15 officers generally work uh an
area and we would have had that many out
that day all right so if uh if those
officers were out they might have needed
10 or 15 police officers accompanying
them to do their uh work in the Red Zone
yes but on the 28th that wasn't uh
necessary like it would have been normal
practice sure but going forward if you
needed police accompaniment that might
have meant 15 officers it might have I
can't speak to the police operation they
may feel that because of the threat that
they would require more than one officer
and one bile officer to attend those
those situations sure
um I understand that in 2019 the city of
Ottawa issued about 350 000 parking
tickets does that sound about right to
you that sounds right
um and uh 250 000 in 2020 due to covet I
guess uh which breaks down to about 20
000 parking tickets per month
or about 10 000 parking tickets every
two weeks doesn't it you did the math I
I I'll agree with your math close-ish
underestimated
um but we've heard that only 1700
parking tickets or so were issued at uh
in downtown during that period of time
right correct yeah no sorry over three
thousand over three thousand still
that's quite a bit less than the normal
10 000 or so yeah yeah
um
Ottawa bylaw and parking enforcement
officers are trained in dispute
resolution and conflict de-escalation
aren't they yes they are and they
received that training because in the
ordinary course of business it's not
unusual for Ticket recipients to behave
in a less than civil manner isn't it
correct right uh and on any given day
protest or no protest it's not unheard
of for Ticket recipients to get it
aggressive with uh Enforcement Officers
is it true
uh but no bylaw or parking enforcement
officers were attacked or injured by
Freedom Movement protesters were they as
I indicated earlier not that I'm aware
of right except for the swarming and
when uh talking to commission Council
earlier you discussed the difficulties
that the city had obtaining towing
services from its standing office offer
Towing contractors and others and the
efforts made to procure towing services
did the city consider offering increased
compensation to towing services to
encourage them to provide it's not that
I'm aware of all right did the city
consider buying or leasing heavy tow
trucks we were looking at all options
you still need to train the drivers and
and this was still being viewed as a a
specific time frame right by the time we
bought a tow truck and we trained an
appropriate driver uh that would be one
truck and we needed a lot more than one
to execute the final plan right the city
never used its two OC Transpo heavy
towing rigs during that period of time
did they it did not initially they they
considered it but they needed it for
their daily operations the bus system
was still running and the buses were
still breaking down and required Towing
so and they were also from the union
concerns about safety issues all right
you mentioned that heavy towing
operators were concerned about driver
safety and that was a big reason why
Services could not be procured light
Towing operators apparently didn't share
those concerns though since the city's
light Towing of providers continued to
tow vehicles in emergency lanes didn't
they correct and there were no incidents
of assaults violence or injuries to
Towing operators during the protests
were there not that I'm aware of all
right well uh thank you very much I've
gone about a minute and 20 seconds over
but those are my questions
okay thank you
uh next it's the government of Canada
good afternoon commissioner Mr ayat my
name is Andrew Gibbs and I'm Council for
the government of Canada
foreign
I have about four documents and about
five minutes so if the seams rushed it
is
um the first document I would ask to
call up is Ott
30s one three zeros five
and while it's coming up this is the
application record from the city of
Ottawa with respect to the injunction
um
of February 13th 14th
do you recognize this document I do
and you provided an affidavit in support
of this application yes I did
and excuse me in your affidavit you
detail uh that the demonstrators were
breaching City bylaws
corrected yes and that it was stretching
City resources is that correct yes
you also state in the affidavit
um I believe it's at paragraph 10 that
you'd visited various sites observed
personally and were advised by
operational staff both bylaw and regular
regulatory services and fire services
to gather the information for the
purposes of the affidavit is that
correct that's correct and you swore
this affidavit on February 13th uh
sorry if we could maybe go to it
um it should be on about page four I
believe I thought it was the 11th but uh
down two more pages
and two more to the actual affidavit
starts
right here
and it's sworn February 13 2022. do you
see that yes I do thank you and you
adopt the information in this affidavit
as true yes I do thank you
now at paragraph uh excuse me
paragraph 10 of the affidavit
you state that you're monitoring uh
using CCTV cameras and you were doing
this out of concern for Public Safety
and uh the ability of First Responders
and other city services to provide
emergency and other services to downtown
and across the city
do you see that in paragraph 10
yes
yes and so if we turn to would you based
on the information that's in this
affidavit would you agree that the
situation in downtown Ottawa at that
time was fluid very fluid yes and
volatile yes and unpredictable correct
if you turn to page 37 please
this is a series of photographs of
exhibit a unfortunately it's on its side
um
this is one of the photographs taken
from the CCTV cameras is that correct
correct and in the bottom left hand
corner
it states the location
yes Wellington Metcalf in Wellington
metcaline Wellington and the top left
hand corner the date
correct February 5th February 5th and
it's I believe 2 p.m correct
what is the white bar that we see in the
middle of the photograph
that's a boom or a it's a crane
that's that's a large crane is that an
industrial crane uh that's an industrial
crane yes and are all those trucks in
the background is that the lineup of
trucks on Wellington that's correct
and did you know what was in those
trucks
uh no
now if we go to page two I'll just move
off of this document but I would like to
go to page two where the list of
exhibits are included and I would
commend this to the commission this
entire affidavit with the exhibits there
are a series of photographs of fuel
Depots at uh Coventry Road the rcg GT
Park
you'll see exhibit D photographs of
fires and fuel stockpiles at
Confederation Park
exhibit e the bylock call logs and fire
complaints dated February 4th to 12th to
2022
exhibit F CCTV images of fireworks on
February 5th 2022
and exhibit G and so forth are the
details with respect to call logs is
that where the various complaints are
registered for open fires correct and
parking violations yes
thank you so in the interest of time I
would now like to move to three quick
documents
if we can bring up Ott four zeros 4061
you had mentioned earlier that your
officers were directed not to ticket in
the red zone is that correct
yes correct
and you'd mentioned that that really
came into play on February 4th
no the 29th of January 29th a chain okay
this email is from February 4th Roger
Chapman he reports to you yes he does
and he States specifically if you look
at the second paragraph
first and foremost our top priority and
responsibility is ensuring the safety of
Staff as you have no doubt gathered this
is a potentially volatile situation and
there is a significant difference
between ticketing illegally parked
vehicles and ticketing a person for a
violation where the latter presents a
much greater risk of Confrontation
do you see that yes and do you agree
with those statements yes I do and in
response to the questions you just
received from my friend Mr Miller with
respect to the lack of tickets or the
number of tickets and very little
charges laid for assault
would you agree that where the uh the
directions to the officers were to
ticket vehicles and not people that is
one possible explanation for that
discrepancy correct thank you
skipping right to the bottom uh again
officer safety is our first priority and
therefore we will not be enforcing other
bylaw violations in the demonstration
Zone at this time demonstration Zone
that's the Red Zone correct thank you
next document
ott406781 please
these are listed as updates
e0ccg update 15.
from yourself correct do you recognize
this document yes I do and would you
agree that the purpose of this document
was to provide accurate and timely
information to your city colleagues yes
to my city leadership team your city
leadership team thank you the date of
this email is Friday February 11 2022 at
7 53 PM yes and in the third paragraph
we see evidence of external influence
persists the hospital the Ottawa
Hospital has received some disturbing
calls mostly from the United States
which have been reported to police
p-i-m-r what does that stand for public
information and media relations thank
you has paused public comments on the
city of ottawa's corporate Facebook and
Instagram accounts for the duration of
the city's State of Emergency due to an
apparent coordinated effort to spam the
city's feed with hateful or toxic
comments including racist comments or
misinformation and rumors was that
accurate information yes it is thank you
last very quickly document
ott408754
this is the operational update 24 on
February 22nd
and we have that document please it's
8740.
and it references on the third paragraph
This is again from you you recognize
this yes thank you
Chio received a false bomb threat
yesterday evening can you remind uh the
commissioner what Chio stands for it's
the Children's Hospital here in Ottawa
so the Children's Hospital received a
bomb threat
while false calls to 9-1-1 have been
reduced there are indications that
outside interference persists
is that correct there was a bomb threat
to the Children's Hospital on February
22nd yes there was now Mr ayat do you
have any evidence that that bomb threat
was connected to the Convoy no
would you agree
that that was part of the challenge in
these events correct we received
a tremendous amount of increased 911
calls that were also false during this
time higher than normal amounts of 9-1-1
calls so we suspected that that it was
related
and the mayor had testified earlier
today to what he referred to as
whack-a-mole
is it not correct and fair to say that
you couldn't tell what was coming next
I I think for the most part yeah we we
didn't know where they were going to go
we were trying to be strategic but it
was a difficult uh it was a difficult
time thank you very much those are my
questions thank you
okay next is the coalition
we have no questions thank you
commissioner okay thank you next is the
ccdl and CLA
good afternoon or almost good evening
star yet my name is Colleen McEwen and
I'm counsel to the criminal lawyers
Association and the Canadian Council for
criminal defense lawyers these are two
organizations comprised of criminal
defense lawyers
many of the questions I have for you
have already been canvas so I've been
trying to tailor them as we've gone
along
if I could just pick up on some
questioning you had you got earlier
about sort of the number of tickets
overall over the course of a Year my
friend said perhaps it was 300 000 or
250 000 and you said you didn't have the
numbers in front of you but you know
that that was sort of about right
is that right yes
and he gave you an estimate that that
could mean something like 20 000 tickets
being issued monthly is that right
yes
and my understanding um not having seen
these figures myself but this would be
for across the whole city that's correct
is that right correct
um but is it still your view then that
the 3 000 tickets that were issued over
the course of the demonstration in the
demonstration uh zone are related to the
demonstration that this would be a uh
sort of a smaller fraction of tickets
that bylaw Services would have had the
capacity to issue
yes but there were a lot more
infractions in that zone that could have
been ticketed
right so so there were many
dimensions and this is a smaller number
than the tickets
but for the safety concerns you've
already described correct
uh and I understand that
um that bylon regulatory Services
received an approval for an increase to
the set fines for various bylon
fractions on February 8th does that
sound right yes
and I know you've already adopted uh the
contents of the affidavit that you swore
as part of the city's injunction
application uh in the course of
questioning by another Council
um so I'll just draw your attention that
you said in that affidavit that you
didn't think that these increased fines
had any impact on the ongoing bylaw
violations uh is that right that's
correct
and that was the affidavit you swore on
February 14th and I take it that your
opinion didn't change after uh you swore
the affidavit that there wasn't some
change after that fact my opinion hasn't
changed in the affidavits was sworn on
February 13th
right and yes and after February 13th
there wasn't um those those changes from
February 8th uh you didn't change your
opinion of whether they had an impact
no my opinion Remains the Same
okay uh thank you very much those are my
questions thank you thank you
uh and now the city of Ottawa
thank you commissioner Alyssa Tompkins
Council for the city of Ottawa Mr ayat I
just have a few questions today uh you
had mentioned in your evidence that
there was a document that reflected the
direction to bylaw or to the to the EOC
through the EOC on January 29th I'm just
going to take you to that for the record
yes so if we could turn up document Ott
zero zero zero zero one two seven zero
and if we could just scroll next page
please
under number three under Section updates
uh there's a comment from a Jay gravel
who's J gravel do you know Jay gravel is
one of our uh commanders in the incident
management system so he used to work for
bylaw services and and now he works for
Rhodes okay and uh it says here
blrs were experiencing issues a
perimeter Red Zone has been established
if blrs are required to enter that zone
as directed by the ncrcc they'll be
provided police escort and then we have
a comment from Kay Cochran can you
remind the commissioner who is Kay
Cochran
Kelly Cochran she's part of our EOC
staff
I say it's police advising blrs to
withdraw Services if they are accounting
concerns will provide escorts on an
accident basis is is this the direction
to which you were referring earlier yes
correct okay thank you
um there was a couple incidents
discussed last week in the evidence
involving the shadow Laurier and the
Rito Center and I was just hoping you
could provide the commissioner with
additional information on that so
starting with the shadow Laurier are you
familiar with the concern that was
raised yes it was raised directly to me
and we had it investigated uh can you
can you explain to the commissioner what
happened and and uh what the city's
follow-up was certainly uh basically
there was an alarm for a water leak or a
sprinkler head that had been knocked off
and and so it was an alarm call for for
the fire service we the fire service
responded with four different trucks
from different directions from different
fire stations which is normal from a
deployment of our resources perspective
we don't respond with just one truck we
respond with multiple especially for a
high risk setting like a hotel
on arrival one of the trucks you know
got close enough but didn't get very
close and that's what was observed by
the hotel and I thought oh my God if
there's an emergency you know they can't
get in here the reality is there was
three other trucks responding people
were the responders were already in the
hotel dealing with the incident there
was no delay in response
uh so you know this was a heightened a
time where people were very aware of all
kinds of different issues and it was
being raised through us through the bias
and hotel association that these types
of concerns needed to be addressed
because of Public Safety their liability
insurance Etc so while I understand
their fear the risk of this call was
very low and we had pre-planned that
facility daily and we've had
conversations with the managers since so
really from a risk perspective it was a
relatively low risk event but it did
highlight that uh you know if there was
a fire uh you know we may not get all
four trucks there immediately and there
would be some need for movement of the
protest vehicles uh so while it was an
incident that was looked at it wasn't
deemed as high risk as it was being
first explained to us
thank you Mr Ai and um in relation to
the Rito Center incident might be
helpful if we bring up uh some the email
correspondence uh if someone could turn
up uh document ott408284
so this is your an email exchange
between you and counselor Floria do you
recall this exchange yes I do
and
um we had seen uh your response or the
draft response prepared last week but if
if we could scroll down and and you
could just explain the response
um to the commissioner
yes can you just go up a bit so I can
see what where that's from from Jennifer
Turlock okay now you can go back down
so in this particular case you know it's
a private property so they could request
that bylaw come and remove illegal
Vehicles it was a truck
um a construction type truck that had a
legal
um diesel container in it uh so the fear
of it you know as counselor Fleury
indicated last week you know we should
have evacuated the the Redo Center well
that's not accurate because the risk was
still very low so in this particular
case the police attended initially uh
looked at the truck spoke to the owner
told him he'd have to move it or be
getting a ticket uh bylaw eventually
went out and gave them a ticket Rito
Center wanted it removed it was one of
those times when getting a tow for a
small vehicle was more difficult more
challenging for us and as a result of
that it took some time for us to secure
the tow vehicle to come and actually
remove it from the Rideau Center and
when it finally uh when the tow truck
was finally on wrote uh the owner moved
it himself so the reach Center was
frustrated that it took you know a day
and a half to actually deal with this
issue but again when we're dealing with
the the whole protest we're looking at
risk and we're looking at risk-based
responses as well so yes there are you
know the counselor was concerned about
them the amount of layers with regards
to us having to get the police involved
and the police coming back and then
police saying they can't escort by law
because they don't have the resources
and I could understand that frustration
and I could understand the Rito Center's
frustration they had they have valid
concerns
from a risk perspective this was also a
very low risk incident
thank you Mr ayat the last thing I was
hoping you could assist the commissioner
what with is the movement of trucks
subsequent to the mayor's deal you
mentioned during your evidence that you
went for a walk and observed the
movement if you could just uh explain to
the commissioner what you observed on
your walk on the various streets
yeah so yes certainly
um I I um I went down to Wellington just
to see you know how much trucks had been
moved and I noticed that they'd have
they hadn't just been moved but they've
been placed in a in a in a in a row
where they can park a lot more of the
trucks and I think that uh they were
doing that to try and get as much uh as
many of the trucks on Wellington as
possible and uh so there was still quite
a bit of room from you know Wellington
from let's say uh Kent Street right down
to sgm with regards to you know the
ability to park more trucks uh Metcalf
was uh cleared for the most part uh
again there may have been a few
scragglers here and there uh you know
south of Laurier uh but Kent was still
packed so when counselor McKinney was
walking down Kent Street she was right
there was no movement of any trucks on
Kent Street in fact Kent didn't clear
out until the police started their
action to actually with the public order
teams to move out and then the trucks uh
moved out quite quickly uh and uh but
yeah so my walk was to just I try and
identify
has any progress been made and is there
still room and are the protesters
actually moving out as well or are they
just trying to move everything to
Wellington Street and it was my my
perception I guess that I didn't see a
lot of trucks leaving town I just saw a
lot trying to get on Wellington Street
and again I can't speak for uh officer
Drummond and and the reasons for uh
stopping it but I suspect that it might
have something to do with that as well
and the negotiation and the ability of
of both sides to be able to you know the
give and take Factor so
excellent uh those are my questions
thank you very much Mr ayat thank you
thank you Mr uh yet I just just want to
make sure I understood what you said
about the uh the fire issue with the
Chateau
and you said they dispatched four fire
trucks yes that would be the appropriate
number of trucks or was that More Trucks
Than what the appropriate response is
that is our deployment for a an alarm
call okay so for in this particular case
it was an alarm call General alarm so
just so I understand so the
when you say it wasn't a high risk it's
because it was a broken
fire plug if you like or yeah sprinkler
uh sprinkler but if there had been a
real fire
that would be a real problem having
not all of the trucks
that were dispatched and presumably
there would be more trucks dispatched if
it were a real fire correct what how how
it unfolds is depending on the
information that the 911 or that the
Dispatch Center the Ottawa fire dispatch
Center receives you know if it's just a
general alarm then we proceed with our
staffing for a general alarm and that's
enough to get things started and then if
it is a fire other rigs would be coming
in and they would continue to come in so
that's a general alarm assignment
um having having uh if it was a fire if
the information came in that we actually
have a fire in one of the rooms there
would have been several more Vehicles
responding because it's a high risk we
would had 25 firefighters in total
responding so you're looking at eight or
nine rigs responding and I guess all I'm
trying to understand is
the inability of some rigs to get there
would have been a bigger problem
if there had been a real fire because I
think what I'm trying to understand is
whether when you said it wasn't serious
it's because it wasn't a real fire but
access would have been limited if there
had been a real fire of course yes and
that would have been a big problem and
that was the concern of the Chateau
Laurier but they were they were
portraying it as a oh my God they
couldn't get in at all well that was one
of the four trucks the other but you're
not saying it wasn't a problem no I'm
saying it's a problem it was a problem
everywhere with the congestion ideally
there's a reason why we have large roads
so that we can get the trucks set and
the same thing for Kent Street if
there'd been because we saw I think
yesterday
apartment buildings on Kent Street that
were inaccessible
because Kent was blocked that would have
been a serious problem if there'd been a
serious fire no doubt and and we planned
for those but again uh we were lucky
there were no serious fires okay uh I
thank you for coming there's just one
more you may have some re-examination no
there is no re-examination so we're done
for the day and we want to thank you for
for coming thank you and uh testifying
today
and thank you all for uh ending it a
little earlier than I thought uh and uh
we are back tomorrow at 9 30.
the commission is a journey
wait